a couple minutes
morning everybody about two minutes
we'll uh get started here
uh representative Brown could you double
check to see if we've got any pink cards
and all that so yeah
okay all right that's fine
okay good morning everybody it's close
enough to 10 we're going to get going
here we'll uh start with the pledge of
Representative Brown why don't you lead
us this morning
okay we're going to ask the clerk to
call the roll please
okay uh Jim and turquoise
here
about human power present clerk is here
represents Guthrie
representative silence here
represents uh your color
representative Kelly
representative Alward here
representative Brown
representative Cahill here
representative Davis here
uh representative
here
representative 11.
representative Gilman
representative majority here
here representative
representative Gallagher representative
Hicks
representative Howland
and representative priests thank you
thank you for the roll call we do have
obviously a quorum and uh we'll go ahead
and open up the
carrying on Senate Bill 88
and we have uh Maya Harvey who will be
introducing the bill
good morning chairman turcotte and
members of the municipal and County
government committee I'm Maya Harvey
from the New Hampshire Senate here to
introduce Senate Bill 88 on behalf of
Senator Regina bartsell the Bill's Prime
sponsor
local officials participate in a number
of town officers associations New
Hampshire Association of assessing
officials New Hampshire City and town
clerks Association New Hampshire Tax
Collectors Association
the annual fee for membership in each of
these organizations is capped at just
twenty dollars per year
that has been the same since 1977.
adjusting for inflation
that would be over a hundred dollars
today
SB 88 would raise the cap to a maximum
of fifty dollars per year and give each
of these associations the ability to
raise their fees to better meet their
expenses
while Senator bird cell opposes just
about every tax or fee increase she's
ever seen she thinks this is a
reasonable adjustment given the
inflation we've experienced in the past
few years
Senator bird cell thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
88. thank you
anybody have any questions on the
committee
representative lasalles
yes
I see that there are these three
associations
are specified
is it possible that there are other
associations that fall in the same
category
so I will be able to take um any
specific questions to Senator bird cell
but I'll have to defer um to her for the
response so I can get back to you on
that
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my my question my question
um
is
is this fee per municipality or is it
per member that might be accessing the
association
that is employed by the municipality
again I will defer to Senator Regina
bird cell and I will have her get back
to you with a response
now it is
all right something's going on with the
okay
um somebody uh representative
thank you Mr chairman good morning and
welcome
um do you have in line number two the
definition of Equitable taxation
thank you for your question
um I will defer to Senator Regina
bartzell and have her get back to you
with a response thank you
hey representative majority how are you
um welcome back yeah go ahead
thank you Mr chair and it is great to be
back um I guess this would be a question
to take but well I guess it's a general
question can legislation have an
adjustment factor in it or does it have
to be a fixed number I assume an
adjustment indicator would bind another
legisl body and I don't know that you
can do that and the only reason I asked
that question is I wonder you know in a
few years is 50 going to be enough and
we're going to have to come back again
so does the question make any sense and
I'm not even sure that it's directed
appropriately
sure and thank you for your question
um I will defer to Senator Universal and
have her get back to you with the
response
I think uh I'll take a stab at it I I
think it's safer to do what we do here
is increase to a certain number if you
put an adjustment factor in there
whether it's inflation or whatever like
that you're going to end up with numbers
like
52.66 and that kind of thing so I think
that has been the historical way of
doing it is actually just adjusting the
number that's my assumption any further
questions
I have one and I know this will be for
Regina Bert cell Senator
um
I'm sure you're taking notes on the
question uh somebody uh one of the other
reps asks about uh the three
um
associations that are named and are
there any others my question is why
those specific three
and I know they're already in the
existing language as is the word
Equitable so that's existing but just
for our edification why those those
exact three that are mentioned that'd be
helpful okay thank you I will have her
follow-up thank you representment
representative velvet
thank you Mr chairman
um again online
it reads shall be entitled to receive
their actual expenses incurred in
attending the annual Convention of their
respective associations
why should taxpayers be responsible for
for that activity
thank you for your question I will have
the senator follow-up
just a point for everybody uh on the
committee
only the Bold
in the bill is what is changing all the
other uh wording that is there is
existing language already there is no
bold
the only bold in this one is the dollar
value
20 scratched out and 50. my apologies
it's fine just no apology needed just
pointing it out that
that's why
um
well I'll leave it at that
further questions
representative Brown I saw your hand up
no
uh Mr chairman thank you uh I guess
along those same lines I was wondering
why it says shell pay uh but based on
what you just told me it's uh existing
language so that's correct those type of
issues if
if individuals on the committee have
issues with the wordings it that would
be good or potential legislation for
next for next uh next year you know if
you see something you don't like
pointed out get a bill drafted and
make changes for it okay
thank you Maya
thank you
okay we have one other
pink card on this this is uh Dan Healy
good morning members of the committee uh
Dan Healy second vice president of the
New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association we had asked Senator bird
cell
to submit this legislation to up the fee
to up to fifty dollars I'm not sure what
our association's actually going to do
if they're going to make the jump to 50
or if we're going to stagger it or what
I believe 50 would be plenty for
probably many years to come I don't
believe we need to come back to adjust
that any higher I can answer some of the
questions that were opposed so the
annual fee for membership is it's it
covers the office so it would cover the
town clerk or city clerk in the deputy
Clerk of that town so not each person
doesn't have to pay for a membership
ship it covers that office
so we are in support of this bill since
we requested it and I'd be open to any
other questions
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
we have no uh other pink cards we have
nobody signed up on the blue sheet so
with that we'll close the hearing on it
SB 88.
and we have about three or four minutes
before we go on to our next one
okay it is 10 15 we'll go ahead and open
up the next Herring on Senate bill 111.
and call the prime sponsor Senator
Perkins guaca hope I pronounced that
right
good morning chairman and uh it's a
Polish last name so if it helps it
rhymes with polka laughs
um
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record I am
Senator Rebecca Perkins quoka
representing Senate District 21 the city
of Portsmouth and several surrounding
communities I'm here today to introduce
SB 111 and act relative to the Town
Council Town manager form of government
SB 111 is a request of the town of
Newmarket and the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and serves to
clarify the responsibilities and
obligation of municipalities that have
adopted the Town Council Town manager
form of government this helps to clarify
issues that have Arisen in the
day-to-day management of the
municipality where it is unclear if they
have certain authorities to act in the
exact same manner as a city council
the committee Amendment
um that arose in election law over on
this Senate side was raised by the
Secretary of State and it was just to
ensure that town clerks as Chief
election officers and municipalities
will continue to be elected positions
regardless of this statutory
clarification so that was one piece that
was different between cities and towns
and so
um we wanted to clarify that on behalf
of the secretary of state which is
reflected in the version before you as
amended by the Senate
um SB 111 then passed out a committee
unanimously and passed on the Senate on
a Voice vote so just to clarify you know
the point of the bill is to make sure
that all town councils have the same
Authority as City councils happy to take
any questions
thank you are there any questions
representative Kella
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question
um do you know what
um
the we are seek seeking to clarify what
was the
misunderstanding I guess
um in New Market that they thought that
they might not have the power
um under the current law and that that
this would help clarify
that's a very good question
representative um and I probably knew
the answer to it about six months ago
but
um I think in general it's just to to
make sure that they're not acting
outside of their Authority on it on a
day-to-day basis thanks
further questions
representable Salas
thank you for taking my question and you
you may have alluded to it in your
opening there but I noticed that the
initially that the um secretary of state
did have some some issues and do you
know that the bill as amended now
satisfies the Secretary of State I do
representatives so the issue that was
raised was that the Secretary of State
wanted to ensure that the town clerk
would be elect an elected position
regardless of this change and so
um under city council operation the town
clerk is appointed okay and so this
statute essentially says town councils
can act under the same authority of city
councils with the exception of this
procedure related to the town clerk so
that satisfied the Secretary of State it
did sir thank you thank you very much
uh representative Gallagher
so you mentioned this affecting New
Market and
um one other town which I've already
forgotten but Durham yeah New Market and
Durham um so I was wondering if there
were any others with this form of
government that would be affected as
well
that's a great question I am going to
defer that to the municipal Association
there are no other ones in my district
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um my question is I'm having difficulty
seeing the need for for this particular
bill
in that
um
RSA 49 Dash D colon 1 which defines the
purpose and intent which is the section
of Statute right before the section of
Statute that this bill seeks to
to clarify to me when I read that prior
section it's very clear that it says
that Alternative forms of governance of
towns
which have the same or similar Powers
traditionally found in cities to me that
that reads very clear as to what the the
um this bill seeks to do could you
expound on why this bill therefore is
necessary sure and I
um I'm likely going to defer to the
folks behind me there's someone here
from Durham and someone from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association to
address that in more detail
thank you
okay see no more questions thank you for
your testimony thank you uh next we'll
call Representative uh Tim Horgan
thank you very much I'm representative
Timothy Horgan from Durham which
actually is I believe
I believe there's two towns that
currently have a charter which is Durham
and then Jerry but I I could be you
probably want to verify that but we've
had this for uh
many years and it's worked very well I
think it's uh I think for a growing I
think for uh with a growing complexity
of municipal government it's a
I think it's a good alternative to the
traditional town meeting and select
board process and there's still like I
think if anything there's probably
the people have more more input into
what the Town Council does into what the
select board does in the traditional
town meeting and it's a more responsive
form of government so if you have a town
that's like Durham that's
it's only big enough to require a uh a
professional uh Town Administrator and I
don't always agree with everything he
does but he's done an excellent job so I
think it's just it's a more efficient uh
way of governance and it's a
it's not as complicated as changing your
uh
changing your town to a city which I
believe no Community has done since I
think
Lebanon was the last one that did it did
it which was some decades ago um
I mean a simpler approach
um I mean the alternative approach might
have been like for example that state to
our South where they just allow
towns to become cities and then just
issue a city Charter that for example uh
I think my sister lives in Needham so I
think their City charger if I recall
correctly uh says something this city
which shall be known as the town of
Needham so I mean that would have been
another approach but this is uh
this is what we did a number of years
ago and I think it's a
I think it's a very excellent reproach
it's uh and it allows a certain amount
of flexibility for the town
um you can have a representative town
meeting or just what they call budgetary
town meeting or a Town Council Town
manager and former government it's not
really much different than a city
manager city council a form of
government and the
significance is a detail about the town
clerk I believe is that uh
a city clerk is appointed by uh is well
I guess they can be elected but
typically they're appointed and they
report to the mayor and of course in a
town even a town that has a Town Council
and a town manager former Governor
they're uh
is no there is no mayor you know the
chairman of the Town Council is not a
mayor they're just a chairman of the
Town Council so uh the town clerk
reports to the people so therefore it's
appropriate to have uh
when Durham it's been a woman forever so
say her um
elected by the people and of course in
cities they have one or more Awards and
they have a clerk and they also have a
Selectmen too who are powers are pretty
much limited to running the election so
that's uh
and whereas whereas in a town you have
a town that has a charter the slick
board is basically the Town Council has
all the powers of that the select board
would have and then so then it's
appropriate the town clerk to be elected
just as in other towns but that's um
anyway that's why I that's why that's
why I support the bill and um I probably
would defer any technical questions to
the uh
Municipal Association although I guess
you can ask me if you feel like it
thank you for your testimony and
questions
yes anyway I highly recommend I think it
works better than the select board for
most communities thanks thank you
uh we have one more pink card nature
Grace
thank you Mr chair and H Grace for the
municipal Association we support this
bill as I as already stated by Senator
Perkins quokka this came at the request
of one of our members and was adopted
actually as part of our uh policy
package that we are asked to advance
back in September of 2022.
um so there were a couple questions the
committee asked that I want to clarify
as far as the Town Council
um forms of government those include
Bedford Dairy Dover Durham hook set
Londonderry Merrimack New Market and as
of well March uh I believe Salem adopted
it as well so they're going through that
process right now
um
so it's not very many communities
I believe representative power asked a
question about why is this Clarity
needed
the town of Newmarket the town manager
submitted a electronic letter to you
hopefully last night
that just clarified there there were a
couple issues relative to issuance of
bonds and then dealing with state and
federal agencies that they see the word
town and then they get confused about
the process so they're looking for a
select board vote but obviously they
have a Town Council vote that's what is
is approving
um
steps in those processes so that's why
they're looking for some more clarity in
the language of
49 D2
in order to to help alleviate those
explanatory uh issues
um as Senator Perkins stated
um the Secretary of State suggested a
change just to clarify that we're not
attempting to change any sort of
relationship between the town clerk
being elected and that process so that
was clarified
I don't believe there are any other
um local offices that would be affected
um
as far as far as I recall
um and so it was good to have this
clarification to ensure that they could
continue to be elected in towns that are
Town Council so I'm happy to take any
questions the committee may have
thank you representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my previous question
still stands
um if outside
agencies or organizations are are having
difficulty understanding
The Entity that that is before them
requesting to do some sort of business
why then cannot the Town Council
reference the statute 49d colon 1. I
think that they they do that I think
they just have some difficulty
explaining it and explaining the
multiple choices of local government
whether that's a select board set up
town a Town Council town of which there
are several variants
um in terms of budget adoption and
everything else which is again going to
affect
especially in the bonding market and
then as well as
um cities so
I
that's really why this bill came about
not that it's trying to change any
Authority it's just trying to
add a line into the into the statute
that makes it a little bit clearer that
they can point to that that helps those
outside agencies well
go ahead
thank you Mr chairman
um so my follow-up question is I'd like
to understand that do cities towns did
they receive some type of a certificate
stating what type of governance that
they that they've adopted locally and
how they operate
they do not
um they just have the statutory
Authority and then
you know at Town originally it would
have been a town they would have had a
town meeting they would have had a vote
a town meeting to change the form of
government they would have adopted uh
either a charter um which would put them
as a charter Town
um or which is a Town Council town or
um they may have adopted uh becoming a
city and that would have occurred at
some point in time of the past and then
they would have
updated all of their you know
documents labels Etc that they that they
use
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I I kind of see this as semantic hair
splitting I think all the language is
pretty clear in the statute as it stands
and I don't think this bill detracts
from it so I don't have an objection to
it what I do have a question about and
possibly an objection to is the
grammatical structure of how the
legislation is proposing to be changed
so when I look at the existing statute
I see the open town meeting invests all
legislative Authority in a Town Council
as the elected body comma and in the
original
existing legislation that sentence goes
on in a very clear way to say or in the
alternative vest authority to make
Appropriations
etc etc
whoever drafted the bill
that's being presented to us today
sticks this phrase with the same powers
and authorities as a city council right
in the middle of that sentence
rendering that sentence almost
a non-sequitur
so my suggestion would be to
have that phrase with the same powers
and authorities the city council as a
separate sentence somewhere else in the
paragraph
because I think it interrupts the
existing sentence in a way that
detracts from it making sense
I have no objection to any changes you
may wish to make
representative Keller
thank you and uh thank you for taking
the question this kind of follows up on
representative stavis's
um
uh comments
the the language that that we're talking
about is is uh Town Council getting the
same Powers as the city council
um how
and in this sentence there is a kind of
an alternative they can do some
um
some different uh
handling of the budget
um how
how does the city council and the budget
interplay
happen in uh cities versus how the
Myriad I guess of ways that it can
happen in the towns because they can
each kind of set up their own interplay
and is there
um and I guess is this limiting saying
that
um that the towns uh that adopt this now
have to have that structure for this for
that City
structure of city council and their
power over the budget where they might
want to set up a different structure
between them the that uh New Town
Council and the budget
can you kind of talk about that so
um
at the at its core the
there's one town left that still has the
very basic form of town government which
is Benton and they have everything
happens at town meeting and that's
basically pure democracy and then we
have cities where we have representative
government so
in Concord for instance we uh we elect
uh Representatives the city council they
go they do everything
um from budget to setting policy
um
Town Council towns are in this weird uh
and I want to say weird but in this
Middle Ground where it's typically
larger municipalities
and typically it's the case they have
Representatives that will set policies
but but they'll
different Town Council towns do
different things so some of them and I
think Hooksett is one of them
they have a budgetary town meeting where
they still have
what you would expect they notice a town
meeting everybody comes to vote at the
town meeting but the town meeting is
really only to vote on the budget
um it's not on kind of the separate uh
all those separate things you would do
at town meeting
so in terms of the intent of this
legislation it's not to change the scope
of the relationship between what any
local
any municipalities voters have chosen as
their form of government
um
if there's any implication through the
the grammatical structure that there is
that is certainly not the intent and uh
I would certainly like that to be
clarified
follow-up yes thank you
um in your answer you said that City
councils have the a power to set budgets
um and
um in this language it says that we are
enshrining that they have the same
powers
and authorities of the city council so
therefore in in with this language we
would be giving the town councils
the authority to the powers to set
budgets
um and it seems like there is no
um
maybe the reason why they're the um it's
not a separate sentence and is saying um
is placed before the or is to say or
um
set an alternative budget via some other
way is that your maybe interpretation of
the structure of this
I think that might be right
um I didn't write this
um my I did have some input but
um
really there are
several options under Town councils some
of which basically operate As Cities but
they're still classified as towns
um
and then there are some where you have
what's closer to a traditional Town
organization so
possibly that's why that's structured
the way it is
one last representative L word and we'll
go back
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question Mr Grace
out of curiosity
uh did you city councilman persons
receive compensation for the
the position
I don't know that off the top of my head
my in my I believe that they do receive
something similar to a stipend but I I
don't know off the top of my head all
right thank you
representative Kellum
thank you
thank you for taking this follow-up
um
so kind of going back to the structure
of this and the or it says so you're
granting them the same powers and
authorities or you're doing something
else with the budgetary town meeting
um and I guess that also brings up the
question that if you do
um
if you do something other than the
normal budgetary town meeting
um
it seems to the structure of the
sentence seems to now throw in to
question what
now are the authorities and powers of
that
um that Town Council because now you
have this or that says well now you
don't have those Powers anymore so now
what powers do you have and so then that
would go back to their essential like
their Charter or their documents which
is
where they should have been
delineated in the first place and then
this change no longer is like necessary
if I can make a suggestion yeah it
appears that representative yokella and
stavis are both very interested in
making sure the grammar of the proposed
amendment is correct and I'm happy to
work with both of them
um to see if we come to some sort of
mutual agreement as to what would be the
best option uh to clarify this
representative save us who had your hand
up again
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking yet another grammatical question
I think this could be easily solved by
leaving the existing legislation as it
is and just inserting
just inserting after the word budgetary
town meeting period the new wording the
Town Council shall have the same powers
and authorities as you know etc etc
that gets away from chopping up that
sentence but it makes the point that
this legislation wants to make
I think that works I'm not the grammar
expert but
I think there are obviously issues that
representative yokella and stavis have
pointed out so
um unless there are any other other
questions I think what we'll do is we'll
end this hearing and will allow those
individuals to work together to come up
with something
that works if it is indeed needed
representative vehicle
thank you thanks
okay I have nobody signed in in favor or
posed I have no more pink cards so we
will close the hearing on SB 111.
and we have about five minutes to the
next one
foreign
45 so we will go ahead with the next uh
hearing and open up the hearing on SB
relative to residency status and
Senator Fenton
very good you have the floor thank you
thank you Mr chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton I
represent District 10. I'm here today to
talk to you about Senate Bill 110
relative to the administration of
emergency shelter programs by cities and
towns this bill provides balance between
towns that send their residents to get
services in the towns that provide those
services
the New Hampshire welfare Administration
approved the policy to help guide
welfare administrators in New Hampshire
in regard to residency and temporary
housing we are seeing a lot of
homelessness in New Hampshire and often
people seeking assistance will come to
larger towns because the smaller town
might not be open or doesn't have a
staff shelter or Aid
these larger towns will provide
assistance or aid but the smaller towns
aren't necessarily reimbursing them
we want municipalities to communicate
and coordinate assistance options with
each other including reimbursements from
municipalities of origin
anyone who goes to a different town
other than their town of residency and
stays in a hospital treatment program
Center emergency housing Arrangement
will still remain a resident of their
original town until they find more
permanent housing
towns and cities want to continue to
provide support for the residents and
this bill helps them do so this bill
will create an environment where
everyone helps fight homelessness and
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you for the testimony
representative Gallagher
um so
um it's got a this bill has a different
title as printed which says
um it was a new title from what you gave
uh relative to residency says I was just
wondering if he could could
um repeat your the original title again
just for comparison and
um I was wondering why that might have
been changed
if I unders thank you representative for
the question if I understand what you're
saying I gave a different title than
what the Bill's title is
uh then then what's printed in the
um handouts that were distributed to us
I have relative to administration of
emergency shelter program by cities and
towns
that's not the title but you guys have
the title on the on the um on the second
page the LBA oh relative to residency
status
um good question I have an act relative
to the administration of emergency
shelter programs by cities and towns you
all have relative to residency status
great question can't have an answer for
that
apologies
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question so my my
question
um
refers to a previous section of Statute
and that would be 165 colon one where it
clearly states that
um has to do who is entitled in the
local responsibility with regards to
providing services
and it reads whenever a person in any
town is poor and unable to support
himself he shall be relieved and
maintained by the overseas of Public
Welfare of such Town whether or not he
has residence there
so that clearly states that the town in
which the the the person finds himself
in that is in need of assistance shall
receive assistance from that town
so does this imply
um 165 colon 1
to me that implies that that
responsibility is with that town and
with that responsibility would come
um you know the financial obligation to
provide that
so to me that it's it's
statute is clear
could could you comment on on
this bill and what it's proposing in in
light and in reference to that other
statute absolutely thank you for the
question I'm not familiar with 165 I
will say we have uh the municipal
Association behind me and legal as well
so I would that's a great question to
ask them but I will say that this bill
was born out of the fact that uh towns
are not reimbursing larger
municipalities uh you know it's a fact I
think we have an issue where
um these smaller towns that necessarily
may not have a welfare office or shelter
or Aid as I said before are sending
their residents to these larger towns
and the larger towns are trying to get
reimbursement but either the town is
ignoring them completely or not
complying
follow-up
thank you um thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my follow-up
question Senator so
um just again to be clear
would you do you agree that current
statute there's no Provisions that there
shall be any reimbursement to another
municipality
I wouldn't necessarily agree I would say
the the welfare Administration office in
New Hampshire
put out a release guiding welfare
offices on how to being reimbursed by uh
the sending towns and
what is happening is that is not
happening dad so I would think that this
bill is reaffirming the duty
four towns to provide for their
residents
oh boy a lot of questions
representative majority
thank you Senator thank you chair thank
you for taking my question so obviously
this bill has an FN on it but I was
confused by the FN because they're I I
don't see I'm trying to understand why a
community would have to adjust their
budgeting on this when we have a
nebulous unfortunately we have this
nebulous I don't know how many homeless
May transition or or may move here and
there I I would think my community would
not change its budgeting procedures we
it's just a matter of whether or not we
are compensating or or or or what's the
word I'm looking for I can't think of
the word I'm reimbursing thank you
reimbursing another Community does so I
don't understand why there's a fiscal
note on it do you can you explain that
at all or thank you for the question
representative I think the fiscal note
came out of
the fact that
um some towns don't even consider it
their responsibility to pay for their
residents and so they might have to take
an account that now you do have to pay
for you have a responsibility to pay for
the residents who reside in your city or
town yeah no thank you
uh representative Cahill had a question
thank you for taking my question Senator
good to see you again
um do you do you think that
there's also this issue
of municipalities and other states
sending not paying for
um people that need help that that are
getting help in New Hampshire do you
think we need to address that issue too
and
thank you for the question
representative um so if I understand
that you're worried about you know we
border Massachusetts so you're saying
or Maine or Maine you're going after
Maine no
um you know I don't think we can address
that situation you know I think we are
focusing on the cities and towns in New
Hampshire
um you know I don't think you know Maine
cities or towns are like hey go to New
Hampshire get their raid they could
that's potential
um but this is focusing on you know our
state our municipalities our cities and
towns and really making sure they're
coordinating and cooperating
representative stavis
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um I want to refer back to
representative Powers point about
um
165 which is extremely clear that towns
have an obligation to provide for those
who cannot provide for themselves and
the problem is and I can speak to this
as representative of Lebanon that towns
and cities that have numerous hotels
motels those kinds of facilities are
receiving
tremendous number of homeless
individuals and distressed individuals
because we have those facilities I spoke
to our welfare director about this bill
uh and she is looking forward to the
time when she can have active
negotiations with the surrounding towns
of Canaan and Enfield so that that we in
Lebanon taxpayers in Lebanon don't have
to bear the full burden of providing for
residents of Canaan or Enfield who are
Indigent so I see this bill as a way of
Shoring up 165.
uh in in a in a kind of terrible 21st
century way when we're faced with this
increasing problem of homelessness and
indigence across all of our towns
I I if there's a question in there I
would agree with it
um I would say that this really gives
the cities and towns an opportunity to
negotiate and work with one another
versus you know um
some municipalities don't even pick up
the phone when you call them to ask for
help or assistance with a with a
resident or an individual
I I would remind the members of the
committee that we do ask questions and
uh not make statement statements are
kind of reserved for our executive
session but uh we let that one go
representative
uh representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Senator all right in
the fiscal note
um last sentence of the first paragraph
it says finally the bill requires
municipalities to coordinate assistance
options with other municipalities when
it is determined unreasonable for the
person to physically return to the
municipality of origin who determines
when it is unreasonable for the person
to return the the the municipality of
origin or the the Locale where the
person is at that time well thank you
for the question it's a good question I
think it determines on what sort of Aid
the individual is receiving if they're
in a shelter or if they're in a hospital
per se I think it comes down to
um the extent of the homelessness that
the individual is dealing with in terms
of emergency housing I think that's the
determining Factor I'll follow up
follow up thank you sir
um under Roman V
temporary urgence assistance
um to meet the basic needs of transient
individuals
or residents of other municipalities
so is this bill saying that a transient
individual
who needs temporary urgent assistance
versus a resident of the municipality
yeah
if someone wanders into a town
and I guess is considered what transient
by the police or I mean someone has to
determine trend transient
and that person goes to the next town
and gets services
so those two towns have to
communicate and coordinate assistance
options with each other and I thought
the problem and I think it was stated
here earlier was municipalities aren't
communicating with each other they're
not answering the phone
um
what compels
any municipality to coordinate with each
other
thank you for the question what compels
the municipalities to coordinate with
each other's reimbursement of funds uh
that transient individual that is just
another
instance of what may happen a transient
individual's wanders into your
municipality as you said that
municipality then contacts the
municipality or town of origin and says
hey your resident is here seeking
shelter or Aid this is what we need
reimbursement for
what of the transient individual do you
have another question I'm sorry
follow-up sir thank you you already had
two uh some other people who are looking
to
represents you guys aren't letting me
off the hook oh no she'll be back
yes Senator yes sir
thanks for taking my question of course
I understand the the idea of a smaller
municipality it's having like in my case
that I live in Litchfield which is
relatively small although we have almost
9 000 inhabitants
we have no shelters or anything we have
a budget provision for welfare and so
forth but if we have a person who
becomes homeless
they would probably gravitate toward
some of the cities and I understand that
do the counties which are more Regional
do they have any sort of responsibility
when it comes to the homeless
thank you for the question great
question
um in terms of this bill does not deal
with the counties it deals with the
municipalities and the towns and cities
um
what well the what this bill really is
about is that
you know I think I've stated this before
is that you know we have an obligation
to those individuals and if we don't
what stops a town from kicking out all
their homeless people and just saying
get out
and sending them to the big cities where
they're building homeless shelters and
providing Aid and assistance that's what
it really comes down to
that's been done
representative color
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
this I I'm kind of
um interested in the 30-day
um
requirement
um kind of from two perspectives one of
them is from your
um stated goal which is to receive money
from the other towns
um from that if the person is in their
homeless shelter for six months why only
30 days should they be in reimburse for
they're only a resident for 30 days
um and from the other perspective what
if the a person actually wants to become
a resident of this new town why should
we forbid them
that especially let's say it's you know
close to voting time and they want to
vote where they're now currently
residing because they want to go in
person
um this might require them to you know
go get an absentee ballot or travel to
another town to vote and because they're
not able to establish residency because
it's against the law apparently that
they are now a resident of the new town
and in New Hampshire right now you you
go to a new town you say you're a
resident now you're a resident you can
go vote there
um how how do those interplay I guess in
your mind
um regarding this bill no thank you
representative it's a great question I
think the the 30 days is exactly because
of voting we don't want them to lose
their residency status because they go
and seek shelter or Aid in that larger
town so we don't want them to say Hey
you came in this larger Town you're a
resident now you're voting here you know
that is what we don't want you know
because we don't want them to say well I
don't want to live in this larger town
or city I still want to be a resident my
my uh original town and I want to vote
there so that's why the 30 days is there
to protect them so that they don't have
to assume residency in that larger Town
we're not we're not saying you can't get
there and not be a resident you know
anyone can uh register to vote and do
that you know
representative Gallagher
um so
this is kind of a follow-up to both my
previous question and representative the
Ocala's question so
um the testimony so far has mostly been
focused on emergency housing and just
now is turning into elections a bit so
um I was wondering
um in section two
um
in addition to emergency housing
governed by the statute number
um person does not change his or her
residency status
while in all those situations so uh I
was wondering just
um residency status
is it it matters for more things besides
elections and emergency housing doesn't
it um do you have a full list of other
places in the rsas where residency
status is referenced where this could
have an effect
it's a great question representative I
don't have a full list I will say that
uh there are other people behind me that
do want to testify on this bill and I
think they'd be giving you some some
very good concrete answers on a lot of
things okay thanks
representative uh I guess we'll go
representative Kelly first
hi um this is probably a ridiculously
naive question thank you for taking my
time absolutely yes sir um as someone
who originally hails from California I'm
curious if the state of New Hampshire
how does the State of New Hampshire
determine who cannot support himself
who cannot what the question is that how
does the State of New Hampshire
determine who cannot support themselves
yeah as opposed to
I believe I believe someone from the
welfare is here so they'll probably have
it they'll answer that question for you
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Senator
um you made a statement earlier that
said uh and I'm curious why you said
this at uh towns are sending residents
to other Municipal municipalities versus
individuals choosing to be in that new
location I I assume they go in there
because of the appropriate facilities
and services as representative lasalles
said so
um
it kind of prompts my my thought and I'd
like your opinion on
why the statement that they're sending
people there as a as a as a as opposed
to people choosing to go to these
locations because they have the services
I I think it implies something different
yeah I think thank you representative
the question I think it implies that
they are sending individuals because
they may still be able to offer Aid in
that original town but they may be full
up you know they may not have the option
of keeping that individual even if they
wanted to so they are sent to a larger
town or municipality that can handle
them
representative majority
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking one more hopefully quick question
that's okay in section five it says
municipality should coordinate I just
want to make sure I understand
coordinate for the reimbursement there
is no implication here of a a one-to-one
reimbursement it is what you can afford
for instance it may cost a lot more in
town X than it than I have budgeted for
so there is the flexibility in here to
to coordinate for what each Community
can pay correct and that you know what
we don't want is lawsuits we're trying
to make sure that one city is ensuing
another city for reimbursement
okay
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my follow-up question
or an additional question so um a lot of
the the purpose of the bill is with with
regards to receiving reimbursement so my
question pertains to line 21
um do we have us in New Hampshire a
statutory definition of a transient
individual and the reason I ask that is
due to residency in originating
municipality for the purposes of
reimbursement so how would that work uh
I don't have a thank you for the
question representative I don't have a
definition of Transit individual I'm
sure the individuals behind me probably
do
okay
representative Edward I know you had
another question do you want to hold off
for somebody else
um I think Diane touched on what where I
was going with that thank you
see no further questions thank you for
your attention I will say you guys very
thorough I appreciate it
that's what we do
all right uh next person uh we have
representative uh bogert
also remind people who are test
individuals uh testifying uh in addition
to your name and rank serial number all
that stuff let us know if you're in
favor or against
uh thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Stephen bogert for the
city of uh Laconia and we're not quite
sure if we're far or against this so if
I didn't check the box I have uh uh by
city and talking with the City of
Laconia they were going why should we
support this so they are
unsure themselves now real quick with
the City of Laconia they are the county
seat for Belknap County they have the
hospital they have the county jail they
have the mental health services they
have all the things that are what
unhoused people look for to come to okay
and so we're a receiver City for the
county and our outside of our County to
[Music]
some of the things that we've done to
address this situation is we've created
uh uh a housing uh an under housing
committee that is researching this based
with the mayor and stuff and with all
the mental health Society local
communities and stuff uh
and the other thing is I have a homeless
encampment 500 feet from my house so I
get an opportunity to see the people
moving uh these aren't long-term people
they come and you can tell a lot of them
aren't from our city so they're coming
from elsewhere
okay and
so the question is it they're going to
migrate to our city and all the other
cities this says like under Section Five
the municipality shall communicate and
we're assuming that under RSA 165 colon
2 that the other
cities these people come from after they
get out of jail or after you get out of
the hospital or something like that
these towns they come from are going to
pay and that's not clearly true so even
though it says they shall pay at some
amount we don't know the city carries
the cost of all of this itself
if one was trying to look out how to
change
the responsibilities for those receiver
cities who have the the fortunate of
receiving or being able to provide the
services to the unhoused maybe it should
be a County
type budgeted
things so that all the cities pay into
the county and then each city is not
chasing another city for reimbursement
it comes automatically from the county
you go to your county and get your
services and then you submit the bill to
the county and the county pays it okay
and all the other towns are
municipalities or whatever within that
County have to pay to the county through
their tax property tax and it takes care
of all the budgeting per town and stuff
it takes that out of these the equation
whatsoever I don't know that that's
feasible or not it's just something
that's thrown out there and
um
we do see a lot of people come from
outside the area we have
we've unfortunately had to set up
cameras and stuff to watch all of this
as it unfolds 500 feet from a
residential area
these are the realities of this
situation and the biggest thing of this
bill if it is to work it a lot of these
showers should be if we're going to
force the other towns in in villages and
whatnot to Fork up then it needs to put
the teeth in that
so that the receiver cities do get a
chance and that the citizens of those
cities don't end up footing the whole
bill for our area
of it and I'm sure there's other larger
cities that are stuck in the same
situation
so that's why we're not quite sure if
we're opposed against it it's got some
good Beginnings but I think there's some
uh more in-depth work it could help to
help
improve the situation for the receiver
cities and sure up the uh
rsas in that manner
thank you thank you questions
representative yokella thank you thank
you for taking the question
um in on paragraph uh three it says a
person who who leaves emergency housing
of their own free will
um
and goes on to to say that they shall
not be considered to have changed their
residency status for 30 days
um in the testimony that we had from the
senator it seemed like his implication
was that they could however this
language on line 14 says that she shall
not considered to have been changed
their residence
um
do you do you see that that is taking
away like the the person's agency to say
this is where I want to
um declare my residency and and do you
think that
um that residency
um
it should be the deciding factor
um like you know messing with the The
Residency you know standards that we
have now in New Hampshire to solve kind
of a tangential issue
as far as taking care of the health
and uh through that may it be physical
help or mental health or whatnot where
they're resident of is not going to
change because being a uh a receiver
city of the County Seat you're still
going to be required to provide basic
support for a person's health may it be
through their mental health or drug
health or their uh physical help okay
the only things that can change through
that are some of the other things like
they were talking about voting and
whatnot which I'm not sure how that
plays into
positive or negatively plays into
what this bill is trying to accomplish
and as far as people leaving one
emergency shelter uh most of the time
they'd never even go to these Emergency
Shelters uh dear the coldest snaps we've
had and up here this past
month uh we had our County shelter open
for warming so these people could go in
there and now we have over 300 homeless
people on House people okay and only two
people showed up and the rest of them
stayed in The Frigid cold
down at the end of my street where you
can see them with their encampments and
that's where they chose to stay over
that so the far as the residency is
concerned and what it's going to be a
hard one to quantify of what are their
resident of of the resident of the woods
or or what it's hard to say
representative Gallagher
um so
um some clarification about when you
said unfortunately we had to set up
cameras to monitor this encampment um
could you
um clarify about
um where exactly the had to part comes
from like was is there a law requiring
you to set up cameras or
what where where where where does this
necessity come from
thank you for the question
the necessity of the camera came from
the fact that as the living in a
dead-end street and you have a constant
stream of there's probably anywhere from
30 to 50 people ongoing living in this
encampment at the end of our street so
every morning you get an opportunity to
see The Exodus of these people going
down to receive the city services of of
breakfast and whatever else services
that they are receiving and then you
give the opportunity for them to return
throughout these times that made the
requirement of that as you have multiple
people with different mental situations
going on you have an opportunity for uh
situations happening in the woods so
that you can the the camera is set up to
help it's not in the encampment in
itself it's towards the entrance looking
in so you can monitor people going in
and see what they are and who they are
and stuff
the other problems that were preceded
we've the people living on this road
have had their mail stolen out of their
mailboxes they've had packages I
personally have had to chase one off the
front porch of my neighbor's house
because he was still in a package
and uh the I've had them actually come
onto my property and stuff so there's
things that intrude into a neighborhood
that people don't get a chance to see
unless you actually live there as you
so I'm trying to answer this question I
think you've answered it well thank you
anybody uh it's uh
seeing no more questions thank you for
your testimony
representative Horgan
thank you much I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan for Stratford County
District Six which is the town of uh
town of Durham and um
I mostly came here for the previous bill
but this one is a subject in your
theater residency because uh we have a
large
number of uh citizens living the town
who are students or who are also like uh
have just moved to the area recently and
there's you know constant uh
we're constantly there's constant mental
gyrations over the term residency which
uh
there's certain there's a certain uh
segment that believes those people
should not be voting in the place where
they are in fact living and um
that applies perhaps also to the uh
unhoused and the transients so this bill
uh
so I think it's very important that um
if you live if you're a resident of one
town and they locate you temporarily to
a hotel or motel because not every town
has a hotel or motel let's say if you're
shipped from um
say Litchfield over to Bedford or
Manchester
um and they're putting you shouldn't
lose your voting rights in your in your
previous Town
um
and I it's a and uh also
even though I think the law already
guarantees the spiritual right to vote
is also a subparagraph two which we
haven't
talked about too much is um if you go
whether or not
um if you're simply you know in a
hospital for extended period or you know
Treatment Center or even a correctional
facility you don't lose your
right to vote in the town where you're
where you're domiciled which is not
quite the same thing as residents but um
having a residence in town is yet
generally requirement for domicile like
um actually the correctional facility
sounds kind of strange because uh
you know if you're actually uh convicted
and incarcerated
you lose your right to vote for for that
time at least it's a felony but there's
a large number of people in jail who are
simply awaiting trial or
have been convicted of misdemeanors so
they don't lose their right to vote as a
result of their status and uh
of course it's also a little bit strange
because Correctional Facilities
accounted for the purposes of the census
you know the prisoners are counted
where they're incarcerated at the time
the census was taken but that's um
so and um so anyways if I think it's
important that those individuals uh
still have residency status and voting
is one of the uh reasons why there's
others and um and if you obviously if
you do leave the emergency
um housing of your own will it does give
you a 30-day grace period to find a
residence somewhere else and um
there's also the case
and frankly if you move to a homeless
encampment unfortunately that probably
that probably is a residence so it's not
not a very good it's not a very
satisfactory residence and if you're
just a homeless encampment because
you're temporarily absent from some
other community uh you're probably
should be eligible probably to vote in
either place depending on where you
consider your domicile is I'm not sure
how many
how many of those individuals are
worried about voting they've got things
much you know lower on the priority of
needs they're just trying to survive
um
and uh
we're talking about
we're talking about a paragraph one
that's language that's already in the
law so uh you know it does towns and
cities already have the option to send
people
back where they came from if that's
possible and that would probably include
even individuals from out of state um so
we had one individual who I won't name
because he's running for president who's
the governor of another state he like
recently sent people from his state to
Massachusetts if that happened here in
New Hampshire
that existing law would already allow us
to put those people back in the plane
and send them back where they came from
I believe but
um
so anyway I think uh and I one thing I
finally underline is if you
start paying for the hotel or motel or
for some other residents in your new
community or if you start paying or if
you start self-paying for the hotel or
motel where you placed on emergency
place when you become a resident of the
new community and um
even though
even though this does specifically just
say four local welfare purposes um
that uh it is interesting that uh with
the student voting
everybody agrees that they're paying for
a resident in the town where the living
world's hitting school and there's also
a lot of attempts to somehow redefine
residencies
can we speak to the bill yes um we
you've spoken yes four minutes now
regarding mostly voting and that kind of
stuff yes well that is that is one of
the reasons uh why this is a good bill
so they don't lose their rights to vote
in the town where they came from simply
because the town is paid for him to move
somewhere else and or or because they're
incarcerated or they're in a hospital or
other treatment facility so that's
that's just one of the many reasons why
this is a good build so
thank you yeah further quote any
questions
thank you for your testimony
uh next we'll call Todd Marsh
oh all right sorry about that I never
want to be that person to ask if it's on
and I just became that person so
um
members of the committee my name is Todd
Marsh
and I represent the New Hampshire local
welfare administrators Association
I do have some notes Here which is good
for me and probably better for you
especially at this time
um
again on the president of local the New
Hampshire local welfare administrative
Association I'm also the welfare
director of the city of Rochester
prior to my employment with Rochester I
was a director first director of the
homeless Center for Stratford County in
Rochester
and residential marriage or the My
Friends Place shelter in Dover I've held
multiple elected positions within my
hometown of Somersworth I am I am uh I
share this with you not because I'm
seeking any employment or running for
any office but just to give you an idea
of the spectrum of uh of knowledge that
I have in this area
um
the New Hampshire local welfare
administrative Association is a
professional non-profit organization
that educates and supports our Municipal
members to Foster compliant
uh humanitarian and fiscally responsible
assistance practices when assisting
residents with New Hampshire RSA 165
colon 1. uh statutorily obligated basic
needs
Municipal local welfare is a resource
that is often down the street from where
people live
and a place where people are not treated
like numbers but community members that
happen to be in need
not only that we are increasingly
becoming a valuable expert social
service voice and resource to decision
makers within our town and City Halls
throughout New Hampshire
we are often a bridge of communication
and understanding between outside
agencies and Municipal leaders
as you were aware
hotels and motels paid for by agencies
and organizations have been used for
emergency housing purposes when needed
for many years
however
as our country's multi-faceted
challenges increased so has the use of
motels and motels for emergency housing
as are multifaceted challenges increase
so has the use of traditional homeless
shelters
as our multi-faceted challenges increase
so has the use of in development of
seasonal overnight warming centers
as our multifaceted challenges increase
so has the use of Android development of
substance disorder treatment centers
and
as our multi-faceted challenges
increased
we have learned a multi-pronged approach
is needed to solution find
in June of 2022 after months of
discussion
in solution finding including mitigating
any unintended consequences
the New Hampshire local Welfare
administry Association by unanimous vote
including many small towns
adopted our ethics resolution agreement
it was it was to provide increased
collaboration and cons and consistent
liability expectations
further established general assistance
best practices
and Foster increased Municipal support
for temporary emergency assistance
by clarifying Municipal liability due to
temporary emergency housing placements
Although our association did not
initiate SB 110 we are flattered much of
our thought
out best practice ethics agreement
language has been used
New Hampshire can be proud that our
individual municipalities large to small
north south east and west worked with
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and legal aid
some would say an unlikely coalition
at the table of solution finding
and found Common Ground agreement that
benefits the people of our state
passage of this bill will establish a
common ground fair and Equitable
agreement on residency in relations to
hospitals treatment program centers and
emergency temporary housing services and
placements outside
of a Municipality of origin
passage will Foster increased Municipal
support for temporary emergency housing
and other services by clarifying
residency liability
to the municipality of origin
there's an old saying
that is spoken by municipalities
sometimes behind closed doors
that if
you build it I know what you're thinking
they will come
well they are human beings
wherever they are from and we should be
mindful of that
however
there is a sensitivity to increased
financial responsibility
for people from elsewhere when
supporting emergency housing including
warming centers
sometimes we need to meet concerns where
they're at
this bill will do that
this bill will help mitigate those
concerns
this bill will maximize Municipal
support
for emergency housing
Beyond increased emergency housing is
important to note SB 110 complies with
the humanitarian intent
in our obligations indicated in RSA 165
colon 1.
the clarifying humanitarian what I would
call Safeguard language
and the bill indicates I'm quoting
temporary urgent assistance may need to
be provided to meet basic needs of
transient individuals or residents of
other municipalities
that Safeguard language
also municipalities shall now in our
ethics agreement we use the word should
in law on this bill it shall
strengthens it
communicate and coordinate assistance
options with each other including
reimbursements for municipalities of
origin pursuant to RSA 165 colon 2A
now the New Hampshire local Welfare
Association
will advise Municipal local welfare
officials to practice situational
residency assistance flexibility with
situations warrant
this bill
is a bipartisan Common Ground
Improvement to the benefits of local
welfare
I recognize there may be a small
minority of municipalities that benefit
from the status quo of deferred fairness
and responsibility also you may hear
from some of our Advocate friends and we
have many
Express uncertainty about the
Improvement as change results in
different
a respect I respect them for tapping the
thought breaks however we needed to
think differently
we need to think better
even if it's a measured and methodical
Improvement
and I think that's the New Hampshire way
it's important to be aware that most
municipalities play nice in the local
welfare sandbox with each other we do
including the greater Seacoast area
which our ethics agreement is modeled on
what our practice has been in that area
however there are Pockets throughout the
state for various reasons
that will benefit from this narrowly
targeted Municipal welfare
clarification and Improvement in the law
Amendment to the law
this bill will strengthen the
relationship with those that already
play nice
and collaboratively in the local welfare
sandbox and legally obligate those who
are not
this bill continues to Auto Municipal
legal and humanitarian obligations
increases Municipal collaboration
efforts increases Provider Services and
decreases concerns for financial
liability to humanitarian service hosts
municipalities
this bill gives municipalities and
provider agencies a law to site
a law to cite something to point to
and not to speak of our ethics agreement
practices of just being right
that's just the right thing to do
I'm proud to be part of this effort
and speaking with you today
um
I may have covered some of the questions
you have I did write down some of the
questions that you had earlier
um if you don't mind I'd like to address
some of those
and certainly as long as you can do it
quickly you would ask for five minutes
you're up to over eight so sorry about
that if you could make it very quickly
absolutely absolutely okay as far as
very briefly as far as elections this
bill this bill the focus is local
welfare
it's for local welfare purposes only
and that was the intention I did speak
to the attorney from nhma there might
have been a dropping of language which
he can speak to next
um when from one body to the next or
when it went when it was amended but he
could certainly speak to that
also 30 days
this this this amendment to RSA 165
the 30 days is for when someone leaves a
homeless shelter rather it's voluntarily
or they're exited that does
unfortunately happen sometimes so long
as they're in emergency housing
they are still considered a resident
from their place of origin
in this bill
also defines motels
used for emergency housing paid for by
paid for by agencies not self-paid for
except paid for by agencies
as emergency housing
so that would help mitigate many of the
concerns that the host municipalities
have the ones that have the motels the
ones who have the the homeless shelters
warming centers
so as long as somebody is in emergency
housing they are considered a resident
of their town of origin
it's when they leave right because at
some point they do need to become a
resident of for local welfare purposes
of the new municipality
okay
I'll end there very good thank you thank
you representative uh
thank you uh uh chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um so for the case of
someone in Manchester where there were
emergency housing and they decided to
to
leave that and go to Laconia and
and spend their nights in this
camp
this dead end camp
and it's been past 30 days so that would
be considered their new residence as
opposed to where they orig were
originally from is that correct
yes
representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um in your statement you often refer to
clarifying language
um and
um in the previous uh in the senator
referenced uh agency
um that said that there was some or
indicated that there was some
responsibility for the for the um other
municipalities to reimburse the
receiving municipality
um but
is was that uh
so that guidance
um he was referring to
um from this uh Welfare Association and
not not actually citing any law that
requires those municipalities to
um reimburse the
um receiving municipality yeah I
appreciate that question
there is a current law which is cited in
the bill
um regarding reimbursements
um however
it's the other language in the bill that
indicates
um I'm paraphrasing it right now but
that indicates that emergency housing
does not constitute residency for local
welfare purposes
um which would include motels used for
emergency housing it's that language
that helps to clarify for reimbursement
purposes
including the 30 days outside of a
shelter
because current currently someone could
leave a homeless shelter and go directly
to the Manchester
welfare office which they can still do
which is they can still do that in
collaboration and coordination and
um
so I think in that way it clarify same
thing with um uh Correctional Facilities
currently someone can go from a
correctional facility straight to the
city of concord's welfare office there's
nothing borrowing them from doing that
currently or in this bill but the
municipality can cite where where were
where where did you where were you where
was your residence prior to
prior to the corrections facility
and so it helps clarify that the the
uh the reimbursement piece that already
exists but it helps clarify
so you know more questions thank you for
your testimony uh last pink card I have
is Nate who is always
quick and on the point and thank you for
your patience by the way
I I have been warned uh Nate Grace for
the municipal Association we do uh
support this bill
um very briefly as committee members
have already pointed out uh 165 colon 1
requires the town's help
um those who are poor and unable to
support themselves regardless of their
residence 165 colon 2 hyphen a says that
the cost is borne by the town of or
Municipality of residence
and the question is well what what
qualifies a residence for local welfare
purposes and we have 165 colon 1C which
is what we're trying to modify here
um and really what this is based on is
that ethics resolution adopted by the
local welfare administrators that's
supposed to fill the Gap and say okay
what are the parameters where
one town is pain versus another because
the zoo party heard today there are
towns that have a large number of
services in their towns that don't have
any services and so at what point does
that residence
shift
the language uh that may have been
dropped would be line 15 it doesn't say
for local welfare purposes as line 19
says that would just modify Roman three
the intent here is not to change
anything for the purpose of voting
nobody
in front of you wants anything to do
with voting in this bill
um and as far as I am aware
um and uh really it's just to put some
parameters around
um okay what do we do when we have
someone from for instance the town of
Conway because I know they won't mind if
I use them as examples they were just in
the paper yesterday about this someone
comes to the town of Conway says the
local welfare administrator
I need assistance Conway says great but
all our hotels are full because it's
tourist season we have to ship you over
to Laconia for instance because that's
the nearest place we can get a hotel
room for you
um and then once that person gets to
Laconia
when if at what time would they shift
residents to Laconia that's what this
bill is trying to put some parameters
around and I'm happy to take any
questions that maybe have because I'm
sure I'm at my two minutes
nice job as always nature representative
Brown
thank you Mr chairman thank you
one of the clarifications I'd like to
get as you you mentioned something I
might have misunderstood it but that
the sending community
let's say to from North Conway to
Laconia they're required to reimburse
right look at the receiving location is
that complete reimbursement or is it
based on the town if it's a small town
their ability to pay for whatever those
services are and is there a limit so I I
always get in trouble with my members
because I have to tell them that the law
under 165 1 just says you have to
provide the aid it doesn't say you can
put a cap on that
um so they don't like it when I tell
that
um
most of the time the sending Community
does their best to find what
assistance they can it's usually pretty
simple it's just housing if it's
something like
um you know some sort of
um assistance program with mental health
or something like that it's usually more
complicated and they'll try their best
to coordinate with the welfare
administrator in the in the receiving
municipality they often also you know
let the receiving me somebody know hey
we're sending this person there
there are some issues with communication
and the hope is that this will spur more
communication between municipality so
they work this out and there aren't
lawsuits and there aren't
there aren't conflicts between
municipalities
go ahead quick follow-up so I just want
to make sure that there's nothing in
this bill that requires them to give
complete reimbursement is that what
you're saying it's it's what they can
pay or is it an absolute you will
reimburse the receiving location thank
you correct it's just that they have to
coordinate and communicate between each
other to figure out what the solution is
for that
so you know representative color
thank you uh
almost missed my chance
um
so it seems like
the
uh in uh Roman 4 that if you
um if a municipality chooses to
um
put
um the person in uh housing
outside of their municipality their
maximum amount of
uh
outlayment or duty to to
um to pay for that is 30 days
under this current under uh uh
Roman 4 because it says that the
transition resident after 30 days then
the transition residency will go to the
new municipality
um and so right now
the requirement seems to me that there
it's open-ended that they could be uh
the sending municipality would could be
on the hook forever and this new
language would say
that the the transition of residency to
the new Mississippi new municipality
will happen 30 days after
um
so I I read that differently than you do
representative um it's if the person
self pays at the at the motel so go back
to my Conway Laconia example Conway
sends somebody to a motel in in Laconia
that person after
two months gets a job they can now
afford to pay for the hotel they pay for
the hotel for 30 days they then lose
their job that person's residence he
would have transitioned to Laconia
because that person is paying for the
motel
it has to do with with who pays not
it's not the time placed on on the
municipality so it's not 30 days for the
sending municipality it's when there's a
break between that person receiving aid
how long does that break have to be
before they transition for local welfare
purposes to the new place of residence
represent power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Graves for taking my question so when I
have look at a bill I like to put it in
the context of the
um entire chapter
so you would
I asked a question earlier about 165
colon 1 and we agree that that
establishes
um where from where the assistant shall
come from and then you just mentioned
165 colon 2A so my question has to do
with 165 colon 1-A and in relation to
the the necessity of parts of this bill
to me when I read that section it says
that any person in a town or city who
was poor and unable to support himself
shall be known as a town or shall be
known as a town or city assisted person
and this is the part that I'd like to
emphasize and shall be relieved and
maintained at the expense of the town or
city of residence so is it not already
clearly established in statute that the
city of residents of the individual
receiving assistance that municipality
shall be responsible to
pay for such Services is that correct
correct and that's that's repeated in in
one 165 to a the issue is
that we have
um
people going to uh
uh not necessarily the case where
they're being sent to a motel from one
municipality to another
um but in some cases they're you know
showing up to Laconia to
other places that have
other services that can be provided to
them
and then they go to the local welfare
office and say hey I came from
Conway I hitched a ride over here and
I'm now receiving this and I need
housing and so you have the
municipalities that are kind of the
centers for providing these other
services in particular are now their
taxpayers are bearing the cost even
though the residents of the person
receiving the services wouldn't
under this and under the ethics
resolution wouldn't be considered
Laconia it would be considered North
Conway or whatever the case may be
so that's what that's what this is
trying to do is provide some clarity to
that
quickly representative yokella thank you
um and I want to try and clarify some of
your statements that you said before
that um that the municipality wouldn't
be on the hook for the entire amount of
the
um it would be kind of a negotiation
where
um uh is the interpretation of the
people that have testified thus far but
um representative power just read the
law that said that they shall be
um
uh maintain at the expense of the town
or city of residence so that to me
implies that it would be the full 100
amount shall be required to be paid by
the municipality of residents for that
um so can you can you um you know
clarify where you're where you're coming
from and that it would be a negotiation
so I think that Mr Marsh would be better
to answer this question about you the
best of my ability to answer it
um
so a lot of the costs of local welfare
are
um negotiable
um because
it may be the case that the hotel you're
working with will cut you a rate because
your municipality
um because you have certain parameters
around the people who are were there it
may be the case that uh you know other
providers of services
are willing to do different things in
terms of funding they're obviously
private advocacy groups that can help
provide funding so
when we're talking about costs you know
even if you look at something as basic
as housing right you can put someone in
the Motel 6 you can put them in the
Hilton and those are going to have very
different nightly costs
um and so part of the negotiation that
has to occur between the municipalities
um that this is trying to Foster is to
enable them to come to
kind of the best solution for
all the taxpayers rather than you know
them going to
the host Community the host Community
saying well the first phone call we got
back was the Hilton store put him there
rather than the Motel 6 even though we
know the Motel 6 has rooms so
um that's kind of the problem when when
you are a municipality operating outside
of outside of your own boundary so
that's the intent here and why
um you're hearing hearing that from
everyone testifying today
one more
thank you
um for the uh for for uh Roman five it's
talking about
um transient individuals and
um
it seems to me that
so transient individuals don't actually
have a residence that's why it's saying
or residents of another municipality so
um the transient individual may not be
actually known to any of those
municipalities
um and so they could say that they walk
through Bedford and and Fremont and
Danville and all of those places but and
then you know uh Laconia where they
ended up couldn't call all of those
towns and say Hey you now have to pay me
some amount of money because this person
said that they show walk through there
even though those municipalities have no
way of verifying that that person
is under the law their responsibility
because under the current law they're
only responsible for their residence
right under the under the current law
there they are responsible for paying
for their residents even if they're not
in that town so what this would do is
they require them to coordinate and
communicate so for transient individuals
not having a home and there are people
who just move from place to place to
place around that's
more difficult to nail down exactly
where the costs are going to be there
you know what kind of services were they
provided before what kind are available
now
um so again uh
you know really what the intent here is
to
under paragraph five is for that
temporary assistance where someone shows
up it's negative 20 out and they say hey
I don't have anywhere to go tonight you
can't let them freeze on the street so
you have to provide that emergency
assistance and then
you as you're talking to them you say
where do you come from and then you go
back and coordinate with that community
and it may be the case that they don't
live there
um they may have lied to you for
whatever reason they may come from
somewhere else they might not be from
the state and obviously we can't recover
from out of state
um so that's another additional hurdle
for local welfare administrators
thank you Nate thank you thank you I
have no more pink cards nobody signed in
on the blue sheet either way so with
that we'll close the hearing on SB 110
and we are about 25 minutes behind so we
will go ahead and open up the hearing on
SB
relative to the definition of broadband
infrastructure as Revenue producing
facility eligible for municipal revenue
bonds
and I believe uh Senator Bradley
you are up
morning Mr chair members of the
committee pleased to be here
um it's the sponsor of Senate Bill 222
um I want to thank the co-sponsors
including my fellow wolfborough uh
resident representative McDonald this is
an important bill to I think
a lot of areas in New Hampshire that
have limited access to broadband
unserved or underserved
quite simply put
um
the two changes that are proposed to RSA
and RSA 38
would allow the use of
Municipal revenue bonds for
communication districts communication
districts were authorized
by legislation in the past two or three
years as I recall so the towns could
band together to
create
Broadband infrastructure obviously
there's been a lot of funding for
Broadband infrastructure we all passed
the Broadband Municipal grant program a
couple of years ago legislation I was
pleased to sponsor the Bureau of
economic Affairs has gotten a lot of
federal funds and they've awarded these
federal funds both to the New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative to CCI as well as
dedicating I believe it was 26 million
dollars to the Broadband matching brand
initiative but this is another tool
to allow communication districts to have
revenue bonds not
taxpayer bonds but revenue bonds to
upgrade
broadband infrastructure
there are I believe it's 16
communities in Carroll County that have
banded together
in
forming a communication District that
has been approved by 15 of the 16 member
towns recently at their Town meetings
only moultonborough has not joined but
they have also not voted on this and I
believe their vote is on May 11th so
this this would enable
um you know this option should a
Communications District seek to Avail
themselves of it
the second part of the bill
um it increases the
Broadband speed definition to a hundred
megabits upload and download or I'm
sorry 20 megabits
um download it's currently right now 25
and 3 which for anybody that is
suffering at that service it really is
pretty limited on what you can do on it
and so the whole purpose of
this multifaceted effort is to make sure
that New Hampshire has easily accessible
higher speed Broadband for all residents
of New Hampshire if you are fortunate
like I am to live on a main road we most
likely have much better access but if
you're in a smaller town
not necessarily on a main road or even
some areas of our larger towns and
cities you may not have access to this
so allowing these communication
districts to have access to this feature
of revenue bonds not taxpayer bonds it
is paid for from the proceeds of the
users of a telecommunication District I
think makes sense having another tool in
the
toolbox to help Implement Broadband
infrastructure so with that Mr chair
happy to answer any questions
thank you
representative Gallagher
um so
the second part of it where it defines
Broadband I'm wondering
um
if this definition of
broadband Applause uh
solely to
the section of law that it's a part of
or if it applies throughout to other
things relating to broadband as well
I'm not sure the answer to that
um maybe somebody else can answer that I
can get back to you on it but um
obviously the intent of this is to
Define Broadband for purposes of these
revenue bonds as 100 megabits upload 20
download
so so that when you're considering what
an area of either unserved or more
likely underserved is that the
definition is a higher speed than the
lower speed which quite frankly
in the way that we're all using
Broadband now more and more the higher
capability is necessary and then if you
look on line 19
um there are also there's also a
provision that sort of allows keeping
um up to date with whatever
transformation transmission speeds are
um adopted by the Telecommunications Act
and the FEC
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question just to
clarify what you just said so um in
lines I guess it would be 16 and 17 that
language is changed or added to
addressed underserved areas yes because
there are a lot of areas that are served
to
um a very low speed
I think all of us are finding
increasingly that more and more capacity
is necessary
um especially if you have you know a
large family unit
um using
your Broadband Wi-Fi network at the same
time it just is absolutely essential
that they're for purposes of defining
what underserved is that the speed be
increased
representative lasalles
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question you may
or may not be able to answer this
question but technology of course is
changing what we used to be satisfied
with with dial up many years ago
certainly we're not satisfied with that
today we're we're
interested in instant uh Communications
there I'm just wondering in rural areas
where fiber optics cables it might be
prohibitively expensive in order to
serve those is satellite internet
an alternative uh I I think it probably
over time will be an alternative but um
you know the testimony that we've heard
as we've
sort of liberalized the opportunity for
towns to participate in this over the
last several years through revenue bonds
through creation of the
Telecommunications district is while
it's out there it still has some issues
that could be involved in terms of being
able to reach it its costs it's it's
availability I think it in the long run
is probably an answer but
I think all of us need internet service
and the pandemic showed us that but you
know New Hampshire is blessed with
people wanting to live here and work
remotely so that's an issue
um
obviously
our kids are learning more online now
and that clearly was the case in the
pandemic but I think to a certain extent
continues to be the case
medical visits are happening more and
more online so it's it's really
important and
that's why I think even though satellite
um starlink is going to be something in
the future it's not readily available at
a price that most people can afford now
thank you
representative viocella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
so
in the so you're this definition of
broadband is changing the definition of
underserved communities
um
Statewide and no longer just using that
Federal Communication standard so when
we're talking and comparing to other
states New Hampshire going forward would
be
um just saying that they that we may
have a larger population of underserved
communities compared to other states if
they were using this Federal commission
guidelines
um and I was wondering if you
thought about the impact of of
communicating in that way versus
um
uh it seems like your intention was
mostly to allow these Municipal revenue
bonds to be able to be utilized only for
going up to the 100 100 megabits a
second and there is a definition section
within that
um Revenue Municipal Revenue Bond
section that this could just clarify in
there that this section should only be
used to go up to 100 megabits I'm just
wondering if you had a thought about
that messaging and saying that New
Hampshire is vastly underserved because
we set our own higher standard than the
Federal
standard so that's that's a good point
um I think the messaging is also that if
we are underserved we're doing something
about it and
um I think that's a pretty important
selling point I've I've talked to
realtors that um
have indicated to me that
um
properties that were for sale in towns
that I represent that did not have you
know good access
um had a
um
the opposite of a premium a big discount
quite frankly at a time that you know
our real estate market is pretty hot
because they didn't have good access to
Internet so I think
um
people that want to come here and and
all of us that live here know how
important it is to have this so I think
the I think the messaging that you know
has occurred over the last several years
starting with
allowing Municipal bonding in a town
then allowing telecommunications
districts then
um you know the governor's efforts and
fiscal committee's acceptance of funds
for the New Hampshire Electric Co-op and
for
um CCI
to be able to build out networks the
Broadband matching Grant initiative that
those of us that were here last year all
voted for the funding that's going in
there I think the you know in terms of
the messaging we're doing a lot to try
to upgrade our Broadband but I will also
tell you somebody who's you know
represented areas of the state you know
considered the North Country even though
I live in Wolfeboro
um you know there are big pockets of New
Hampshire that are rural that are
underserved and it's been like this for
years where
um you know as technology improves their
air is a state that improved a lot
faster sooner and I would hope that this
is one more tool in the toolbox to help
those areas the state that aren't going
as
fast rapidly
any further questions for Senator
Bradley see you none thank you very much
I next like to call Carol Monroe
good afternoon
um I'm sorry that you're still here
having to struggle through all these
bills it is afternoon but
um thank you for allowing me to testify
chairman turcotte Vice chairman power
and all the representatives of the
municipal and County committee
my name is Carol Monroe do you do me a
favor and pull the mic just a little
closer to you I can thank you
um
I'm the chair of the board of a company
called valleynet and valleynet is a
construction management and operations
company for East Central Vermont
telecommunications District so the
concept of a communication district and
the ability to fund it with Municipal
revenue bonds is not new and it's
happening and it's happened in our
neighboring state but also across the
country in other Municipal areas
easy fiber as it's better known has 7
000 customers and 1500 miles of network
and a great deal of that network has
been built with Revenue
bonding Municipal Revenue bonding which
is of course very attractive to
investors because it's taxable you know
it's not taxable in the state and for
income taxes as well as on a federal
side and so the
so the revenue bonds that this District
puts out working through of course a
bond company
they're sold out on the day that we we
deploy you know we we offer them I guess
that's the word I want
um
EC fiber has been so successful that
that the first 23 towns very rural area
in in East Central Vermont are
um are fully built out and has accepted
another eight towns adjoining that to
build out fiber to their premises
and they have been
um
ebitda positive and cash flow positive
since 2015. they have been on time with
their bond payments and bond debt and
have a success that could be used in
other communication districts here in
New Hampshire
um I don't have to tell you and and you
have my comments by the way in your
email that significant Broadband has
proven to be a necessity uh for each and
every home and Business in New Hampshire
and during the last pandemic years has
become essential to the average
household
telemedicine was a very immature
technology solution prior to the
pandemic today it's an option for you
know for everyone at any time provided
you have a broadband connection that can
allow you to do some face-to-face online
with your your physician and for those
that don't live close to a hospital or
to a an area in which you have you have
all these Specialists close to Dartmouth
close to Concord the rest of the state
has to travel a great distance for some
of these services but telemedicine and
and Telehealth has helped to solve that
I actually used it not too long ago and
um I was amazed at the quality of my
service now mind you I live in Dublin
and we are lucky to have partnered with
a ISP with CCI so we do have Broadband
in Dublin New Hampshire but many areas
of the state do not
the current legisl the unserved areas in
New Hampshire spread throughout the
state although primarily in the Western
and the Northern areas of New Hampshire
and often cable services are available
in the downtown areas of these of the
towns or business districts
but not available where the housing
density is very low
and so when you define
unserved areas this is an important
aspect because you have to get through
those served areas to serve those
unserved areas and many much of the
funding
Associated
and restricted by the current
legislation the current what's currently
in the RSA doesn't allow you to use
Municipal Bond funding or any bond
funding to build where others have
already built but you need to get
through that area to get to those that
desperately need Broadband so increasing
the unserved definition will help that
situation
revenue bonds Municipal revenue bonds
are the responsibility of the in this
case the communication District it's not
unlike what we do for sewer districts
and water districts
and so the responsibility for payment of
those bonds is with the the revenue
within the district not to the average
taxpayer and so any revenues
the any payment of the revenue bonds
will be coming from those that actually
utilize that service and not through
taxpayer dollars
it's been pretty clear over the last few
years that 25 3 which is the definition
of broadband the FCC uses
has used in the past
is not adequate it is not adequate
Broadband for those individuals or
households here in New Hampshire
even the FCC acknowledges that because
all of the most recent funding coming
from the FCC uses the 120 which is what
we're asking this change to take place
120 as a definition
um for Broadband unserved areas so
anything not not served with 120 is
considered underserved or unserved and
it's those areas that the funding is
targeted for so this is just changing
the language within our own rsas to
bring it up to a more current definition
of what Broadband really is
it's important I think that we have all
the tools in the toolbox we can possibly
imagine
um getting to that house or that group
of houses at the end of the dirt road a
mile in is an expensive endeavor
I'd like to think that satellite
services would do that it's not quite
there yet
um you might have seen Elon musk's
starlink satellites if you have an
opportunity to see them in the sky
they're very beautiful but they go
across the sky like a path but how many
of those can he keep putting up into our
our atmosphere to support not only all
of us but all of the rest of the world
it's um they're trying they're grappling
with that and so it's not a a
it's not a done deal how's that
and it's not hasn't been has proven not
to be consistent or reliable so
ultimately perhaps that's going to be a
solution but it's not a solution today
and we'd like to make sure that every
premise here in New Hampshire
all the way out to the end of that dirt
road has the ability to have adequate
Broadband at a speed over a hundred and
over 20.
um we I heard some questions about
neighboring states and whether or not
that was too high of a standard
your neighboring Vermont the standard in
Vermont is 100 over a hundred
um so you know it is that is where
states are going at this time Maine as
well
um and I think that's uh adequate at
this time 100 over 20. the cable
companies can deliver 100 over 20 on the
current cable networks so I think that's
the 20. fiber can deliver 100 over a
hundred without any problems at all
I'm happy to take any questions you
might have and once again I want to
remind you that I did send it out in an
email so you have my notes or if you'd
like a copy I have those representative
lasalles
thank you for taking my question and
clarifying that satellite question that
I had previously do you know and uh if a
current
served underserved map of the state of
New Hampshire exists
um not at this time and so the current
FCC maps are they're all waiting to be
approved they've been there are
challenge locations throughout the state
where people are had the map show they
have service and and the individuals
have challenged that that information
they don't have service
um and vice versa though there are some
that show that they don't have service
and there are companies who are
challenging that so the maps aren't
final yet and the next round of what we
call Bead funding which is coming from
the federal government is waiting on
those maps to be accurate so
um we have an idea of you know who will
be sir who is served or I hate to use
the word underserved because either
you're served or you're not served but
who served or underserved
representative yokella thank you
um
you talked about these maps that are
being created at the federal level
um are they using the
120 standard for that that
um new map
um
and uh also is
you seem to indicate that they're
already moving towards that 120 standard
and so
um
it seems like that that if this
um does not pass it was still likely
become into effect once the Federal
Regulations get updated is that not the
case there's no indication at the FCC
when they will officially change the 25
3 definition
but but all of the materials that have
been coming out have in their in their
um
uh Federal funding documents indicated
the 100 over 20 as a definition so they
haven't they haven't changed it formally
at the FCC but they're using the other
so we have no idea when that will happen
and even if they feel the necessity to
have to have it happen and so to tie us
to the FCC low definition I think is
restricts us from moving forward
can you comment on whether the map would
be be reflecting the the current
standard or the 20010 so when you when
you go into the map itself you can
pinpoint a location and it will tell you
what providers are there and what
service they provide service so if it's
25 3 it will say something similar to
that if it's 100 over 20
um it will say that as well
further questions
seeing none I have a couple for you
um
in your opinion you don't have to give
me an exact estimate but in your opinion
when do you think uh satellite internet
will be
available
not in the near future
um he it
it's starlink is doing well
in certain areas at certain times of the
day it can deliver the speeds that it
has said it can
but in in other areas it's inconsistent
and unreliable
um so they're they're of course working
on that but part of the issue is how
many satellites do you put up in the
orbit
in order to serve
premises 24 7
consistently well enough so that you can
depend on it enough so that you would
want your emergency services to to
depend on it and that's it's not there
yet I I'm thinking three to five years
we might see some progress to that or he
may find it too expensive to put up the
number of satellites required to make it
consistently reliable
my correct there are other companies
though that have in the past have
have operated uh satellite internet or
different types of companies yeah
um and the reason I bring this up kind
of along the lines of Representative
lasalles
Senator Bradley mentioned uh last term a
bill that put a lot of money tens of
millions of dollars
to run lines in underserved markets or
not serve markets in the North country
and at that time I don't quote me on
this but when you did the math at how
many people they were going to serve how
many households versus how much money we
were putting out it ended up being some
ridiculous amount like twenty thousand
dollars per household I mean just insane
amount of money to spend for for that
amount of coverage so
oh
When I See This I and that's the reason
I asked you the question about how long
um
as an example GPS that is that's
operates worldwide
um
airplanes use it cars use it uh
everybody here has probably use it on
some on their phones I mean it's it's
it's something that that works so I'm
just
questioning the
the question ultimately comes to is in
three to five years let's say it's three
years
and satellite is available and it's uh
extremely cost effective and now the
towns have gone out with these bonds
and you end up at the situation like
Burlington Vermont or some of these
other ones that
have crashed and then who's going to be
responsible for those bonds is it going
to be the town districts who took them
out or is it going to be the entire
State taxpayers asked to subsidize it um
that's a concern of mine what would you
say to them
so I understand your concern as a town
that has gone out and and not used
revenue bonds but regular General
obligation bonds to partner with
Consolidated Communications to run fiber
to the premise
um three years ago
I can tell you that no one in town is
disappointed with that and that they all
are willing to pay the premium because
we pay an extra 11 a month on our bills
which covers the cost of the bond
uh and it uh it is it's working great
now is the town ultimately responsible
should something happen to Consolidated
Communications we would own the network
and be able to provide another find
another provider the fiber is up on the
polls and the equipment is available
however in this case we're looking at
Municipal revenue bonds so a
communication District would have the
ability to put out Municipal revenue
bonds which would be based on the
revenue of that communication District
not on an individual taxpayer and so if
it should go under it would be the
assets and the ownership of the re and
it's the revenue of the district that's
backing those bonds
and
um
and and so you know there is that risk
but the investors outside investors and
sometimes investors within the towns if
that should they desire that we'll be
paying
um will be
who would be the the individuals that
would be hurt right these would be
Municipal revenue bonds it's a utility
it's unlikely that that would occur it's
um the the experience
um of EC fiber is that once these are
your customers it is a it is just like a
utility you uh the the churn rate is
very low and they have routinely been
able to cover operations and their Debt
Service like any other company
um so I you know I think that you have
the asset up there if if it should fail
there would be another operator who
would be willing to run that asset
thank you seeing no more questions thank
you for your testimony we have one more
pink card Catherine heck
I was about to say good morning but good
afternoon members of the committee
chairman Turca representative power and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Catherine heck and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and today we are here to
voice our strong support for this
additional enabling legislation that
creates a new Financial tool for
communication districts to form and move
forward with revenue bonds which I think
um as Monroe did an excellent job of
explaining how revenue bonds are very
different from General obligation bonds
and how they function they are widely
used Nationwide and even here in New
Hampshire for water sewer projects for
example other Utilities
in larger cities they might use them for
a bridge project and collect a road toll
for example to pay for them so the onus
of that
risk Falls onto the investor rather than
the taxpayer so it's it's quite a
different um situation and I did want to
address that over the last four years
here in New Hampshire there's been a
great deal of legislation passed that's
enabling we're not a home rule state so
that municipalities can continue on the
work of building out Broadband to their
residents much like I think at some
point in time the federal government
realized that landlines were a necessity
we're starting to realize internet is a
necessity as well I think that I heard
the comment about satellites it is
unlikely anytime soon that satellites
are going to take over
um the share of the market over fiber
optic because of reliability and
affordability those are the two reasons
why we don't anticipate that happening
and that's widely
understood right now in the industry as
far as the mapping is concerned New
Hampshire the office of business and
economic Affairs and their Broadband
initiative division has taken on mapping
broadband and if you go onto their
website Broadband NH
they partnered with UNH to create a
comprehensive Broadband map so that we
can better understand our served and
underserved locations because as already
stated several hundred million dollars
through federal funds has throat flowed
in through New Hampshire these were not
state general funds these were federal
dollars to continue to build out
Broadband especially in our most
unserved areas recently just in February
CCI successfully received a bid to build
out in the North Country for 40 million
dollars and that will be taking place
over the next several years to bring
Broadband because it's incredibly
expensive to get Broadband you know in
those rural areas hanging that wire much
like it was with telephones the
difference is back in the day telephone
companies received a monopoly and had to
serve 100 of the people living with the
copper today we don't have monopolies so
we have to have these other Financial
Tools in order to bring Broadband to all
of our residents in a different way we
have great tools already we have public
private Partnerships communication
districts have been able to be formed
and then we have the federal dollars
coming in which again do require that
100 over 20 in order to even apply for
the grant you have to guarantee that
you're going to build out at that speed
in order for that the government to know
that it's a good investment in the
future because we continue to see those
speeds um changing and getting faster
so I'm certainly happy to take any
questions that you might have for me I'm
not a Broadband expert however I do
understand the financial components and
how important this is for the certainly
the 16 towns or the 15 currently that
have joined this Communications District
because they're unable to take advantage
of some of the opportunities they maybe
didn't qualify to receive the funding
directly from the federal government in
this way perhaps they were served enough
and the state chose to go into a
different location with some of the
federal dollars and they're maybe not
desirable for a public-private
partnership or P3 under the Chesterfield
model like my own town Greenfield and we
just heard that Dublin did which
everyone is extremely satisfied with so
they're looking for another
opportunity to bring that Broadband to
their community at no risk to the
general taxpayer
nice job four minutes I try
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much
Catherine for your testimony
all right I have no more pink cards uh
we have one signed up in favor on the
blue sheet and with that we will close
the hearing on Senate Bill 222
looks like we're about 30 minutes behind
we will
foreign
we will open up the hearing now on
Senate Bill 78 relative to subdivision
regulations on the completion of
improvements
I show Senator Innis
as the prime and only
all right good afternoon chairman
turcotte and members of the committee
I'm Dan Ennis representing District 7. I
live in Bradford New Hampshire and I'm
here to introduce Senate Bill 78. the
lack of affordable housing is one of the
main obstacles facing New Hampshire
families and our state's economy too
often government policies make building
housing more expensive than it needs to
be current law authorizes local planning
boards to require security such as a
performance bond or irrevocable letter
of credit against completion of a
subdivision which all makes sense the
law also requires that towns release
that security as the work is completed
I've heard from Builders around the
state that these regulations aren't
always being implemented consistently
from municipality admits municipality
with some of them not releasing the
security deposit or not responding to
requests or requiring
um or requiring case in violation of the
statute this bill would clarify the
existing subdivision regulations which
have been in place for about 10 years it
would increase the allowed cost
escalation factor from 10 to 15 percent
and it would require the release of a
bond within 20 days of the time the work
has been completed streamlining
subdivision regulations would help lower
the time and cost of bringing new
housing to Market without weakening the
security requirements requested by the
local planning boards this bill would
help ensure that all communities are
meeting the legal obligations that are
already in place and decrease
uncertainty for New Hampshire Builders
there are some folks who will follow me
in testifying and I would defer
questions to them they're much better at
answering them than I will be but I want
to thank you for your consideration and
your support and I think this is an
important tool in New Hampshire's
campaign to increase the supply of
affordable housing
if there are basic questions I'm happy
to take those
do we have basic questions for Senator
Ennis thank you representative power she
doesn't usually do basic questions I've
heard that thank you Mr chairman and
thank you senator in this for taking my
question of course pretty simple it's my
understanding that there's an amendment
associated with this bill and has
anybody
brought copies of that Amendment to the
committee hard copies because we'd like
to look at that do you not
representative infantine has those I
will make sure you have it in a number
of minutes if it's not already here
okay
representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you senator for taking
my question good to see you again good
to see you as well I apologize I don't
have the line number but I'm going to
the first bold which says and the cost
of remaining work yes do i it is it safe
I shouldn't say is it safe does that
mean relative to the cost of the entire
project or does that mean that the cost
that the entire cost can be reimbursed
say that again I didn't say it well
it says in that sentences phases of the
portion are are completed and approved
by the planning board correct then they
can decide how much of that can be
reimbursed yes and then that Clause says
end the cost of remaining work yes does
that mean that the cost for remaining
work the planning board could also
release all of that
or is the cost of remaining work just
relative to the entire cost of the
project my interpretation was relative
the entire cost
um
that's an interesting question okay
that's what I was hoping it would be
thank you yeah that must be the
amendment there
foreign
thank you senator for taking my question
but of course
um
I have a couple questions and one has to
do with the other part of the sentence
that representative majority was
referencing
um the at least one time every
365 days yes on the first page of the
the bill yes
if you are in a municipality and you're
planning office is responsible for
scores of developments across the city
on a regular basis
uh
would you think that this might impose
us a pretty serious amount of extra work
for planners and and staff and planning
offices to to maintain some kind of
okay
relapsing calendar that every 365 days
so and so's Bond needs to be it just
seems pretty Byzantine to me
um be frank uh it coming from a city
where there are many many developments
going on all the time that's my well
that's my first question yeah I I think
that's a valid question and it might
impose some additional work on
communities but I think it's one of
those cases where you have to look at
the trade-offs do we want more housing
do we want Builders to be able to do
this in a way that is an onerous for
them as well
um and and to me it's it's a cost
benefit thing
um yes it might require some extra time
from the communities whether it's town
or a city at the same time facilitating
construction to address the housing
issues that we have I think outweighs
that but there are probably folks from
municipalities who may testify who will
be better able to quantify that than I I
can tell you in most of my district it
wouldn't be onerous but my towns are
pretty small
follow-up
so the trade-off then
Lebanon would have to hire more staff
create new systems to track these things
accurately under the law should this
become law
and that cost would be passed along to
the taxpayers I can't answer that
question I think it would vary by
community and how much capacity they
have on hand presently but I don't know
the answer to that and I think it would
be different from City to city and town
to town thank you thank you
for the questions representative
majority thank you Mr chair and thank
you my question was answered in the
amendment so thank you and then I just
want to ask in section e new section E I
assume or is is it correct that that
section is added to give an enforcement
through the courts uh because I'm not
sure how else the shall in there is
enforceable or the question is how is
the shall enforceable in section e
which line are you on represent uh it's
it's throughout it's just okay the
timing you shall just shall be completed
within 20 days
you know in the ideal world we never get
to that point right right and I don't
think we would I mean I can't imagine a
town saying yeah you completed the work
but we're not releasing it I mean that's
just not the way we do business yeah
yeah so it's prescriptive maybe not
punitive how's that all right
seeing no more questions thank you very
much Senator thank you
next we will call Representative
infantine
thank you Mr chairman my name is Will
infantine I represent uh Hillsborough 16
which is a east side of Manchester
I serve on the Executive Board of the
Home Builders Association as well as
being an insurance agent where I have
been providing Surety bonds to people
for the last 35 years
so when the executive board sat down
nine months ago trying to determine what
we could do to make things easier to get
more building or housing units on the
market this was one of the things that I
came up with I actually tried to present
something to this committee eight or
nine years ago but
the desire to get more units on the
market wasn't as as um
important as it seems to be today so I
wanted to explain to you I do espouse
the virtues of Surety
Surety is as most of you know is a
guarantee you've all heard about a uh um
a bail bond it guarantees you'll show up
we've all heard about it in the news and
someone has to post bail there's all
kinds of things that require bonds
the point is to guarantee
um The public's money
so we post what we call Performance and
payment bonds if you build a school you
build a municipal building you build a
road it has to be bonded you provide a
performance bond to guarantee it'll be
done as per the specifications you need
to provide a payment Bond guaranteeing
that all bills and will be paid because
you can't lean a public building
so you must post a bond to make sure the
Public's money is secured and you get
what you pay for
um and you protect the public money
same thing with these bonds
I'm going to guarantee a developer will
guarantee they will do what they say
they're going to do if they're going to
have Granite curbs in that subdivision
then they're going to have to have
Granite curbs if they're going to have
so and so lighting they're going to have
to have a so and so lighting the
municipality wants to make sure it's
done because they don't want to have to
deal with if if someone goes belly up in
the middle of a project the things
aren't done the road can't be plowed the
road can't have emergency services to it
so you post a bond I'm all in favor of
that and have had a
good time doing it most of my career the
problem is no one's really following the
rules
in the city of Concord they decide
they're only going to reduce the amount
of a bond once from the full amount to
50 percent
that's it well that's in violation of
the law
I have something right here in my hands
in the town of Derry first of all Dairy
won't accept bonds well the law says you
have to accept bonds
so you have to push push get an attorney
involved and push them
and then when they do
they give you
one of these things one of your
questions representative Travis asked
about who has to do this almost every
municipality uses a an engineering firm
to determine what the bond amount should
be and the developer pays that and then
come up with a nice little form like
this it breaks down everything from
clearing and grubbing to gravel to sand
to erosion control to sight mitigation
all these things and it's all written
out here and at the end the law says you
can only add 10 percent to this this
one's 28 percent
I've seen some that are 30 or 35 percent
that they add on to the cost for the
bonds
in Kingston
I'm working on 11 months now since the
Project's been done and I still can't
get the town to release the bond
Londonderry has a bond form that's so
onerous no one will write on it
they've had to amend that because
they've been pushed back on a number of
times so there's all kinds of goofy
things that happen Rochester is a great
example Rochester has decided it's too
expensive for the developers to post
these bonds they let everyone start
working go ahead do what you need to do
cut trees get it ready get the gravel do
the asphalt but you can't sell a lot or
you can't ask for a building permit that
reduces the cost of the developer
and they get the guarantee they need
toward the end guess what that's not
legal right now that's not in the law
so the idea was to kind of Corral a lot
of these things that are being done
to make it consistent
I understand
um
it costs more today so be trying to be a
little magnanimous I increased the
percentage allowed from 10 to 15 percent
of the the maximum amount that the
municipality can add as a as a a buffer
amount so a lot of these things were
done just to make it easier because what
really happens in real life
a developer wants to
um
build a road cost three quarters of a
million dollars
to build a miles worth of Road actually
costs more but trying to make it easier
here
and they have to let's say they own the
land outright
it costs them they have to go to a bank
and get three quarters a million dollars
to build the road
then they have to post a bond if they
can't get a bond because it's either too
onerous or the town says well we're not
going to accept a bond they have to go
to the bank and get another 750 000
alone
to post for the bond
so now every time they sell a lot and
sell a home
let's say they would have something
called a lot release they have to give
the bank a certain amount of money
for every lot sold say a hundred
thousand dollars
so at the end of the
um they sell a lot they have to give the
bank x amount of money to pay off the
loan for the road and x amount to pay
off the bond
and that money just goes in goes pays to
the bank so at the end of the project
the you know the bank would have three
quarters of a million dollars of the
developers money they could use for
other things and the costs associated
with that because he has to post that
Bond
that's why they asked gee can we reduce
this once every 365 days or when
something significant has been completed
now I have written Bonds in Lebanon
since you mentioned that every town
has a has rules they all accept these
bonds they all keep a ledger of what's
going on they all inspect
many towns and cities require the roads
to be inspected every 30 days and the
developer has to pay the inspection fee
even though it's done by a third party
engineer that the town hires they know
when things are done they know when
things are being completed and then they
ask the engineer to do another one of
these little handy dandy reports that
everybody uses
and they can reduce that bond amount
it reduces the penalty the liability
that they have it reduces that loan if
they have an irrevocable letter of
credit or cash that they had to post in
order to get the bond so all these
things that are in here I know it's I do
this for a living I'm trying to be fast
here and I've been doing this for so
long
that I know this backwards and fourth so
I apologize if I'm trying to go through
it too fast but all the things that were
done here were done to try to make
things move faster
because sometimes more often out they're
not following the rules
and it's not because they do it on
purpose most of them when I bring up the
RSA to I'm like oh we didn't even know
that exists either just kind of rules
we've used
and I understand because I was alive in
the 80s when things went bad
and subdivisions were left uncompleted
okay and and so Tom said I want cash I
want cash in the barrel head I want to
be able to call it whenever I want I'm
going to call that cash I want to have
it in my hand
these handy dandy things come in really
uh good every once in a while because
the bonds are predicated on these things
and I've had Towns come back and say you
know we decided
we're not going to release your bond
because we want guard rails over on that
corner well that's fine and maybe the
guardrail should be there but you can't
hold my bond hostage because it's not in
the form that's not what was agreed to
so it works good for both
it keeps the developers
um doing their job the way they should
and also keeps the towns
um from doing what they need to do
so I'm sorry I went through that Mr
chairman I didn't want to go through too
much I'm sure there'll be a number of
questions I have been working with the
municipal Association and although we
have found some small air issues with
my Amendment some things that we gave to
um OLS did didn't come up out quite the
way we wanted they're not substantial
but there are some minor word changes
that I'm going to have to make either
way Mr chairman
very good the good news is we won't be
executing bills and probably until at
least the 10th so you will have as much
time as you need to do what you need to
do do we have any questions
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman
um
so just some clarifications for people
uh I spent over 50 years as an engineer
in construction but I just want to make
sure I understand some of the reasons
why you're doing this the the bonds are
paid for by the contractor the developer
correct yes and then the municipality
indirectly pays for that Bond through
the bid process through the award of the
contract correct no good that's what I
wanted to make sure that people
understand that no it's directly related
to the contractors
bid process but indirectly they include
a price for that Bond would you say yes
or no
I want to make sure I do in answering
your question declare something very
specific
when the municipality wants a school
or a road done you go out and you get
the money you put it out to bid all the
towns expense and you get it done and
there's a performance and payment bond
that is provided to guarantee those
things of the town
subdivision bonds what this is about is
totally separate this is a private thing
between the developer and the town the
developer has to pay for everything
pay for the permits pay for the bond pay
for the construction
and you whereas the other time you when
you're building a school you're paying
for all of it this thing the developer
pays for everything the municipality
gets the guarantee obligation
we're just kind of defining the rules
about how that transaction works but
there's every cost Associated pretty
much with a subdivision Bond or
subdivision whether it's the engineering
whether it's the inspection is all born
on the developer
now I'm not saying you don't have
employees okay in the municipality
they're doing the work obviously they
are but that's what you know a lot of
the the fees and permits are and the
costs associated with with getting all
of this approved and then selling these
homes is all about
representative Stevens
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
another question
um I just want to be clear about the
stated intent of the bill
um Senator Innis said that this was
about adding units of housing in a
housing crisis
I'm now hearing visits to make life
easier for developers and hold towns and
cities accountable and I'm not hearing
anything in that conversation about
affordability and I and I realize that
that's not the intent of this bill but
if but if the intent of the bill is to
put more housing units into the market
there is an affordability crisis
and I I'm going to go back to Lebanon
again we have 500 600 700 unit
developments going up none of these
units are affordable
uh so can you can you articulate
that the purpose of the bill
is to put more housing units on the
market but not necessarily affordable
housing units
or is it to hold planning boards and
municipalities feed to the fire in terms
of their own regulations which is it I
think it's a combination of all of them
except for I can't guarantee anything
about affordable
what is Affordable in each place and
what I'm trying to do
obviously the home builders wants to
what is the goal of the Home Builders
Association
build build more homes put more people
in homes okay
there is a cost associated with this the
analogy I used
about someone having to post a cash bond
which some
um
towns still think that they can force
and how you have to get that double loan
all these different things that you need
to do
in this 11 months someone still is
paying me every year and it's now a
whole nother year into it they have to
pay me for another Bond because the
municipality is still 11 months after
the job's been done approved signed off
on
the the town father still won't sign off
on it because they just haven't gotten
around to it all these things cost money
um the executive director of the Home
Builders Association is here and will
speak after me there's some astronomical
number of 60 some thousand dollars per
home when it comes to all the permits
all the bonding all the fees all the
things associated with putting a home on
it
we're trying to streamline the process
obviously if you streamline the process
it's going to reduce the cost
it's foolish
my I have a 23 year old daughter who's a
graduated college as a teacher
then I'm trying to help her find she you
know if you don't say
find a home
and so it's real to me as well
as to the cost so whatever we can do
these things go for condominium
associations as well when someone builds
this it's all the infrastructure bonds
that go through it so honesty I can't
guarantee it's going to put more
affordable housing depending on how you
want to Define that on the market but I
do feel it'll streamline the process
it'll make it cheaper and for the
developers to be able to reduce their
cost and yes there's a little bit of
let's everyone follow the same rules
can't be any more honest with you
representative representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
I watched the the Senate hearing and my
understanding was in part with regards
to that this bill addresses was that the
point
during the development at which these
Bonds were issued so I see language in
this amendment that that speaks to that
on page two lines three and four it
it states that
their there should there will be no
bond required prior just laying down the
infrastructure of the subdivision like
the roads as it says here utilities Etc
so
is that correct that a builder can in
can install those types of things prior
to having to go and apply for a bond is
that correct
as the exam I will I can't answer that
in a yes or no please allow me as I
stated briefly I explained what happens
in Rochester which again is illegal but
they do it anyway and no one seems to
mind they allow the Builder to start
building doing everything of the
infrastructure
prior to needing a bond however when
they then require a building permit or
sell a piece of land to someone who's
going to buy a lot there they must post
the bond to secure them it reduces the
amount of the bond the cost and the cost
of the developer they do that I'm trying
to make it legal here it says may now if
all the other towns if they still want
to say no
you don't touch a leaf on your land
before you post a full bond for the full
amount so be it that's okay too
but it allows other towns there's a
small I wrote a bond last year up in
Arrow
um and and they don't even require paved
roads up an arrow they were happy with
Bank Run gravel on the road
um and and they allowed the person to do
everything except that final work before
they could then sell a piece of property
so some people are doing this the point
of that paragraph is only make it legal
to what some people are doing anyway
but it's not saying that every
City in town must allow that
thank you
representative Majora you had your hand
up
thank you Mr chair and that was my exact
you just answered my question it was the
same it was a concern actually I uh I've
been dealing with the municipal
Association on this and we're going back
and forth and there was a comment
yesterday
um you know you're just trying to
eliminate bonds no
no I think they're darn right necessary
and they have to have something that
just a different way of getting to the
same end
representative stavis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking another question from of course a
planning board member
um
I have a question about wording in
section c
yeah we look at the amendment or the
original the amendment thank you very
much inspections required by the
municipality for at least not should be
completed with 20 days of written
requests delivered by hand request from
whom are by whom
especially
um
as as I said when when an inspection is
done
the municipality that does it with their
own forces and Concord has their own
people most everyone else uses it um the
um
uh municipality they want them to
produce one of these these reports that
show
um
what has been done what has been
completed
so the municipality would now
I'm as I mentioned Also earlier
um some of the things that OLS didn't
carry over in agreements with the um
uh Municipal Association we've increased
that to 30 days just as a
we've agreed to increase that
yes follow up thank you Mr chair I think
my my question has more to do with
from whom is the request coming oh the
developer asked the municipality I'm
sorry I would hope that that would be
clearer here in this language
where I can make it more clear it's it's
difficult when you're looking at
existing law and then you're trying to
paste an amendment on
um and the whole rest of the law isn't
there
um so I I think it is but I'm happy to
um I don't think Municipal Association
would have a problem if we made it more
specific either
representative Brown
yeah thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking another
question so just to refresh my memory I
think that contractors or developers are
when they apply for bonds they're only
allowed typically through their bonding
companies to have so much bond out is
that correct and that part of the reason
why you want to make this uh make these
funds return to these developers is it
so they have the cash flow that allows
them to continue to do work since they
only have since they have these limits
is that correct would you say that's
correct yes there are actually three
different ways you can post a bond cash
so obviously if you're posting half a
million dollars in cash you want the
municipality to reduce the bond amount
so you can get some of your money back
an irrevocable letter of credit from a
financial institution so when you get it
reduced you tell the financial
institution you show them the letter
they will reduce
um the collateral or whatever they have
for that and number three is the surety
bond which is based on your correct
total capacity of a bond which is all
based on financial underwriting
um they have give you a certain amount
of bond capacity
and it costs a certain amount of money
and when you reduce the bond it reduces
your cost on that in a
reduces your liability and allows you to
have you know have that capacity for
additional bonding final follow-up so uh
represented what you're saying to kind
of go back to representative stavis's
question the way this would help
developers and our communities to get
additional housing is because it frees
up their cash so they continue to do
additional work uh additional
development for the housing market
correct again reduces their expense of
the cost of the interest in borrowing
and yes thank you
without I might add
taking away what I feel is the security
needed by municipalities
representative majority thank you again
Mr chair and thank you again for taking
my question in the uh in the amendment
on line 22 other non-construction
reasons
um I'm just curious if if and you would
have the expertise here
if those need to be articulated you know
uh including but not limited to or
is that okay to have that language
because that was
better than what was it before I forgot
what the other one other similar reasons
right now as I say the law allows that
once you get a cost derived for what
they feel the cost of that subdivision
is right the municipality can add 10
percent right
um
what over the years people have done is
they've said well okay we're only adding
the 10 percent
now we're adding another 15 for
engineering another 10 for oversight
another five percent for this actually
you know the Bond's 145 percent of what
the cost is going to be so I was afraid
that if I said you can't be for
engineering or Administration someone
would come up with something else
okay well we can't we can only do fit so
and again
I understand the way life is so probably
should be 15 that's probably a little
more security for the municipality but
don't and if I can't add engineering and
administrative maybe I'll come up with
um I don't know
additional inspection fees or who knows
what you know and I just didn't want
this to
you have to keep following the ball
representative priests
uh thank you Mr chairman um I have
several questions on page two
um of the amendment uh on line three why
couldn't the line the planning board may
not require be changed to May required
so it doesn't sound so negative and that
the planning board might not require a
bond but they may require a bond
foreign
I think you have to go back to the
original law that is in place
unfortunately
because the original law says
you must you shall
the the current law which we're not
amending says you shall
okay so this basically says you shall
post a bond and then however the
municipality May at their own discretion
choose to do it a little differently
okay
a follow-up please on line six
um
shall not require a bond form be used
that is so onerous
how do you find owners that local
bonding companies will not approve it
could you give me a definition of that
they they will put a a bond form in
place that has what we call
immediate call language or forfeiture
language
so they get into an argument with a
developer one day and someone gets mad
I'm calling the bond the bond says you
will pay cash within 24 hours by
certified check into our accounts
that is not the concept of Surety ship
you post a bond you call the bond if you
don't like what's going on okay the
municipality has the right to do that
Bonding Company usually has 30 days to
go in Meet see the job see what's going
on if the developers broke Bonding
Company steps in and finishes it if
they're into a a an angry conversation
that people are angry with each other
all right everyone this is serious stuff
you just call this bond this is a
legally binding contract why don't you
settle this out and get it done
but these these these um I've seen it um
they put in these things that no one in
their no body company in the country
would agree to
representative Tatro
thank you Mr chair and and thanks
try and clear up something that a lot of
us don't understand I'm sorry
um
what
if you can't get a bond
fill the roads and the utilities that
have been in
uh installed and so forth
um
the development goes on
and the roads don't hold up to the
construction equipment that's going
across it
now
if they've built it
who who's going to end up paying for
that the taxpayers
to fix our own
um what ends up happening uh
realistically
is that
um use your example
the bonding company or the municipality
says You must Bond 100 of it up front
so they post a bond for 100 of it every
time something gets done there's
inspection requirements whether it's the
gravels the compaction certain amount of
asphalt asphalt has to be tested to make
sure it meets a certain whatever right
most municipalities will not allow the
final course of asphalt until all of the
work is done all the homes are built so
there's no construction equipment going
on
then you're allowed to put the final
coat of asphalt down then you have to do
the final landscaping and then
municipalities require what's called a
10 maintenance Bond on every single
project every single subdivision and for
up to one year a bond of ten percent of
the amount of the project must be put in
place and the municipality has at least
one more year then to call that Bond or
to tell them to fix it fix the
Landscaping that that didn't the trees
it didn't take or the the wash away a
rut that was caused by a heavy rain and
if that road doesn't hold up again
that's what that maintenance spawned for
but municipalities you know pretty smart
and and everyone kind of follows the dot
rules for building roads you know you
can't lay asphalt unless it's 40 degrees
and rising and all the other stuff
which is why most municipalities will
make you wait 18 months could go through
at least one winter before you lay the
final coat of asphalt because they want
to see what happens because if the base
coat doesn't hold up they're not going
to let you put the final course on so
the goal
representative is to have everything
okay before you put the final course of
asphalt you have one year maintenance
guarantee and a bond and then hopefully
those roads will last 20 years but yes
eventually like every Road in every town
will eventually be have to be repaved
after 20 or or so years
that's just the way it is now I'm not
changing anything follow up please go
ahead
um
that's kind of my point I unless I'm
reading this differently you're not
allowed to
uh require a bond for the infrastructure
and
if it all goes
a couple a week after the first winter
and they go oh well
you know what who's left out to hang
that is not whether I just I will
politely disagree with you
um that's not what the bond does I mean
the the bill does the current law states
that you must
shall post a bond
this amendment says you may
that Miss Ali May then asked to post a
bond
after a significant amount of work has
been done
before you either sell the land
or ask for a building permit that does
not in any way shape or form reduce the
municipality's requirements that they
that the roads the construction up to
that time period be inspected nothing
changes
they still have to have it inspected it
still has to be approved and then the
bond has to be put in place for that
remaining amount and if it fails that
remaining amount of the bond is
available to do that
thank you
representative Edward
thank you Mr chairman and
nice to see you today sir
um on line
of the amendment to SB 78.
um do you happen to know if the term
substantial improvements is
statutorily defined somewhere else in
674. I
I've read that I think in the
subdivision regulations but I can't
remember if they have a definition of
what a substantial Improvement is
I am
I'm remiss because I don't have the
original Law 674 in front of me right
now right I just I believe it's in there
um
you know you're right let's be honest
intelligent people need to agree uh
you're doing five thousand dollars worth
of work is not substantial
finishing all the clearing and grubbing
and putting all the gravels in is a
substantial amount of work
I I don't you know I I guess I could
Define it for you for more than 10
percent of the project
um I'm happy to do that
um
you know usually cooler heads prevail
someone says Hey I want an inspection
well we just did one like 30 days ago
and you really didn't do much so no
we're not going to do it
um
my goal was not to make the original law
has has kind of worked for a number of
years other than a few tweaks around the
edges I don't want to make it so
litigious that I start adding all these
things that someone's gonna
start throwing in and well substantial
means more than 10 percent
I'm happy to do it uh it's from my
knowledge
the engineers and and the contractors
know when substantial is and they've
always been able to agree uh but I'm
happy to do that
thank you very much
for the questions
representative Tatro could you thank you
very much
seeing none representative I have just a
couple
um you mentioned
the
that towns and cities now do not abide
by the current irsas what is the current
remedy
that the towns have on that
other than lawsuits so it's lost in
Derry it was a uh a motion for summary
judgment written by an attorney
and the town said yeah okay you're right
we'll accept the bond even though they
hadn't done it for 10 years I mean no
one wants to do that you haven't seen it
the construction in New Hampshire we
have eight or nine months that's it you
have to do infrastructure in that that
period of time
and you go to court you lose an entire
season and that's just more costs
associated with carrying costs of where
everything else so nobody wants to get
into an argument with the municipality
because it's a no-win situation with our
seasons
totally understand which brings me to my
next question do you believe the changes
that you're proposing in here will that
stop the towns from violating the rsas
I think it'll make it more clear for
them I every time like when I had to get
involved with concord
I talked to the attorney in Concord and
he said well I'm sorry well I mean I'm
reading the law too but these are the
rules we're given so I call the mayor of
Concord and
talked to him for 10 minutes he goes yep
okay I'll get back to you and sure
enough the next day is like follow the
law please you know and and dairy and
and they kind of came around and and in
Kingston who kind of put this and said
you know come on guys do you have a time
period you got to do this
um and usually they come around no one
purposely does this everyone's you know
they have their own rules and
regulations that they're following in
their town no one ever pulls out 674
during the day to compare and contrast
their rules
so it's nice to have something that and
and quite frankly every time I do push
the issue everyone's pretty good about
it you know they okay sorry didn't know
that sure we'll we'll get moving
so will this stop them from violating do
you think or just simply yes I think it
gives them a better road map to be able
to to do it because like everything else
everything is evolving
okay our society has evolved since the
80s when they put these things in place
construction is faster it's quicker it's
more you know using less men more
machines you know we used to do it with
a you know a Transit you know now you're
doing with GPS to make things levels so
many things are happening so much faster
that you know it's okay every 20 years
to update
understood
two more
um what what do you see as a potential
downside risks to the changes do you see
any
to be honest I tried to look at it
from every different direction
I looked at it from the Home Builders
Association that wanted no bonds I said
no that's not going to work I wanted to
take it from my standpoint I wanted to
do my job easier I wanted to do it from
trying to help the develop but not give
the developer too much because you know
what happens if you give a developer for
too much they take give them an
instantly take a yard type thing so I
really tried to that's why I increased
the percentage to 15 I I try to do my
best to make it even for everybody so I
don't really see any downside here if
anything I make a few more people that
are doing things illegally right now
legal but no I don't representative I
don't
uh last one is more of a language
structure issue if you and maybe nature
whoever's going to be redrafting
whatever you guys redraft
when you look at uh page one
Roman numeral three
the last line of that paragraph says the
regulations or practice of the planning
board and then you have a b and c that
say may shall May then you go over to
the second page
d and e do not follow the language
structure those probably should be
separate items because if you actually
read it the regulations or practice of
the planning board the planning board
limitations under this paragraph it just
doesn't flow correctly so
um I don't know if you make DNE separate
paragraphs or whatever but
yes valid point we'll try to make some
changes okay
um one final one the reason on uh the
second page for eliminating the section
about uh fire suppression what was the
thought process behind that
because it's already illegal I'm going
to let
um
uh Mr Clegg
who was involved with developing that
law answer that question that's fine
thank you
no more questions thank you very much
representative
thank you sorry to give you a goofy
tutorial on Surety I apologize if it was
it was choppy
next we do have represent uh Robert
kleich
thank you and just just to be clear
um we are kind of working off what you
kind of are proposing as an amendment
and not that first part yet we
anticipate there's going to be further
work done correct correct okay very good
go ahead for the record I'm Robert clay
I'm here representing the home builders
I am a developer and I wish you'd give
me an inch will because I take three
inches not the yard but
um I just want you to know that I'm part
of the reason why you see what you see I
have an a development right now with
four lots that I can't even register
unless I post a 96 000 Bond because
that's what the city engineer wants
so that 96 000 just so you know goes
towards every single lot and it's why we
have no longer the ability to make of
affordable housing we don't even call it
affordable housing anymore we call it
attainable
I used to sell a house for 350 000 in
2020 that I can't even build today
for 350 000. so we have to figure out
where to go and how to make things go
this is one of the things when we talk
about putting in the infrastructure
and it says in here once I asked for a
building permit where somebody's
actually going to live I have to pull
the bomb and I don't have a problem with
that but in the meantime I still have to
get permits to put in my sewer my water
and I have to have inspections before I
can bury it so I'm not doing anything
that isn't already seen I'm not causing
any more problems for the local building
inspectors because they have to do that
anyways I'm just saving some money
even if it's a cash a bond like
Nashville requires cash
that's money that's sitting there that I
can't use
to make things work so if I have to
borrow money and it's ten percent or
seven percent I add it to the price of
the house I mean we're in business
so this would allow me to put in all my
infrastructure it would also allow me to
put down my first coat of Paving my
first coat of Paving as well infantein
said is what we call the binder and it's
there forever but I have to have it
inspected I have to have the gravel and
everything else inspected before I can
actually put the pavement down so I
haven't I haven't lost anything the
community hasn't lost anything all the
inspections are the same there's just no
money sitting in a bank someplace that I
can't use
when we look at the inspections required
by the municipality for release of a
bond
the idea is that
if the municipality says these are the
inspections you have to have and there
is some changes someplace
um then I have to notify them
I can't just sit there and say well you
never showed up
I have to notify them and when I say
that you sit there and not show up
um septic systems is a good example if
you're building a septic system and you
call them and they don't show you just
bury it so this says you have to you
have to call them you have to give them
so many days I guess we're going to
change it to 30 business days and you
have to give it in writing or by hand so
there's no question that you asked for
it and no question that they didn't know
so we're actually trying to give
something back to the communities and
not take it away
the other question is is um
in the second part somebody asked the
question about the municipality shown
spec for completion of work cited as
incomplete or non-compliant
within 10 business days of written
notification
the problem or the reason there is that
if I miss something I'm not talking
about anything that went on the ground
but let's say that I said I was going to
put in 10 trees and there were only
eight it doesn't take much to come down
and see that there's two more trees put
in or maybe I didn't put in the bounds
so I have to do all that there are small
things that shouldn't take a lot of time
it's oops you didn't do something
somebody comes down it shouldn't take
you more than 10 or 15 minutes so that's
why we put in the short notice
um
someone asked what happens when the
cities of towns ask for stuff that it's
not legal
there's a thing that says go along the
get along so I have cash bonds out there
because certain places require it I can
argue it
but I'll tell you that arguing with an
engineer or somebody who's now going to
inspect your work isn't real smart
you're better off to just go along to
get along and that's why we came here to
do something you know I've been a member
of my community for a long time as far
as Selectmen and Council and
planning board and all that stuff so so
I get it and I and I know that we don't
want anybody to come in and do something
wrong that's not what this bill's trying
to do it's trying to make everybody do
something right together but it really
does matter
and and I only build affordable housing
I only build family housing we used to
build three family three three bedroom
family houses with hardwood floors and
selling for 350 and we can't and when
you look at the people out there trying
to trying to get a mortgage today
mortgage is a six and a half percent to
seven percent so if you used to qualify
for a hundred thousand dollar house you
only qualify for 250 000 house today and
it's a real problem so anything we can
do to lessen the cost to the Builder
then it lessens the cost to the consumer
I know you guys are hungry so I'll take
any questions if you have any
of course representative stavis
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so does that mean
based on what you just said that if your
costs are lower you're going to pass
those savings along to the home buyer
absolutely we do
thank you
a representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
my concern now about this because I
as a planner I agree with what you have
put down because I think the game rules
haven't been played and haven't been
enforced by both parties and that's been
a concern of mine
make the distinction between the urban
areas that have the staff they have the
inspectors the engineers
to do this work versus the rural areas
that may have one planner
and maybe one building inspector and
they maybe
contract with an engineer
to me
it makes sense for the bigger areas
bigger cities but for the smaller ones I
think this might be a burden to them
thank you I I don't I don't see it that
way I work in some of the smaller
communities who don't have building
inspectors and and don't have Engineers
if we're doing a big project usually the
cost of an engineer to the community
falls on me
um and and when we ask for inspections
uh um of anything that's in here it's
usually done 30 days is usually more
than enough time especially if you're
using a contract
um inspector I used to represent the New
Hampshire building officials and and I
know that some of them did double duty
in certain towns so usually they were
available in 10 to 15 days so I really
don't think that the smaller towns would
have to worry I think the only time a
small community is going to have a
problem
is when somebody comes in to put a
high-rise apartment building and then
what normally you do and developers have
to pay is you hire an engineering firm
to work for the town side
um and as developers we're pretty smart
we know that we don't want to aggravate
the engineering cause any more
additional payments because we're paying
for it so I think I think the small
community is okay
further questions
I have one Mr Clark
um
for the most part are all the current
requirements that you as a developer run
into are they
City and town regulations rules zoning
and that kind of stuff those the issues
that you run up against in the
we run up against all those a few years
ago in the legislature we passed a
Statewide building code
and that made it a lot easier for us
because it was supposed to be able to go
from Community to community and have the
exact same regulations
so
I know you asked about the sentence at
the bottom what's that you asked about
we took out nothing in this paragraph on
the bottom oh the sprinkler yeah sure
the reason why we took it out is because
the law actually says you can't do that
so there's a law that says the
communities can't do that in 155. so
what we did was we cited 155 in the top
and says in accordance with 153.5 I'm
sorry Roman numeral three
the communities can't do that and that
was to protect I will say it's to
protect the Builder because I built some
units with some houses with sprinklers
and Liberty Mutual came in and gave me
30 days to shut them down or I'd lose my
insurance because they pay more and
water damage from sprinklers than they
do from fires
okay thank you very much seeing no more
questions thank you very much for your
testimony uh thank you Gary Abbott
you're up
uh thank you chairman committee members
for the record my name is Gary Abbott
I'm the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I represent large commercial
and Industrial contractors a little
different than the home builders but I'm
here today to support Senate bill 78.
um I probably am going to include a
little bit answering some of the
questions
I've been involved with legislation
regarding third-party oversight that
towns are allowed on the larger
commercial projects for the site work
and the development and I think what you
just heard a little bit of is there is
there's an awful lot of requirements
that a contractor or developer have to
go through and agree to and those
third-party inspections are paid by the
developer or contractor who does the job
so there already is a process on that
early part of any project where there's
oversight and control and inspections I
think the other point that was a
question that was brought up that's very
big to us is
any company or developer has a bonding
capacity that he can get a bond for so
it's very important on this second part
of this bill is the release of the bond
and that's the whole having the town
release portions of the bond and not
having my total bonding capacity tied up
in any one project or multiple projects
as a contractor or developer you want to
do numbers of projects you don't want to
be limited by your bonding capacity and
that is all Financial but it's a major
thing I think there are some this this
bill gives guidance to both the
developer and the municipality now the
reason I was involved with third party
inspections which is a different part of
the session is because the same kind of
thing that's happening here
there were towns that were going beyond
what was they were making rules that
weren't necessarily compliant with what
made sense and the costs were getting
awful high for any developer to
Encompass those so we worked on language
to make sure that was clear in the
statutes I see the same thing happening
here we're trying to make sure the
bonding routine that the municipalities
fall at least a guideline that you have
in the legislation so therefore there's
not abuse on either side and the
developer gets their bond back in a
timely fashion I know you're working on
the amendment and I'm glad to hear the
municipal Association and the home
builders and the sponsor Prime sponsor
working on language because I think that
Clarity is necessary and so far what I
see is I think this is progress to
clarify it compared to what we have in
the statutes now and so I would hope the
committee would support the Senate Bill
78 and thank you you when I take any
questions the committee may have
thank you Mr Abbott any questions
get off easy no questions thank you very
much
uh last pink card we have Nate Grace
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members Nate Graves for the municipal
Association
um
has stated we are
we we have a compromise on uh on the
language of the bill I do want to point
out one thing in that compromise to you
that wasn't captured unfortunately by
OLS yesterday as they were drafting this
page two lines three through five that's
the second sentence on page two it's
going to read a planning board may allow
Road and utility construction to start
without a bond however a bond for the
infrastructure roads and utilities May
must be in place prior to the sale of
any parcel of land within the
subdivision or a request for a building
permit for structures for human
occupation I think that
um
all right I know that three committee
members had questions about that
particular sentence
um and we think that will work better to
capture uh what actual practice is as
you've heard extensively today uh the
statute as it exists now doesn't reflect
what actual practice is and we'd like to
align the statute better with practice
and also
in the spirit of a good compromise I I
think that no one got quite everything
they wanted but I think we all agree
this is the best possible outcome
I'm happy to take any questions that the
committee may have representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so my question
pertains to page two and lines six
through seven I'm concerned that the use
of the word onerous
is very vague and subjective do you have
any other suggestions as to how to
address that concern in the language of
the bill that's more specific
I do not that is
one issue that was raised during
discussions and that's what we
ended up on
but we're we will discuss it further
after this hearing today and get you a
final amendment by close of business
Friday is my goal
representative tomorrow yes represent
the infantine disagrees with you on that
just so you know
um any any other questions
seeing that I do have one Niche um
Mr cleghead I asked him about rules
regulation zoning by the cities and
towns as you're well aware in our this
committee we've had three bills this
year
the four units on a single family we've
had the
um
what were the other two rent control and
we had another one which would have 80
use added the adus double and each one
of those the
we will We felt and it was in a very
vast bipartisan man uh manner to be
mandates from above
from the state down to towns so
in your opinion
why or why not is this a state mandate
going down to the towns and cities
so
I don't think it's a state mandate I
think it's Clarity on the existing
Surety Provisions in the statute
um
one of the uh one of the issues that I
think representative infantine
highlighted is that uh different
communities are
have different regulations relating to
sureties and there's also obviously
industry practice which he's way more
familiar with than I am
um and we need to make sure that
industry practice and kind of the local
regulations line up under State Statute
to ensure that everything that's being
done is lawful because we don't want a
situation where we would be encouraging
lawsuits or uh discouraging building
because there's uh there's not Clarity
and so that was the attempt here in
front of you today uh is the result of
the discussions to provide that Clarity
to ensure that we have that local
flexibility that we that we prize or at
the same time really making sure our
state statute which uh I believe is
written
um as in a response to what happened in
the 80s
um lined up with uh what industry
practices and current construction
practice which I understand has changed
quite significantly since that time
thank you further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you I have no more pink cards the
blue sheet had two signed in in favor
and with that we will close the hearing
on SB 78
our next one
couple minutes
our next our next uh Committee hearing
is scheduled for two but we will begin
um and we'll go at 210 how's that
so we'll see everybody at 210
all right
hey that's the kind of guy I am
um
okay
thank you
um
thoughts
somebody
foreign
okay
you don't have a clerk
that's true
scribble yeah we'll wait till John gets
back
give us two minutes Center we're waiting
for our Clerk
and here he is
everybody uh members of the committee
and individuals in the room
unfortunately we cannot have anything at
the tables other than water no food no
sodas any of that so if you could kind
of
put those somewhere please thank you
okay gonna open up the next hearing on
Senate Bill 47
that is establishing a commission to
study barriers to increase density of
residential development in New Hampshire
and
I'll get it right this time Senator
Perkins quoka is back with us
chair your fast learning why they put
you in charge
all right
um good afternoon
for the record I am Senator Perkins
quoka from the Senate District 21 city
of Portsmouth and several surrounding
communities I'm here today to introduce
SB 47 and act establishing a commission
to study barriers to increased density
of residential development in New
Hampshire
this commission was a continuation of a
prior commission which meant from
September 2019 to November 2020 but was
curtailed due to covet it did not have
the chance to complete its work most
importantly
determining minimum standards for
residential density by considering
public water and sewer and other
appropriate Alternatives accounting for
the variability of environmental
conditions property tax incentives to
promote residential development and
exploring the possible method of
enforcement of the shared Community
responsibility of Workforce housing
under RSA 674 5861.
since the time of that previous
commission ended the housing crisis has
grown even worse with a shortage of what
we thought to be 20 000 units Statewide
now increasing to be just under 24 000.
the Council on housing stability has
completed a review of all state
regulations affecting Housing
Development and found that Des septic
system and capacity septic system citing
and capacity requirements are far more
astringent than surrounding New England
states this increases the cost of inland
area required to build housing in areas
lacking in water and sewer some
communities have found ways to tackle
this dual housing and affordability
crisis but there are many others who
have not
statistics from the New Hampshire zoning
Atlas highlight the current barriers to
Housing Development created by local
land use regulations only 34 percent of
residential and mixed-use Zoning
districts throughout the state
representing 16 percent of the state's
buildable area allow single-family
housing on less than an acre
only 28 of residential and mixed-use
Zoning districts representing 11 percent
of the state's building area allow
duplexes on less than an acre only 38
percent of residential and mixed-use
Zoning districts representing 21 percent
of the state's buildable area allow for
five or more family housing units on on
Lots under two and a half acres
layering on top of these regulations are
others such as parking and lot
requirements that affect our housing
Supply Statewide
it is understandable why local
regulations can be a barrier unknowingly
to housing in New Hampshire and helping
our communities achieve their housing
goal requires cooperation and support
from us at the state level
the reconstitution of this commission
will help develop these Solutions and
guidance so that our cities and towns
can provide local custom ordinances
based on some helpful groundwork laid at
the state level
the committee Amendment brought on the
Senate side was from my friends Senator
gray and Senator Murphy to just adjust
the membership of the committee slightly
but other than that Senate Bill 47
passed the Senate on a Voice vote
so I would be happy to take any
questions
thank you questions representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question so um my
question pertains to if this bill were
to become law in in light of the fact
that we have
um a special committee
on commissions and committees and then
also I would just I was I'm aware of
there is a bill Senate bill 84.
that was hijacked by Senator gray and it
also has something whatever his
amendment was it IT addresses the
composition of the Committees and the
commissions so how if this were signed
into law can you speak to how this bill
and the the ability for it to move
forward might be affected by either of
that house committee that's been stood
up and or
like sustenability for in particular
thank you yeah thank you representative
power I I can't speak to the house
committee on commissions because I don't
um know their procedures but as far as
SB 84 the membership of our
commission would be compliant regardless
of whether SB 84 passes so I believe
that
one of the requirements there is that at
least half the members of the commission
be legislators and so this is compliant
in that eight of the 15 members are
legislators here
further questions
representative lasalles
thank you for taking my question how
would this fit in with the special
committee on Workforce housing that is
uh I assume is still meeting
yeah so my understanding is that um that
special committee is composed entirely
of legislators and so it would be
different from this Commission in that
the membership
here includes a lot of
um experts on housing policy in the
state and so if you look back to their
reports I actually was able to attend
this group a few times while it was
still meeting it's
it's housing experts sort of tackling
really technical issues
um that they know about from their
professional experience I think that
it it sort of arrives in a different
Lane you know than our legislators who
are sort of hearing about the issue and
and thinking about other policy
Solutions on a different level
thank you
representative yokawa
um I'm over here
that's fine
um
thank you for taking the question
do you believe that the
um
that the
this proposed committee might
be able to be
utilized or help
um that special committee on housing in
the house
um maybe identify uh
issues that we may not have uh
found yet
thank you thank you for the question
representative and vice versa if you
were done I didn't mean to cut yeah
that's fine okay
um I think that they very much could
work in tandem I think that they're you
know policy Solutions and and sort of
problems that are brought to legislators
that we are often very reliant on our
sort of subject matter experts to help
us develop Solutions on and so
um again when I attended this commission
um before it was curtailed
that's a place where I think problems
that are raised in the legislature can
really be addressed in detail and
um I know the special committee on
housing is also trying to serve as a
place to generate ideas
um you know going forward I think that
the work that this commission does
really could support that goal hand in
hand
oops there we go representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions
it seems to me the group that's going to
have the most impact on this this
commissioner is going to have on is a
local planus
and I don't see anybody on this
commission that's going to give any
input
to local to this commission about local
issues because this commission is going
to impact on the cities and towns
depending on what legislation they come
come up with our rules and regulations
so where is the uh input to this
commission from the plant local planners
is it going to come from outside as
testimony or as
you know how you how can we change this
so that there's at least one planner are
planning for a member local planning
board member sure thank you for the
question so
um
just to be clear I think the intent is
that
this be a commission that identifies
Solutions so it certainly wouldn't be
imposing anything on anybody
um just to sort of be clear about that
but you know to your point everything
that they would recommend would be
implemented locally and so making sure
that it's feasible locally is important
we do have in the in lines
um 21-23
you know someone to represent planning
interest in um that includes someone
from the planners Association which is
composed of local planners New Hampshire
Association of regional planning
commissions and the New Hampshire
Municipal Association which as you know
you know represents local planners so I
I don't know if that fully addresses
your concern but it is something that
you know we tried to address in the
membership
I think we're both naive if you think
that they're not I'm going to impose any
rules or regulations in the local
communities
so I I have a problem with that and as
long as there's not a member on a
commission I could not vote for it
and if they may follow Mr chair just to
um and I you know respectfully I just
wanted to add I didn't respond to the
other part of your question there
certainly would I would think the
opportunity for local planners to join
them you know to testify for their
meetings as well thank you very much
okay thank you representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and and thank you
for taking my question
um this is a great effort that you're
undertaking how much of this was done
prior to the onset of covet and he had
to shut down with any of this
yeah the commission was able to meet and
I know a couple of the commission
members are here and so can can speak
more fully
um
after me but they were able to complete
um an impressive body of work that was
issued in a in a sort of interim report
at the end you know during covid but in
that report they also mentioned that
there were things they were charged with
that they were not able to complete so
I'm gonna let them sort of correct this
but my impression was sort of they got
to do maybe two-thirds of their work and
not the last third
follow up
sorry
thank you so much thank you so much Mr
chairman um
is would it be possible that
when you're
like halfway through
this project that you have a public
hearing
and just solicit public input from all
the communities
I think that would be very beneficial
and you'll you will receive a greater
buy-in would this be possible I I would
think so again it's um you know the
benefit of having a commission is that
um
it includes folks who are very
experienced in the field and so again
when I attended this commission prior to
its um
prior to covid it you know it was
certainly soliciting input on certain
topics you know on a on a sort of
meeting agenda as it went through so
that was my experience with it
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question
um I've been in several recent meetings
in both my district and in the in the
county delegation recently where
local residents have spoken in regard to
their concerns about groundwater issues
groundwater capacity in light of the
recent droughts that we've had I see
over in line 15 that you talk about
environmental services where they're
designated being part of the commission
but there seems to be a a lot of concern
about groundwater in particular the
capacity in people as well as drying up
so and people have talked to me about
cluster development and those types of
things which have not been that positive
so how are you going to address those
concerns I understand you're going to
have experts but is that something that
has been in the Forefront in regard to
this discussion
yeah thank you for your question
representative
um all of these things go very much hand
in hand and
um out of
an effort that was I think
um
in 2007 and 2008 was something called
the growth and development Roundtable
and it was an attempt to make sure that
housing and conservation were very
closely aligned so that we were
developing housing in a responsible way
I think many of us share the goals that
um
housing be very compatible with the
natural environment that we all enjoy
and so to get to your question
specifically about groundwater you know
the long-term supply of groundwater and
drinking water is something that I think
is traditionally addressed
um more in the environmental sphere I
know I'm on the long-term commission for
drinking water over on the Seacoast and
we're talking about sort of salination
of groundwater supplies and sort of
long-term conversion from Wells to
public water
in my mind is only sort of helped by the
conversation of responsible development
and sort of identifying you know
where in our communities is the
appropriate place for us to be seeking a
solution to housing and where is an
inappropriate place and I think
um without being thoughtful about that
um
many towns and cities may have
ordinances that unintentionally
are allowing housing on land that was
previously undeveloped or requires you
know sort of bigger Lots than they need
and so
I guess in my opinion the more a thought
is going into this field the better
um and so allowing
sort of Housing and particularly septic
requirements and sort of sewer and water
density requirements to be something
that's now being discussed in
conjunction with housing I think just
kind of reflects the forward thinking
that you're talking about so
yes I hope so yeah
representative majority
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking a question sure
um my town I'm sure a lot of other towns
work with their Regional planning
commissions on the rewrites for master
planning which usually includes future
land use chapters do you anticipate that
this commission will at least explore
grant opportunities to provide that
information should a community say we
need a complete rewrite
based on the information provided
well representative
um I happen to have a bill another bill
that addresses that question as well but
yeah I think that
um when towns and cities do make the
decision that they need to audit or look
at their local regulations it's it's an
undertaking and it's expensive
um to have someone sort of redraft that
zoning so there is the housing Champions
program that has passed through
um two Senate committees and has been
tabled to be put in the budget that
would create a a municipal grant program
to support
audit and rewrite of zoning regulations
that said I think that one of the
um Concepts that's been discussed with
this Commission on and off and I know I
was just talking to one of our speakers
before this is
being able to develop some model zoning
which would make it a lot easier for
towns and cities to have at their
disposal something that's drafted that
they can kind of customize locally so
not directly in this program perhaps but
you know certainly supporting that
effort
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony we have
five pink cards up here right now uh we
have another hearing coming up at
three o'clock so we are going to uh use
a three minute time limit most of you
have put three minutes or less
so we will use three minutes for a time
limit when Vice chairman Powell a
chairwoman power puts her uh pink card
up that means you have a half minute to
go so with that The Honorable Ivy van is
next
thank you Mr chairman thank you former
honored colleagues it's nice to be here
I'm here to speak in favor of SB 47
um I think that the thing about sp-47
that is crucial is the fact that it is
intended to take on some fairly
technical things that need to be
addressed in order to allow
historically appropriate
building in New Hampshire no one wants
to see New Hampshire become Manhattan
and I don't see that any of the things
listed in this proposal are going to
send us there
uh the two things that I thought were
particularly important was the whole
question of discussing with the
Department of Environmental Services
their standards Des has not had a chance
to update their their septic standards
and a number of years and in the
meantime there have been quite a great
many developments that allow for uh
perfectly safe and adequate often
producing potable water
septic systems that are not a standard
septic tank and giant leech field right
now you cannot install any of those
systems in New Hampshire unless you also
build a twenty thousand dollar leach
field because the Des standards require
that leech field I've talked to a number
of people people recently as I'm working
as a consultant for the Housing
Opportunity planning grants and so I've
been talking to people in small towns
about
you know what they see as issues and I
have and this is anecdata but I've had
more than one person tell me that they
had to they were going to replace their
septic system because it had failed they
wanted to put in a much more efficient
and less expensive system that is you
know has been approved in other states
but they can't do it here because Des
has not yet updated their standards so
I'm very interested in that piece of
this committee I think that's crucial
the other thing is the whole question of
a model ordinance a model ordinance is a
really really useful full tool
in New Hampshire many of the towns
are more alike than they are different
63 percent of New Hampshire's towns do
not have Municipal Water and Sewer
and we could create a good model
ordinance that could be calibrated to
those towns and this is a good way to
get started on that
um so in in short I think that SB 47 is
very different from the commission that
is being that's being spearheaded by
representative Alexander in that these
are really technical nitty-gritty fixes
that we need to take on in order to
address our housing issue which gets
worse every minute and I'm happy to take
any questions uh questions
representative Guthrie I just have a
quick question and I'm glad to hear you
sounds like you're working in the front
lines on septic system doing my best
well it seems that particularly in a
small town like I come from Hampstead we
have septic systems no water but we're
going to have water in about next four
or five years it's coming down
into our towns so my question is do you
know when you'll be able to have that
rewriting or whatever has to happen on
this septic system so that we can have a
better system but uh less
uh requirements well what has to happen
is that the Department of Environmental
Services has to address has to
re-evaluate their standards and what we
would what I would expect would come out
of this this
um commit committee is um a list of
proposed changes
um I know that the EPA has produced
documentation on small systems for small
towns that were essentially originally
developed for the colonias on the Mexico
Texas border so they're small systems
that are suitable for small
neighborhoods so that would be one thing
that would be on the list the Fuji
system which I mentioned earlier so what
this commission would do is say okay
here are some other systems that have
worked in other places we need the Des
in New Hampshire to take a look at these
and and rewrite their standards to allow
these so it's not going to be fast I'm
sorry representative Guthrie well a
follow-up Mr chairman if I will go ahead
and thank you for taking a follow-up is
it fair to say that this commission
could act as a catalyst in the area that
you're working absolutely and that's why
I actually drove up here today is
because when I saw that on the list I
thought I need to go talk about that
that's really important for all these
small towns I think it is too thank you
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question I consider you to be an expert
in these areas
um when we were talking about the
four-plex bill I was talking to my
constituents in a single family
residential neighborhood who were
overwhelmingly opposed to this and so I
was trying to
talk to them about what we need to do
there's nowhere in this commission
that's going to that I see is going to
consider how to educate people
about the need
um and maybe change some Minds about
their backyards could you yeah
yeah I don't think that's actually the
job of this committee but I think that's
a really important Point
um I do know that the Housing
Opportunity planning grants that have
been being dispersed this year and that
I'm working on they have a huge piece
that is public engagement and the whole
purpose of that is in an effort to
change hearts and Minds about what we
need to do
um
I don't see that as the purview of this
committee but I absolutely agree that
that's a thing to do and I do think that
the work that this committee is
proposing to do would be helpful in
having that conversation
sure thank you
see no more questions thank you for your
testimony thank you so much for having
me you're welcome next up we have uh
Christy Saint Laurent
I do have written
while on my face first I do have written
copies of the testimony
and just as a reminder we are kind of
maintaining a three minute brief thank
you yes
um so thank you for hearing my testimony
today my name is Christy St Laurent and
I'm a member of the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging just as a reminder
the commission was established in 2019
by the legislative session to advise the
general court and the governor on issues
related to Aging in recognition that New
Hampshire demographically speaking is
becoming older we're one of the oldest
State's fastest aging States you guys
have all heard that before so what we're
seeking is thoughtful shaping of public
policy and investing across Generations
that will ready our state for this
change and Foster a future in which we
can all Thrive which is why I'm here
speaking on this issue
there's two prongs for the support from
the Commission on Aging
for this bill
one is housing when the commission and
DHS did the update to the state plan on
Aging one of the top two concerns of the
older adults that we heard speak from
across the state was the availability
and affordability of housing
many older adults find that driving is
difficult and so they want to be close
to services so the increased density
would not only help to draw services to
them but would make it easier for them
to access them
it also allows for more efficient
delivery of home-based services you've
all heard about the lack of Direct Care
Workforce in New Hampshire and the
impacts that's having so it would allow
more efficient delivery of those
services
and it would also by having available
and affordable housing that is also
accessible to older adults it would
allow their probably larger house on a
large lot to be able to go back into the
supply for families seeking housing
the second prong of our support is for
that Direct Care Workforce I just
mentioned older adults in need of
services are not able to find the
services are not able to find the hours
of services that they need because of
this shortage affordable housing would
support Recruitment and Retention which
is a big issue in the Direct Care
Workforce
density makes that affordability and
availability attainable in 2020 New
Hampshire's Direct Care median income
was 21 500 which puts them at or below
the ability to afford housing in New
Hampshire and in fact 28 percent of New
Hampshire's Direct Care Workforce that
year lacked available housing
the commission on aging's meeting
earlier this month month focused on the
topic of Aging there were articles about
it in the New Hampshire bulletin and
also there was just recently an article
in the Valley News entitled rapidly
changing property values squeeze
residents on a fixed income
there was also supportive information
along these lines and that we heard that
morning
regarding the Statewide housing needs
assessment published by the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
compared to the the house special
committee on housing the charge of SB 47
is seen by the commission to be narrow
we're in scope and with discrete tasks
that would Target the issues that are
part of the fabric of the housing crisis
facing older adults
certainly there's also been talk with
emergency rooms getting backed up and
part of that problem is older adults not
have when they need to be discharged not
having a safe and secure place to be
discharged home to and again that's by
in some cases because they are unable to
afford or able to take care of houses on
their own and they don't have anywhere
to go and with nowhere to discharge them
they stay in our hospitals and emergency
rooms
okay you're close to being done because
you've yep we're well over go ahead nope
that's it
perfect very good any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony uh next up we have uh Bob
Quinn
good afternoon my name is Bob Quinn I am
the CEO of the New Hampshire Association
of Realtors and we are in support of the
bill
um
I will say first of all um thank you to
the house uh recently on hb2 by
inserting an appropriation of about 40
million dollars for both the New
Hampshire affordable housing fund as
well as invest New Hampshire those are
much needed dollars to expand access and
affordability of housing in the in the
state of New Hampshire
but keep in mind that even in the best
case scenario those funds are only going
to bring in several thousand new units
three four thousand units as you've
heard before we're about 20 000 units
shy today
so where are those other units are going
to come from I think this discussion
that we're going to have in this
committee uh will help bring forward
some of those Solutions I have a lot of
data uh to sort of underscore and
highlight the problem with housing the
dire situation of housing in New
Hampshire but I'm only going to leave
you with one and that is we have an
affordability index that we track which
is basically we look at what is the
median income in New Hampshire versus
what is the median sale price
right now that affordability index is at
70.
it's an all-time low what does that mean
it means the median income in New
Hampshire is only 70 percent of what is
needed to afford the median sale price
of a single-family home in New Hampshire
which is 445 thousand dollars
so while other states I think in this
region are aggressively looking at
opportunities and means in which to
expand housing in those States I think
New Hampshire also needs to follow
through and find solutions that work
uniquely for New Hampshire and Order
expanding housing affordability and
increase inventory
thank you very much
nice job
less than two minutes
any questions representative Guthrie I
have an equipment
can you tell me why we the builders
continue to build 400
000 homes and up
and can you tell me why the how the uh
the single wide double wide housing that
is ideal for us the seniors are not
being built uh in New Hampshire
it's a very long answer that I'm not
going to
I will say this I think you heard a bill
prior to this one that helped to explain
some of the costs that go into building
single family homes I think there are
issues with some municipalities in how
they uh Zone single family uh to family
three family that make it very
challenging to build more densely and
create greater costs so I think again
this commission would provide an
opportunity for all voices to get
together and try to come up with some
solutions to that thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your answer
see no more questions thank you very
much thank you very much
next we have
uh Ellis um
I can't make out the last name marcelyn
something like that
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Alyssa margolin
and I serve as director of housing
action New Hampshire we're here in
support of SB 47 housing action New
Hampshire was one of the organizations
that had advocated for the creation of
the commission we followed its work and
then saw its work stall out during covid
and so I thought it would be helpful for
you to kind of understand the history
um and we were also working with
leadership here in the house to create
the new special committee on housing so
I thought I could distinguish that for
you and also happen to be part of the
group way back in 08 that was helping
facilitate the growth and development
Roundtable
so hopefully I could just provide that
perspective so
um essentially we understand that in
order to increase production and
affordability to keep New Hampshire's
rural character and preserve our
beautiful uh uh natural spaces we need
to understand density and we need to do
that in Partnership and we need the
expertise of folks who are going to tell
us about septic water sewer alteration
of terrain very technical issues and we
need to find consensus a move forward
policy where there is uh you know buy-in
and educate our municipalities in ways
so that we can address this dire housing
need and that's what the work of this
commission has been and they were making
progress and we're simply asking the
house to reconvene them and allow them
to create their final report and deliver
it at a time where there is
unprecedented I think political will to
really doing something about the problem
and that we do have this special
committee that's about to go into their
kind of policy proposal stage for next
session so with that history and context
we urge you to pass this bill happy to
take any questions thank you very much
for your testimony I see no questions
excellent
final pink card we have for this bill
Ben Frost
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
committee members my name is Ben Frost
I'm the deputy executive director and
chief legal officer at New Hampshire
housing it's my pleasure to be here this
afternoon to express New Hampshire
housing support for Senate bill 47. I
served on and was the clerk of the
preceding density commission and so I
got a a
front row seat as witness to the work
that the commission did and was
recording it in the minutes
um the commission did substantial work
but then as has been noted was stalled
by covid we lost six months of time and
were unable to complete some of the most
important tasks
which are outlined here in the purposes
of this proposed Commission
so I'll draw your attention to a couple
of them
um one as Ivy van mentioned examination
of septic standards this is really
important this was one of the things
that was a specific charge of the
preceding commission and they simply
couldn't get to it because of the the
time that was lost
two this is on page two lines eight and
nine the impacts of development looking
at school enrollment I'll tell you right
now New Hampshire housing has just
launched a study on this on this very
issue and so we expect to have the
results of that study in time for this
commission should it be formed to be
able to take that up and perhaps
identify appropriate legislative
responses
um and third I'll note on lines six and
seven of page two exploring possible
methods of enforcement of the shared
Community responsibility of Workforce
housing
that's language that was added to the
the original legislation that
established the preceding commission
added by this committee
which noted the importance of uh
Workforce housing and looking at it from
a regional perspective so this committee
took that very seriously
I'll just note that New Hampshire
housing has just published a Statewide
Regional Statewide housing needs
assessment in which we identify a
current shortage of housing in the state
Statewide of over 23 500 units that's
the number of housing units that would
be needed to restore the market to
something we would consider to be a
stable Market that balances the
interests of buyers and sellers that
balances the interests of landlords and
tenants we are a long way from that but
it is achievable and that doesn't
account for potential for future growth
that our employers so desperately need
we if we do not accommodate a growing
Workforce by providing relatively
affordable and I don't mean capital A
affordable I mean lowercase a affordable
relatively affordable housing for our
labor force to occupy that will put a
pinch on our economy which
you know how important that is for the
state to continue its operations
I'll just want to close by responding to
representative Guthrie's questions
regarding single wide and double wide
they're not being built because in most
cases municipalities do not allow them
to be placed on individual Lots they
only allow them in manufactured housing
parks where they already where those
Parks already exist and there's limited
opportunity to expand so in the
municipalities do this legally they that
is consistent with the law
municipalities must allow manufactured
housing in one of three ways one of
which is Parks so if they go out in
Parks then they've met the the legal
obligation and they can say no you can't
do that on a single lot so that's why it
doesn't get quite the single wides and
double wides don't get built and why 400
000 homes it's a question of economics
if zoning only allows large lot large
lots to be developed then the only way a
developer can and profitably build a
house is to build a larger home which is
going to sell at a higher price the
purpose of this commission is to
identify ways in which municipalities
can
accommodate denser development which is
the way we will achieve greater housing
affordability in New Hampshire but to do
it
in a way that is consistent with
Community character that's the hard task
thank you
is there representative power has a
question thank you Mr chairman I have
two unrelated questions one's quick
could I ask too
you may ask one and then okay follow up
thank you so my first quick question is
is there could you please inform the
committee as to where we might find the
reports of the previous commission for
for our study
I happily representative power and in
fact New Hampshire housing had a website
or web a web page on our website for
that we have all of those records I'll
be happy to send them to uh I'll send it
to the full mailing list for the
committee follow up go ahead yes thank
you so um I appreciate in the in the um
in the text of this bill on page two
lines eight nine as you um highlighted
that one of the charges of this
commission would be to study the impacts
of a development but then it says
specifically the impacts on on schools
how that would affect the municipalities
so that's that's that's great but
additionally is there any language in
this bill
um that would
ask or require that additional impacts
be also looked at such as infrastructure
Municipal services and what those types
of
impacts would have on taxation
uh thank you for that question I would
say yes indirectly if you look at a page
two lines one through three the minimum
standards for residential development
focusing on public water and sewer uh it
doesn't talk about the cost necessarily
but certainly if if this committee
wanted to add that as a charge for this
committee that uh for this commission
that would seem to be appropriate
follow-up uh representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman um if I understand
correctly you were on the previous
commission is that correct that is
correct so with that said
um what do you think your success was
before and how do you expect to bring
that forward as far as a positive impact
on on getting additional housing uh as
opposed to what the new commission would
do
uh thank you for that question and and
I'll go back to what I said before and
other speakers said too uh the work of
the the prior commission uh was stalled
like we lost six months of time uh which
was at a point in the commission's work
when it was gearing up to do frankly the
heavy lifting we had done many months of
fact-finding gotten a lot of testimony a
lot of different presentations and
assembled a lot of information
but then you know was it March 20th 2020
the world shut down and so did that
commission the commission only resumed
its work in
uh very late August of 2020 in time to
do a final report and there just wasn't
time to do it as I say that the heavy
lifting of that Commission
that uh the re-establishment of that
commission formation of a new commission
following in its steps would allow uh
that work to be done
go ahead
so I'm just trying to understand I'm not
trying to be negative here I'm trying to
understand what was accomplished so that
we get positive results out of the
previous work so we can move forward
with with Ashley getting some positive
results with this and I assume it's
going to go forward with this that
information come forward to the new
commission and that commission would
carry on so that we get some positive
results of all the all the work so what
what would you expect that to be
thank you uh well I I think if you uh
representative if you look at the the
charge of this commission you can
identify uh certain potential products
and deliverables of the commission model
ordinances uh
working with Des which would be
represented on this commission to
identify what appropriate revisions to
septic standards are
and then send Des off to do its
rulemaking in consistent with that
providing municipalities with additional
tools
partly to visualize what uh additional
density looks like
and a lot of it a lot of the
a lot of the density that
we live with right now is think some
things that we don't acknowledge
so we look at
um you know our cherished historic
communities I used to live in Amherst
which has this
gorgeous town center and if you look at
the density of Amherst of the village of
Amherst it's pretty dense
and yet Villages like that can't be
built under most of our zoning
ordinances and yet that's what we love
so much about New Hampshire it's the
villages and then the spaces between
places so identifying areas that are
appropriate for conservation I'm getting
off into good planning right now
what's appropriate for conservation
what's appropriate for development and
where we are going to develop how can we
do it best that's really I think
ultimately uh the mission of this uh
this body this commission thanks I
appreciate it that certainly clarified
your thoughts representative save us
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
my question
um I struggle with the um the concept
that increased density will inevitably
lead to more affordability
and
in Lebanon we have not seen that happen
prices just keep going up so I'm
wondering will this Commission
which I think is necessary for the place
that we're in right now will you be
looking at where those two lines cross
and why
where does density equal affordability
what is the mechanism that makes that
happen and why is it not happening now
oh representative what a great question
uh and and a a deep philosophical one
too uh that goes into uh
economics I think to respond directly to
your question I think uh what you're
witnessing in Lebanon is uh
the market responding to dire need for
more housing
and the supply even though Lebanon has
as a community has done so much
the supply still not being enough to
meet the current demand because so
little has been done for so long
we have statewide uh a as I said this uh
pretty significant shortage of housing
until we meet that shortage we're not
going to see
the prices really stabilizing we've got
to do a lot and we have to have more
communities like Lebanon stepping up to
meet this challenge
representative color
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question earlier today we had a bill
about
um the extreme cost of infrastructure as
far as
um per mile of of broadband
um and so obviously having more density
per mile of that extreme cost would
reduce that per per per per unit cost
can you talk a little bit about the
other types of infrastructure that
um and their significant costs
um that might be a little bit
reduced per unit by The increased
density since since it kind of follows
up on the previous question and if you
could do that in a brief manner please
thank you
yes Mr chairman I understand you're over
time now and so am I
um representative yes I this is a great
question uh and let me
answer it briefly by saying New
Hampshire housing recently worked with a
consulting firm called Urban three they
are National specialists in looking at
Municipal costs that and revenues that
are associated with different kinds of
development
and we we those reports we have uh phase
one report which looks at Municipal uh
Revenue
so what kind of taxes do municipalities
get based on different kinds of land
uses uh and we are just about to get the
final report on phase two of that which
looks at uh Municipal costs which looks
at uh the um not not so much Broadband
because that's that is a more difficult
question to get to but the pipes the
water and sewer uh roads and looks at
the efficiencies that you get by having
greater density of development on that
infrastructure rather than
I'll use the word sprawling it out
inefficiently from a cost perspective
from a municipal cost perspective
allowing sprawl to consume the
countryside and sending our dpws out to
do work all over the place instead of
focusing their efforts in a much more
small smaller area
we're happy to get those reports to you
as well
thank you
for the questions
no Miss representative majority no
question okay
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you Mr chairman
okay I don't have any more pink cards I
have two people signed in in favor on
the blue sheet and with that we will
close the Herring on SB 47.
and with that we were going to open up
the hearing on uh sp132
which is prohibiting cities and towns
from adopting Sanctuary cities
foreign
is going to start the or introduce the
bill
thank you very much chairman turcott
members of the municipal and County
government committee it's nice to be
back I am Grant bossy here to introduce
SB 132 on behalf of Senator Bill Gannon
the Bill's Prime sponsor uh he is out of
the hospital and into rehab uh expects
to be back into the state house uh in a
matter of weeks and hope to see you all
soon
the United States is not facing one
border crisis but two illegal crossings
from Canada into the U.S are surging
according to Customs and Border
Protection apprehensions along the
border in New York Vermont and New
Hampshire increased
846 percent from October 2022 through
this January total encounters at the
northern border have increased 1300
percent over the past two years CBP
actually sent 25 new agents to the
northern border but unfortunately it did
so by taking them away from patrolling
the southern border yet the Biden
Administration has refused New
Hampshire's request to have state
authorities help enforce the Border
where it has failed last year 434 people
in New Hampshire died from drug
overdoses most from fentanyl smuggled
across one border or the other one
seizure in February found 4.5 million
fentanyl pills 3 100 pounds of
methamphetamine and large quantities of
heroin cocaine and Fentanyl powder in
2022 federal seizures on the southern
border totaled more than 50 million
fentanyl bills more than ten thousand
pounds of fentanyl powder more than
enough to kill every man woman and child
in America
at a recent congressional oversight
hearing U.S border Patrol Chief Raul
Ortiz admitted that the Biden
Administration did not have quote
operational control unquote of the
Southern border that means the
prevention of illegal entries including
terrorists we need to address this issue
now to protect New Hampshire citizens
sb-132 to be clear prevents Sanctuary
policies but it does not mandate the
towns participate in federal immigration
enforcement it prevents policies not
individual decisions it prevents
municipalities from adopting blanket
Sanctuary policies that prevent law
enforcement from ever executing an
immigration detainer it does not mandate
that they cooperate in each and every
case New Hampshire municipalities should
not be releasing illegal immigrants they
arrest when they are sought by federal
immigration officials Sanctuary policies
would tell illegal immigrants to come to
New Hampshire to avoid enforcement
putting further strain on local
resources we should not allow local
officials officials to tie the hands of
their own police departments when
cooperating with Federal officials and
preventing the release of dangerous
criminals Senator Gannon thanks you for
consideration and your support of Senate
Bill 132 thank you
thank you Mr flossie any questions
seeing none thank you for introducing on
behalf of Senator Gannon thank you
okay we have a lot of pink cards so just
so everybody in the audience knows we're
going to be very firm with the three
minutes you're going to be three minutes
to speak so have your points down really
well
and uh when you see representative power
hold up the pink card that means you
have 30 seconds left so
everybody's on board all right very good
let's start uh first into uh rep
piamonte
thank you Mr Chan thank you committee
this room looks familiar to me
um I
uh my grand bossy pretty much covered
most of the
topics that I had and I'm not going to
repeat them
um
this is a a bill SB 132 is is called
Public Safety and National Security just
plain and simple
this is permissive legislation
law enforcement has discretion to pursue
or not
and that preserves local control
um let's see where
I can go from here
I know the cartels are moving the drugs
up to Lawrence Mass and then
distributation and distribute them
through New Hampshire
Maine
and Vermont
this has caused a problem with fentanyl
here
overdoses have increased considerably I
think uh today I I heard on the the news
it went increased 87
overdoses in Manchester and Nashua this
year
you know
um more than likely you know you know
someone who's been affected by drugs
here in New Hampshire
and um it's a sad case
uh when that happens you you don't
realize it and
um it's it's bad when I was in the
military
I know the
the Communist Chinese Communists used to
prove uh bring heroin into the GIS
and it was Pure Heroin they came back
here
and the heroin that they received or the
drugs that they received here
were far less than what they had
caused overdoses we're in the same
predicament here not with Heroin but
with the Fentanyl and the drugs from the
cartels
um
on page two lines one and three defines
immigration law
um lines 14 to 16 defines policy
uh line 17 to 22 defines a sanctuary
policy
and lines 27-29
Define prohibition of sanctuary policies
there was one thing I don't think was
mentioned but there was a doctor that
was arrested
in Woburn Massachusetts for altering
fingerprints and they're getting
documents
and not being able to prove who they are
that was uh that person was arrested by
the FBI
uh and it an admitted financier for a
terrorist organization was arrested
working in Rochester
but he was living in Dover
and
that person was also arrested
so
border patrols are doing the job I know
that there is a a two-way I think it was
287 which is a
uh it's a what it does is it it
deputizes either State Police
or
local law enforcement as
a an immigration agent it's like they
how they deputize the people in the in
the old days
but that doesn't mean uh
they're going to debitize everyone I
know the governor is looking at putting
together
more State Police up in the Border
because it's 51 miles that the people up
there can't handle and the the border
patrols are not being sent out to the
Border to take care of this stuff I mean
that's pretty much all I have
oh they called they call uh
Swanton sector
up north that is governs New Hampshire
and um I believe New Hampshire and
uh
just New Hampshire and Canada border
and the other thing was is that the
immigration
officers the only one
that can re arrest
a detainer and I don't think a lot of
people know that they they think that
the police can arrest
um immigration because mere fact that
they feel that's the case there's no
profiling in this bill
and um I think that's pretty much it
thank you representative Piemonte a
question uh representative yokella thank
you thank you for taking the question
um
what was kind of uh alluded to was
essentially local
um entities having something a policy
it seemed uh to be explicitly stated but
in the definition of policy it does
state that there isn't
um Unwritten policies that would be
um considered and just common practice
or any practice uh I guess let's say the
the municipality is understaffed and
they're they don't have a written policy
but they have an Unwritten practice of
not
giving themselves extra work when
they're understaffed and and for
um for a municipality to permit that
um would be in breach of this
legislation do you think that is
um
um a little bit too uh restrictive on
those municipalities essentially saying
that you have to
um have
um at least some practice of of abiding
or you know
helping these uh those Federal
immigration laws that's that's what
allows the local control to exist there
they do not have to do that only if they
want to it's not something that's uh
forced upon them and that that is part
of this bill it's permissive it's
discretionary
and it preserves the local control
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you uh next uh
for the record uh representative
Piemonte and my next uh presenter are
both co-sponsors of the bill so we've
given them just slightly more latitude
uh representative Nutter
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the committee I'm I have a
lot of homework for you and to to cut
down on the time first of all this I've
been here 13 years so this is one of the
bills that comes back every term and I
keep a file on bills like such as this
so this is my file
we had expert Witnesses when we test had
the um the hearing in the Senate they
were not able to be here today so I'm
going to just go over a little bit of
what they're going to talk about and you
can read it
um before you you um have your exact
session and if you have a study I'm
sorry a work session on this bill I'd be
happy to come back
so when I testified in the Senate I
talked about the word alien because in
the past that we had complaints people
didn't want to use that word but from
the retired senior special agent of the
immigration and National Naturalization
Service Michael Cutler we've had many
conversations and I learned the origin
of that word and why it is the proper
word to use we had uh testify people
testify that said
um you know these are people you're
you're being you're being terrible but
you did hear you know it's
we have to vet people coming into this
country we have a right to do that we we
we need to do that it's prudent to do
that everywhere else in the world they
protect their borders they don't just
allow anyone in and that's for our own
safety
I um testified that the term Sanctuary
conjures up a comforting image of a
place of security and serenity
this term makes me think of refugees
crossing the border to escape tyranny
and those who would halt their arrival
as unchristian and uncharitable in that
respect I can't say that I disagree
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
that falls under political Asylum and
this bill is not about political Asylum
so I did make copies of
Michael Cutler's words so that's the
first a handout
the second is from
Kevin Williams
he's a retired Immigration and Customs
Enforcement
and removal operations officer he was
deployed as a deportation officer
I have a show on public access called
chatting with Janine and I had Kevin
Williams on the show and we talked about
how he flew illegals around the country
so it's not a myth it really does happen
I have his testimony since he couldn't
be here today
and then this one's the longest one I've
become good friends with um
Sherry oh thank you Tony
Sherry's from the Federation of American
Immigration reform
this is lengthy it's double-sided it's
about seven pages long so in the
interest of time I'm just going to go
over very quickly what she talks about
first she introduces herself she defines
the organization what they're all about
she says Sanctuary policies not only
lead to more crimes but they are also a
magnet for illegal immigration
she gives offers examples of crimes and
murders committed by illegals
she agrees that not everyone who is in
the United States illegally intends to
harm Americans but individuals who come
through the back doors have not been
vetted so their intentions are unknown
she has a lot of stats and information
on um
different crimes that have been
committed and why it is prudent to to
pass a bill such as this
there are areas in New Hampshire that
have Sanctuary policies she cites those
as well she says proponents of sanctuary
policies argue that enacting
anti-sanctuary legislation like sb-132
will result in public officials and Law
Enforcement Officers discriminating
against minorities however this issue
has been addressed in the bill itself
sb-132 specifically prohibits
discrimination saying that a state or
local government entity shall not
consider an individual's race color
religion language or national origin
so
I guess I I can wrap that up since in
the interest of time
um but I I do hope that you you have a
work session on this bill and read
everything that I sent and the contact
information for these individuals are on
the paper and
share are they the fair packet the third
page
I mean the last page is is the second
page I don't know how that happened so
there was a mix up in the the numbering
thank you
thank you representative Nader are there
any questions
seeing none thank you very much
okay here's where we're going to have
representative power start the timers uh
three minutes uh first up is uh
representative wheeler who has said he
only needs two minutes
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm here as well first of all I'm
Jonah wheeler from representing
Hillsboro 33 Peterborough and Sharon I'm
here representing my town select board
which on Tuesday voted 3-0 to sign a
petition in opposition to this
legislation they did so not because they
want open Borders or a bunch of
undocumented people running around their
town I don't think that's I think that's
fear-mongering and I don't think that's
true they did so because they don't want
their local police using their resources
to enforce federal laws and I think that
is a reasonable
requests from the police in Peterborough
we have a lot of undocumented people
here in New Hampshire and in the United
States and I think
anyone would be mistaken to say that's
not a problem we need comprehensive
immigration reform and a pathway to
citizenship so that those 11 million
people 11 million plus people can find a
way to become legal
but why are those 11 million people here
in the United States
it's not because there's some secret
Invasion going on it's because in Africa
southeast Asia and South America
corporations and American government and
policy has subjected those countries and
and those people to
Decades of Terror they're living in
apocalyptic conditions right now and I
think we get a little bit too
comfortable here in places like New
Hampshire and we don't really understand
how real it is for people across the
world
uh
these people are coming seeking refuge
and the only place that they feel is
safe and I think we should be more
focused on the fact that there are
places like that in this world right now
instead of criminalizing them and taking
away their autonomy without due process
ice and the federal immigration
authorities should enforce their loss we
should have immigration laws we should
have a border a strong Border in which
people cross legally
but we don't get there by introducing
legislation which would strip away
people's due process rights even if they
are here undocumented that is a
restriction of freedom and I'm a little
bit concerned by that so I see the pink
card here I just want to introduce I
just wanted to affirm peterborough's
position here I'm not for open borders
but I am for uh legal immigration and a
pathway towards citizenship and this
isn't the right way to move forward with
that
thank you very much for your testimony
uh for those who will be coming up after
representative wheeler I'm going to ask
that not only do you maintain the
three-minute
um allotted time but also try to keep
your comments specifically to the bill
at hand and that bill is sanctuary city
thank you next we have representative
Joe Shapiro
thank you chairman turcotte and
committee members for the record my name
is representative Joe Shapiro
representing Cheshire 16 and I'm come
before you today to speak in opposition
to SB 132. I think SB 132
um
is predicated on some major
misconceptions and because of the time
constraints here I'm going to try to
address a couple of those
um
number one is that immigrants present a
major problem in New Hampshire
um we have heard about
um addictions and overdose fatalities in
New Hampshire and I am the first to
agree that that is a major problem I
know that
um
much of those drugs come from out of
this country but I don't think that this
bill addresses that in the least we've
also talked about heard about crime and
um
and dangerousness but we haven't heard
any data from the northern border or
from people coming elsewhere into New
Hampshire we haven't even heard any
anecdotes about New Hampshire specific
crime or violence
um
in reality New Hampshire is consistently
rated within the top three states in the
nation in regard to having the lowest
rates of violent crime governor sununu
recently in his travels around the
country is fond of saying that we live
in the safest state in the country it is
no secret that we have a woefully
inadequate Workforce there are jobs for
anybody who's able and wants to work
and this is one of the claims that I
think people make about immigrants
coming to New Hampshire that they will
take the jobs and other benefits
reserved for residents
um
it is no secret that we have an
inadequate Workforce
um there are jobs for everybody who is
able and wants to work I recently had a
conversation with the vice president at
um pitco friellator which is a Concord
company which makes commercial
friolators for McDonald's all over the
all over the world and for other
restaurants as well he talked to me
about
um with covid the lack of people
applying for jobs and the number of
people leaving and there are problems
with producing their product
and that somebody had convinced him to
hire four recent Afghan evacuees who had
moved to Concord
um and he was unsure of that because of
language problems but he hired these
four people last spring and when I spoke
to him in the winter he had 40 Afghan
um
he had 40 Afghans working there and he
felt that it had really saved his
Workforce
um okay I'm gonna have to move along
because I see the pink card
um
so why if this bill is so problematic
and unnecessary we even hear today
discussing it not just today but year
after year as was said before this isn't
is not an example of the New Hampshire
citizen legislature trying to solve a
New Hampshire problem brought To Us by
our constituents rather we are porns in
a national funded campaign
by a national immigrant an
anti-immigrant organization which seeks
to demonize people who speak different
language than us may be a different
color than us and may practice a
different religion than us immigrants
coming to New Hampshire will not in
itself solve the problems of an aging
state with inadequate Workforce but
please do not pass a bill that will in
effect put up a sign at the borders
saying you are not welcome here
today I urge you to do two things first
to go to your communities and introduce
yourself to the newcomers who this bill
will affect
hear their stories find out about their
families listen to their aspirations
second truly protect New Hampshire
communities by voting itl on SB 132.
good thank you for your testimony any
questions
see you none thank you uh next up we
have uh representative Horgan
thank you very much I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan from Stratford County
District 10. I I'm used to being
District six but I'm Different 10. the
town of Durham I'm also a member of the
Stratford county executive committee and
um so one thing I'll mention is our
County administers a
contract with the Federal Bureau of
Prisons for taking in federal prisoners
including immigration detainees and I'm
concerned that some of the language
about polishing Sanctuary policy would
interfere with the County Jail's ability
to uh you know deal with the detainees
humanely which they make every effort to
do
um because often oftentimes when you
have an immigration detainee they maybe
intending to apply for Asylum but we
haven't accepted the same as Asylum or
their visas run out or there's all kinds
of things occasionally they even take a
citizen who maybe doesn't speak English
well or just looks different and hauls
them in
also the number of also the uh I guess a
number of uh undocumented immigrants
it's probably not going to obviously
we've destabilized Africa and Latin
America as represented wheeler aptly
said but we also have a a war in Eastern
Europe so that's creating a large number
of uh you know displaced people some of
whom are coming to America who are you
know
look like me blonde haired in blue eyes
you know Russians ukrainians and so
forth so it's not just people of color
who
are being who are coming to the coming
to this country looking for uh Sanctuary
or Asylum
um
and uh and the title as I said is
misleading it applies to all state
entities um it really we're not a home
real estate it's a really really even be
possible to
single out Sanctuary cities and towns
because their powers are all come from
uh come from the state and so fact the
discovers the whole state not that
there's much possibility of a New
Hampshire declaring itself a sanctuary
State I think that bill would go down in
flames although I've considered
introducing it
and um
so there's like a lot of things I mean
somebody mentioned the fentanyl trade I
know much time to go into it but in fact
it's uh personally not being smuggled in
by by immigrants it's being smuggled in
by cargo the fentanyl trade is extremely
uh sophisticated high-tech operation and
uh you know it involves uh people here
in the U.S not just people in China and
other countries so and
finally there's a conundrum in this bill
which is on the one hand
state law enforcement agencies are not
allowed
to refuse to interfere with uh
Federal
immigration policy but the other hand
they're they're not allowed to cooperate
with Federal Gun policy
and he just know if we pass this bill
pretty soon
a uh a citizen of another country is
going to be arrested on gun charges and
we're going to be
we're going to have like a logical
conundrum we're going to be sort of
going around an infinite Circle deciding
whether or not
how we're supposed to respond to that so
that's uh
so so I think those two so I think so I
think those two bills are are so those
two laws are incompatible so you're just
going to very quickly put our uh
authorities in an impossible position
the first time you have a situation like
that and they're absolutely will be one
because uh you know citizens and
non-citizens like commit all sorts of
sorts of crimes immigrants not
necessarily more than uh citizens but
they said including Firearms crimes so
you get an immigrant with the illegal
firearm what are you going to do about
that I I don't know so
um so thanks I think this is a bad Bill
so itl thanks thank you very much any
questions
thank you thanks
um next we have I can't quite make out
the last name Alan aldubus
okay that's true
that's right
maybe I would have been better off
good afternoon chairman turcott and
members of the committee my name is Alan
aldenberg and I am the chief of police
for the Manchester Police Department
thank you for allowing me to speak today
on Senate Bill 132 and act prohibiting
cities and towns from adopting Sanctuary
policies
as the chief of police in the LA in the
state's largest and most diverse City
I'm concerned with this bill and I
respectfully request that you find it in
expedient to legislate Public Safety is
always my top concern in thoughtful
policy is a significant factor in the
Safety and Security of our communities
I feel that Senate Bill 132 would be
detrimental to the trust between the
police and the community
he would have dire consequences for
victims of crime and it appears to aim
to change current policies that have
proven to be effective
additionally prior testimony was offered
from a retired ice agent in another
committee
I believe it's the Kevin Williams that
was mentioned earlier who stated that
the Manchester police department and
other law enforcement agency agencies in
the state do not cooperate with the
United States immigration and customers
enforcement that testimony is patently
false and irresponsible to stay publicly
I'll outline precisely how the
Manchester Police Department manages
interactions with undocumented
immigrants to begin the Manchester
police department works daily to gain
and maintain the trust of those we serve
and furtherance of this goal we have
developed a model policy that balances
the need to ensure safety of all
regardless of their immigration status
we have and currently cooperate with our
federal immigration Partners on
violations of immigration laws our
policy has been in place since 2011.
to ensure the community trusts the
police we don't we do not ask about
their immigration status when they are
the victim a witness of a crime or a
juvenile we also do not inquire about
immigration status during a routine
motor vehicle Stop Those seeking medical
attention or victims of domestic
violence
this is an important policy decision to
ensure our community knows that they can
come to the police for help with without
the threat of being deported
we should not be adopting policies and
laws that could potentially deter
victims of crime from reporting their
victimization to the police
doing so causes a cycle of violence to
continue particularly in domestic
violence situations
this also opens the door for predators
to exploit undocumented individuals due
to the less risk of being reported to
the police
examples could be human trafficking or
labor law violations
our policy already ensures that we work
with Federal immigration Partners when
it is appropriate for example should an
officer believe a person under arrest is
an undocumented immigrant the officer
can notify ice for consideration of an
immigration hold when the person was
arrested for a felony was arrested for a
misdemeanor crime of violence or a
misdemeanor that poses a threat to
Public Safety
they were or they were previously
deported immigrant or the person was
actively wanted by ice for immigration
law violations
and this does happen we do call ice in
these circumstances most often when the
person is wanted by ice and the warrant
is entered into the national criminal
information center also known as ncic
the reality and to be frank with you
that oftentimes ice declines to come in
order to take custody of the individual
the Manchester Police Department policy
has become a model for other police
departments because it works this
balance of this policy the balance of
this policy is the best approach to the
Departments because it works
Senate one Senate Bill 132 was not
needed it does not fix a problem or
right or wrong it would only hamper our
ability to Serve and Protect again I ask
that you find Senate Bill 132 in
expedient to legislate
thank you for your testimony uh
representative Keller
thank you thanks for taking the question
um in Reading
um
Roman 5 uh page on page two line 17.
um it seems to say that
um The Sanctuary policy that they're
talking about is essentially forbidding
um
any cooperation with
um enforcement of federal law
immigration laws
um
would your
and you stated before that someone was
saying that you are
um would not be in compliance with this
but you just stated that in certain
circumstances you do comply or you do
cooperate and so therefore in fact it
wouldn't have any policy change to your
department right because you do
cooperate sometimes and other times you
choose not to and so therefore you
wouldn't have a a sanctuary policy that
says you never cooperate is is that your
understanding of of this
um law and how
what page you want again I'm on page two
the sanctuary policy yes sir
um you said before that that you were
someone claimed that you had a sanctuary
policy but you just stated that
there are certain times which you would
be cooperating and so then you wouldn't
be in violation of of this having a
sanctuary policy correct correct but I'm
yeah I'm concerned too about
um you know who
asking law enforcement to local law
enforcement to enforce essentially a a
civil action on part of the federal
authorities to me is problematic because
sometimes those
those detention orders that may be in
existence are not accurate
um they're sometimes not rooted in
probable cause
sometimes there there's sometimes many
mistakes with those and to put local law
enforcement in that position
um I think is is dangerous it's a
slippery slope and
not only am I going to erode the trust
of my public
I don't have the people for that to be
honest with you to be going out and
enforcing the work of the federal
immigration authorities it's not that's
their job to do that we assist we're
appropriate and when asked hopefully
that answers your question
I think uh representative Guthrie here's
a quick question thank you Mr chairman
and thank you chief for your your
testimony I think it's
gives a real good look at what's going
on with this bill
[Music]
is it fair to say that you don't need
this bill I think you and the previous
speakers have said that this bill is not
needed
it's not a tool that you could you would
use it's not a tool that's in the best
interest of the State of New Hampshire
is that Fayette or is that a
misinterpretation of your testimony
chief that is fair and I will also
acknowledge that do we have a problem at
our borders
um but this isn't gonna
this isn't going to affix that that's an
that's a global problem thank you chief
for your testimony thank you Mr Gia
representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman afternoon Chief
just I'm right here I'm sorry it's okay
there's a glare I apologize
representative that's all right I just
got a quick question for you kind of a
scenario uh one of your officer stops
the cough arrests the person for class A
misdemeanor go into you want to 10 21 22
or 23 comes up as a hit that there's a
detention on it from uh immigration
what are you going to do what's it
officer going to do
what happens then is the you're going to
call the immigration folks it could be
two o'clock in the morning and we'll
call the on-call number for ice
um in the vast majority of time
um if we're being honest
um we don't get an answer
um or
they'll answer and say okay thank you
for letting us know
um We'll advise them of the reason the
person's under arrest and
person will be bailed out and released
on your misdemeanor charge correct okay
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
Chief good afternoon representative my
question is you're you're calling the
detainer a civil matter
so when you go into ncic the detainer
doesn't show up under that database
correct it will it can yes
yep
and I'm sure there's maybe an attorney
in the room could probably entrust that
better but um it will show up in ncic
okay and usually it's a hold or you know
hold contact ice
um and a lot of times it could just be a
it's a hit on a similar sounding name
um so you got to vet that out we call
that a soundex
um
but yeah something will generally pop up
in ncic
thank you follow up please go ahead
can can you cite where in this bill you
dates that law enforcement
does something that you're you're
opposed to
um yeah what I'm opposed to is asking
local authorities to get into the
business of enforcing Federal
immigration laws that's what I'm in
terms of
you know how's it going to look right
let's simplify it how's it going to look
that hey now the local police are acting
as under the guise of as ICE federal
agents in going out and you know now
asking people though immigration status
and now
um now they want us knocking on doors
and I mean I I'm just I can see where
this is going and maybe not state that
directly in there
um but those are my concerns with the
local at the local level I want to
maintain trust with everybody in my
community I want to make sure that when
somebody's a victim of a crime that they
feel comfortable coming forward
in doing so that they're going to be
treated appropriately
thank you so much thank you
representative
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
chief for taking my question
um it's a two-part question the first
one is have you read the text of the
bill yes okay so to follow up with what
the the representative just asked where
specifically in the language of this
bill what line does it state that local
law enforcement shall
enforce federal law
I think it was
20.
no let me find it give me one minute
representative
I'm sorry what'd you say
what is it
28 what do you mean by 28.
I know I marked it here
give me one second
I think I'm missing a page
representative so I apologize
follow up that's why I have a different
text of it I apologize
um
she started line 27 no state government
entity local government entity or law
enforcement as you shall knowingly enact
issue adopt promulgate enforce permit
endorse maintain or have an infect a
sanctuary policy
that's my understanding of it maybe
perhaps I'm misinterpreting the language
um so I'm open to having that discussion
um
follow-ups follow up guys thank you Mr
chairman
um
I would agree that that's not what this
this language in the bill says okay this
has to do with
Sanctuary policy being adopted it has to
me nothing to do with enforcing federal
law but additionally I would like to
understand you you made some reference
to going out and asking immigration
status again of local law enforcement
you're saying that this bill would
require local law enforce enforcement
let's say a required but I kind of worry
about what's next
well we that's all
I understand the language of the bill
representative I get what you're saying
but I kind of worry about what's next
thank you sir but we need to focus on
what I agree with you the bill is I
agree with you so we're not confused
absolutely
one more question representative Kelly
go ahead
thank you um
thank you for taking the question
um kind of following up with
um this this language on 28 where I
previously asked about the per the the
fact that it has all of these um
um enact issue adopt pulmon great and
force permit I was focused on the permit
um language and then following up the
sanctuary policy
um defy or uh the policy on line 15
talks about how you might have a
practice or a custom
of
not uh
doing some cooperation
um and we talked a little bit about how
you may be understaffed or or different
municipalities within this state may be
understaffed and may have an Unwritten
practice of not creating an extra work
for themselves
um by by uh
quote unquote cooperating
um
do you think that this if you were under
staff that you might prioritize
some some other aspect of of the law
enforcement and not
um uh you know you may not have a
written policy that says we're not going
to do this anymore but for a certain
amount of time you may have a practice
of not doing that because of the
Staffing shortages and you might be
prioritizing other part of your duties
that could be applicable in many things
in law enforcement yes yeah thank you
very much I see I get your question
though thank you
of Representative priest
thank you Mr uh chairman and uh
thank you for taking my question yes sir
um I'm a resident of the city of
Manchester and have been for the last 20
years and I thank you for your service
um
does immigrants cause a problem in the
city of Manchester that you know of
people that look like me and look like
you cause problems in the city of
Manchester thank you all right
seeing no more questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
uh next uh
Eli Rivera
the right hand button
here we go there we go
sorry about that uh
good afternoon Mr chair my name is
Hillary Rivera and I'm the Cheshire
county sheriff and have been for so for
11 years and have over 34 years worth of
experience in law enforcement
the Senate has passed Senate Bill 132 FM
which states that no state government
entity local government entity or law
enforcement agency shall not only enact
issue adopt promulgate enforce permit
endorse maintain or have an effect any
Sanctuary policy
the bill also broadly defines a
sanctuary policy as any policy that
prohibits cooperating with the
enforcement of federal immigration law
but not limit including but not limited
eight USC 1373 with respect to a person
who has been detained
buy or is over in the custody of the
state county or local law enforcement
agents with suspect the violation of the
state law including enforcement arrest
warrant by the courts
this bill yeah
um runs counter to the recently
enshrined principle that New Hampshire
generally does not take orders from the
federal government for example on one
side of the cone New Hampshire RSA 159
E1 which was enacted last year prohibits
local law enforcement from using any
Personnel Finance resources to enforce
and Minister cooperate with any Law act
Rule of Order or regulation of the
United States government or executive
order of the president of the United
States that is inconsistent winning law
within this state when it deals for
firearms however on the other side of
the coin the Senate just passed house
bills 132. FM which mandates us to um
enforce Federal immigration and
enforcement immigration detainers which
immigration officials and case law clear
the fines as a request not a mandate by
the federal government
on the other hand the Senate wants to
mandate me to do something I'm not
federally mandated to do namely enforce
and comply with Federal immigration
detainers and on the other hand in
Firearms contacts the legislation wants
me to ignore federal law and not
cooperate with Federal enforcement
regardless of whether I am required by
law or not
you probably know about most New
Hampshire laws do not have a mandate
most New Hampshire laws do not mandate
an arrest or the attention of a person
who's this of a person for this holy
conduct it's assault theft sexual
assault Etc
these laws these are the laws of our
state
you allow us law enforcement throughout
the city of New Hampshire to have
discretion in the decision making we are
the ones out on the community and know
our residents the best
yeah legislation is passing bail reform
laws and minimize the holding of people
with criminal with serious criminal
records
some in the legislation wants us to
enforce immigration detainers not issued
by a judge
embedding this bill is another problem
in the harm that will the harm
that immigrants will fear whenever they
want to engage with local law
enforcement and fear of being deported
according to Jill
I'm sorry last year three minutes so
okay if you could wrap it up very
quickly please thank you absolutely
um 97 90 of the drugs are actually
coming through our legal ports of Entry
86 percent by American citizens is not
the person backpacking through our
borders trying to have a better life and
and fear for their own countries and I'm
looking for the lived American dream I
do have my testimony in writing so I'll
pass them along and have the complete of
it perfect thank you very much
representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman
um
Sheriff Rivera correct can you tell me
how fear of being deported
gives a removable alien a pass
for being in the country
illegally
fear of being deported gives an illegal
and how does an undocumented person
right I was using your word sir how is
fear you you mentioned fear of being
deported as a reason for not passing
this bill and I asked how does that
equate to allowing a removable alien
which is also in this bill
um
give them a free pass to be in our
country it's not a matter of a free free
pass it's um the matter of reporting
when they've been victims of crime when
um our own
um
contractors
um local folks take advantage of
undocumented folks for their own
benefits and and pleasure whether it's
to get lower bids on work on
construction sites because they're
exploiting undocumented workers it's
it's that what I'm talking about when a
victim of of domestic or an assault who
is an undocumented person will not go to
the police because they fear that the
transition going on we don't care about
your crime we need to know the portrait
because you're on the undocumented and
we're ignore the purpose of what they
came before the police
thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
seeing no more questions you're done oh
I didn't see your hand up I'm sorry I
didn't say it representative
thank you for taking my question do you
have an idea of how many
um deportations have occurred in your
county
in my County I don't have a number
representative yokella can you make your
question
brief no without statements please thank
you you know I can try
um
thank you for for uh taking the question
how about how do you
um I guess prioritize that this type of
work in your department are you do you
feel that this
um type of work is is generally done by
the local municipalities and not really
like outside of the scope of what you
normally would need to deal with and so
maybe you have a policy that says like
Hey we're going to let leave this to the
to the local municipalities and not be a
County
um issue or do you think that it is a
county issue when you you can and do
um
uh reach out to ice on a regular basis
thank you
um excuse me the policies that I have in
place comply with Federal current
federal regulations and that is that
it's a request not a mandate
if members of the federal government
came to me and said I'm sure if we need
some help we are going to um
take down the local restaurant because
we believe there's undocumented people
dishwashing
I'm gonna say
go for it but I'm not going to help you
with that if they tell me I'm sure if we
have a um level 3 criminal in the state
of New Hampshire in your county that's
wanted for murder or assault will be the
first one through the door to enforce
that
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman in your county
what percentage of the violent crimes
that are committed are committed by
people uh aliens or immigrants
a number doesn't come to me so that
means it's very low
or none
thank you very much for your testimony
okay we are now getting into
citizens discussing
please I'm going to ask again three
minutes please also keep your testimony
to the subject matter of the bill we've
heard about the drug trade we've heard
about that please keep your comments
specifically to
the sanctuary policies in New Hampshire
thank you first person we have is
Jennifer Smith from Pembroke
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm a retired medical
physician I've done Health projects in
three different Latin American countries
and three African countries all of which
have serious problems that if I
described to you you'd understand why
oftentimes people find that they need to
leave
and it can be very difficult to get into
this country
even if you've already got family here
legally so people do come in
undocumented I've also worked with a lot
of immigrants in practice
um in this state never knew who was
legal and who wasn't
but the point that has been made but I
want to re-emphasize is that creating a
situation where people who can't figure
out how to be here legally or know
people who don't have a way to do that
means that people will be very unlikely
to want to be involved with any law
enforcement unless that law enforcement
has made it clear to their Community
where there are mixed status families
and
non-family members but people who care
about each other
makes it very unlikely that even though
there's a serious crime going on that
they will try to get help
from law enforcement which makes us all
less safe
so I I really urge you to say this you
know this bill just doesn't
pass the sniff test for being important
to
keeping safety and it may in fact make
people less safe
because of that fear including people
who are here legally
but also people who have come because
they just have no other good
way
of getting out of very difficult
situations
so thank you
thank you for your testimony
um I'm going to once again remind
everybody this bill is about Sanctuary
policy
if you can please keep it believe that
was what I was talking about
further any questions
I see none thank you very much uh next
on our list uh we have Judith Reed
foreign
thank you very much
I'm a resident of Keene New Hampshire
um Judith Reed I strongly oppose the the
bill HB to 170 132
um and uh and uh it's I must I want to
speak to the bases for this bill
um as Joe Shapiro representative Shapiro
said
um the the bases are are are are
fallacious
um I've worked with others to assemble a
set of facts about immigrants
that are um stated in the uh document
that I'm passing around so I won't I
won't reiterate them but I will just
highlight a little bit of them
uh there the facts that I'm I'm
presenting to you are based on highly
credible sources
um which are listed on the back
um this bill flies in the face of those
facts
it's based on false fears that are
trumped up to satisfy political ends
hounding people who are seeking a
livable life in our state will not make
us safer and it will needlessly imperil
the well-being of hundreds of productive
well-meaning human beings I think is
that that point has been made very
strongly by the law enforcement
Representatives here
uh just briefly a few facts immigrants
accept jobs that employers can't find
U.S citizens to do that's a fact
it's a fact that they work hard and
spend money fueling the economy
that they start businesses that create
jobs again fueling the economy
it's a fact that in the aggregate they
pay more in taxes than they use in
services
in short they strengthen our country and
our state
and finally I'd like to point out that
unless your ancestors are from the
Abenaki Indian Nation we in this room
are all descended from immigrants most
of whom came here to work and often to
earn the funds to bring their family
members to join them
and I'm thankful that my ancestors were
able to do that
and I certainly would never regret
regrudge anybody else that opportunity
thank you very much
thank you any questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony next up we
have
Kathy Holmes
thank you I sent you email
um testimony mine had an elephant at the
top of the page trying to make the
capital Dome go back on the top
so we've heard a few people give the
same reasons oh I'm against I'm not I am
for this bill I've been hearing it so
much it gets I am for this bill
and
um we've been hearing many people use
the same excuses that we heard come out
of San Francisco in that Sanctuary City
and you know the City was destroyed now
New Hampshire our main industry is
tourism
if you're going to destroy let if you're
going to allow the cities to destroy
themselves they're taking the state with
them
and that man earlier was trying to
describe what the Swanton sector is in
The Epic Times who they have this
article on illegal image immigration
surges at the northern U.S border
that is 24
000 square miles including six six New
York counties all of Vermont and three
New Hampshire counties
it's it says a quiet crisis is unfolding
near the northern border
so
New Hampshire I'm so proud of the
senator and representatives that have
put this bill forward because it has
such Vision to protect New Hampshire
from destroying itself
and
this you can't see it but you many times
you've probably seen it where New
Hampshire stands out in all of the blue
around it they stand alone for
conservative and and right and I'm very
proud of them and I
hope you will
uh vote for this bill
thank you very much for your testimony
representative
thank Mr chairman thanks thank you for
taking the question
um do you think that this committee and
the House of Representatives should pass
legislation that tells communities what
they cannot can and cannot do
I believe this legislation is telling
the cities that they cannot do like San
Francisco did and declare themselves to
be a place to come for illegals and that
we will protect you
follow up go ahead representative thank
you
um
I remember our discussions previously
and I think you testified about housing
and not passing legislation that would
force municipalities to make rules
regarding housing
so that seems contradictory to me oh no
no when I testified before I was telling
you guys not to have the landlords pay
for the socialism that you were looking
for
thank you yeah
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
so this is saying that you can't uh have
a policy about not
um enforcing Federal
laws um regarding immigration
um and you support that do you think
that we should
um do you all do you support the
legislation from last uh term that said
that that we as a state are a sanctuary
state for
um gun policies Federal Gun policies
that we're not going to enforce the
um I've never heard that term
sanctuaries for where Sanctuary state
for gun policies Federal Gun policies so
I just wanted to
um to see if you are in favor of the I
think the federal isn't he supposed to
stick to the to the topic I mean we're
talking about saying Sanctuary cities
Sanctuary States it seems representative
for the moment
okay um just for a point of anybody
who's testifying you may accept
questions or you may not accept
questions if you don't want to take the
questions you don't have to and if you
don't know the answer or something
that's being asked of you just say I'm
not sure I don't know yeah and I've only
recently become involved
um in New Hampshire politics so uh last
year is I'm not a an expert on
thank you
are you done taking questions oh okay
no you're not done taking questions okay
yeah I'm done
sorry representative Gallagher
um next we have Andrew manaval
foreign
correct
no you are as honorable after you've
been a State Rep thank you for that
thank you chairman turcotte and members
of the committee my name is Andrew
manival I serve currently as the chair
of the select Board of the town of
Harrisville New Hampshire
in our 2017
town meeting we passed the article 9
which approved the following quote in
order to ensure that Harrisville is a
safe and welcoming Community to see if
the town will direct that its police
officers in the performance of their
routine duties in Harrisville will not
ask any person about his or her
immigration status and will refuse to
share information regarding any person
with the United States immigration
custom enforcement ice except in cases
involving allegations against such a
person of violent criminal activity or
of a violation of New Hampshire State
felony laws
the objective of this town policy is to
a reserve limited local law enforcement
resources to the functions properly
assigned to them B encourage not
discourage cooperation in law
enforcement efforts by victims Witnesses
and suspects of criminal activity C
serve the interests of economic
development in town D preserve our
diverse local cultural characteristics
and E avoid undermining or harming
familial and community relations
close quote our local municipalities
have the right to direct how their local
law enforcement resources are deployed
Harris Hill's legislative body our
citizens
exercises right in passing article 9.
we do not have sufficient resources
to assist federal agencies
with what are exclusively Federal
responsibilities we don't ask the FBI to
issue speeding tickets in our town and
we don't want to help the IRS detain tax
evaders for the subsequent arrest
nor do we consider it appropriate to
become involved with immigration
officials in the performance of their
duties
ice officials are authorized trained
deployed experienced and equipped to
perform their immigration law functions
our local police are none of those
things
we establish and budget
for local law enforcement requirements
without taking into account the needs of
federal agencies for enforcing federal
laws
Our Town police officers should not be
expected to assist federal law
enforcement in matters for which they
are neither prepared nor trained
we do not want to make law enforcement
harder for our local police passing SB
132 would do this victims of crimes
witness of crimes people knowledgeable
about illegal activities even suspects
of low-level offenses uh if they're
discouraged from interacting with or
communicating with police our criminal
investigations will suffer
even basic track traffic infections
could turn into dangerous chases
in addition municipalities have a right
to protect themselves against possible
Financial exposure to liability
regarding Fourth Amendment violations
municipalities could realistically have
such liability even for actions that may
have been thrust upon them by Ice agents
our towns and our police departments and
officers should not have to incur
additional exposure to lawsuits over
allegations with breach of federal
constitutional rights
as stated in our warrant article
Harrisville is a safe and welcoming town
I hope you all come and visit it
um we do have a very busy and small
Police Department
we view SB 132 as making our or if it
were passed would make our town less
safe less welcoming and also we would
not like the idea that our Express
self-determination regarding our
deployment of local law enforcement
activities would be from a top-down
across the board basis precluded as a
matter of
um a denial of self-determination in
this respect
that's bad public policy so I
respectfully request that you vote itl
on SB 132 and I'll take questions very
good thank you very much representative
Joe Kellum
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um is is it your under is your your
interpretation that the um the article
that was passed um does not comply with
this
um law if passed because it seems like
um The Sanctuary policy under article 7
would require that you prohibit
um cooperating with law enforcement uh
enforcement Federal immigration laws in
all circumstances and that that policy
seems to allow for some cooperation so
I'm just wondering if you believe that
it is it is compliant with this law or
would be
um in effect null and void or would it
be going to you know the courts to
decide thank you for that question
representative I I have read it as being
violative of our article which would
require its nullification I understand
your point I wouldn't want to have to
spend three years Liga gating at a
federal court on behalf of the town of
Harrisville and the expense and
diversion of resources that would take
but I hope you're right if you if in the
Assumption built into your question that
if in any way you are willing to help
Federal authorities as our article
expressly said we would do for example
in the case of any breach of a New
Hampshire felony law then certainly I
would appreciate that it could stand for
that purpose
thank you
good to see you again thank you thank
you
uh next up Christine Wellington
good afternoon
um
chairman turcott members of the
committee I will try to be extremely
brief I wanted to point out that first
of all that
most of the proponents testimony
scented and relied upon Southern border
scare tactics and much misinformation
I should say also before again I'm a
resident of Derry and I've been involved
with the New Hampshire immigrants rights
Network and worked on
researching this SB 132
we don't believe that the requirements
give communities and law enforcement
agencies discretion we think that it
requires uh
it sets policies that would undermine
fear and impartial policing policies
throughout the state a policy that's
also incorporated into the Attorney
General's law enforcement manual
um policies that direct
um particular law enforcement agencies
not to honor immigration detainers we
think it's not discretionary and it
would undermine many policies we also
think it has the ability to increase
racial and ethnic profiling and expose
law enforcement agencies and communities
to liability want to remind folks that
the status of being in the United States
without permission of the United States
government is not a crime it is a
federal civil infraction
and so that to ask um law enforcement
offices to start to enforce
civil federal law will raise many
problems in our opinion we also believe
that and I believe that the people of
New Hampshire do value diversity and do
recognize the value that
our ancestors and forebears and current
immigrants give to the state of New
Hampshire including be an important part
of our
um
our Workforce
um so we think that this legislation is
absolutely unnecessary for New Hampshire
for in in all ways and that the entire
committee vote to itl this Bill thank
you very much
thank you
seeing no questions thank you for your
testimony uh next up uh Bob Keating
Maybe
hello my name is Bob Keating thank you
for the opportunity to speak here today
uh I'm speaking uh in opposition to a
Senate Bill 132. I've been a long-term
resident 48 years in uh in Nashua and a
member of Granite State organizing
project which works to help create safer
and healthier communities I'm going to
make two points and part of it is going
to be assuring a personal story about
how I how I think this bill goes against
uh
um what hopefully is the purpose of it
to try to make a safer Community
First by by speaking about the sanctuary
policy here on page two beginning on 17.
I think we we've had the testimony
already by a police chief a sheriff
and a a town official ballot why they're
opposed to this particular bill so I I
want to elaborate but I think this is so
open for multiple interpretations and
the fear is that this will inhibit
people who are at risk or see other
people who are at risk to reaching out
and uh on doing something about it
and I want to do that by the the
personal story I was in Boston uh
um Monday for the marathon as I've been
it was my 60th anniversary of uh my
first time there as a kid when I ran it
this time I was watching it and I was in
Framingham and uh where my wife grew up
and it was so striking to the day when I
was there uh 60 years ago when there was
200 people uh and what I was struck by
we were standing next to the to the uh
the railroad station and it was a sign
electronic sign see something say
something there was dogs going back and
forth for smelling for for bombs ten
years earlier I was at Mile 25 race
walking the marathon when the marathon
for me stopped and for many other people
it had already stopped my wife was at
the finish line with my granddaughter
and right when the blondes went off a
friend who was a volunteer there at the
race suffered ear damage from the
concussion from the bombs it was because
of the kindness of strangers that many
people's lives were saved at that point
in time
and I suspect that many of you have had
opportunities where the kindness of
strangers has made a difference in their
lives I have in other places too I think
this bill whatever the purpose and I
believe the best intent here is really
an anti Good Samaritan purpose all of us
are in a situation to take risks to do
something that would make it more
difficult for safety for all of us
because this is not about immigrants
it's about all of us taking risks of
time to protect others so I would ask
for our strong relation to not pass this
thank you
thank you any questions you know
questions so I guess you're free to go
okay thank you next we have uh Eva
Castillo
good afternoon chairman and members of
the board my name is Eva Castillo I live
in Manchester I've been in New Hampshire
in Manchester since 1982. incidentally I
am a Manchester Police Commissioner
since
2011. ah mine was a couple years that I
stepped up and I'm back I'm not speaking
on behalf of the police commission but
just in case somebody finds out that I'm
there you'll accuse me of hiding
something
um
I'm an immigrant rights Advocate and
that's my job I've been doing this for
16 years as a job and before that I've
been doing it since I came to New
Hampshire
as part of my job is to build
relationships between police and
communities where we come from parts of
the world in I'm I come from Latin
America and I can tell you for certain
in most of Latin America if not all in
African countries in most of Asia police
are not honorable people police are
crooked they're a strong arm of the
totalitarian Communist governments they
are the ones that rape you they're the
ones that steal your money they are the
ones that commit crime so we grew up
fearing the police I remember my mom
always tell me stay the hell away from
the cops do not ask for help if they're
you know so we come here and this is
what we have in our hard drive stay away
from the police
so part of my job is go around talking
to the community to the Immigrant
Community about police work here is
totally different our police are
honorable trained people that will do
the right thing and at the same time I
go to the police departments and I build
relationships with all kinds of little
police departments and big and big
police departments so we
you know become
respectful and knowledgeable about one
another I am like a bridge I'm totally
fascinated by this job and I do many
networks just trying to build and try to
understand we're all members of the
community regardless of immigration
status incidentally I carry my U.S
passport card in my pocket I have it in
my because in 2005 we had really bad
instances of profiling and I know by if
I keep my mouth shut No One's Gonna
profile me but I don't want to go back
to those days where I feel the police I
don't want to go back and this bill is a
problem
you know it's going to be a problem for
all of us
for people that sound like me but it's
gonna open the doors to profiling it's
go we're going to go back 20 years of
work we have little departments and big
departments have bought adapted policies
that work for them in their own
municipalities
we take pride in Live Free or Die
we do not need to be micromanage each
department has adopted policies that
works for their own for their own
localities
so we need to just keep things the way
they are the Russians are not coming I
hear people reminding like of the movie
and it's almost comical but it's really
sad that today we still have to inflame
fear of people that are here just trying
to do the right thing so please if you
have any sense in your life just vote
this bill
itl because it it's a problem that we do
not have in New Hampshire
thank you thank you
seeing no questions
Louise Spencer
hi thank you Mr chairman for taking my
testimony thank you to members of the
committee my name is Louise Spencer I'm
from Concord New Hampshire I'm
co-founder of an all-volunteer
Grassroots advocacy organization called
Kent Street Coalition but I'm speaking
here on my own behalf
um I just want to tell a story
um that I think reflects on this bill
which is several years ago I was in a
parking lot and I was I got a little
distracted I backed out and I hit a car
my fault entirely
I jumped out of the car the other person
had a car full of
um
passengers and I went over to say oh my
gosh I'm so sorry is everyone all right
everyone was fine I offered to exchange
information possibly call the police so
we could so my insurance could pay so I
could take care of the damages
and the women
um who appeared to speak no English said
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no it's okay
um and
the look of Terror in her eyes will it
haunts me still
she was so afraid that I was going to
call the police
and it became clear to me that the
reason why she most likely was afraid
that the police would be called
because most likely either she or
someone in her car was undocumented
person
and so because of that she ended up with
a fairly significant amount of damage to
her car that ended up not getting
covered by me as it should have been
and when I think of the fear in her eyes
I can only imagine how much greater that
fear would have been
if the circumstances had even been more
um you know if it if this was someone in
a violent situation someone who had been
the victim of a violent crime and yet
still felt that either to protect
themselves or those around them that
they could not tap into the help and
resources that are there that should be
available to all of us without the fear
that that would lead to somebody
potentially being deported perhaps the
only Breadwinner in their family perhaps
a parent who would lose access to their
kids so the fear to me was
understandable
but heartbreaking
so that's my story and that's why I
would urge you to vote itl on this bill
we've heard today that it's unnecessary
the police in fact it interferes with
police
with good community policing so thank
you very much thank you
I see no questions thank you next step
we have now from a few agencies
Sarah Jane Noy
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to be here today and submit
testimony my name is Sarah Jane kenoy
you pronounce the k and I'm the director
of the Granite State organizing project
the granite state organizing project is
the state's largest faith-based
Grassroots organization working for
economic racial and Justice in New
Hampshire we bring people from various
Traditions across the state to share
Community concerns and advocate for
Positive Solutions our organization
frequently does what Ms Castillo
referred to we frequently help to build
relationships between traditionally
disenfranchised communities and the
government and public officials we've
brought together residents of public
housing and the police members of The
Immigrant community and the police and
so on
SB 132 and and we were very involved in
helping the Manchester police craft the
policy that Chief aldenberg referred to
today it was actually came out of a
discussion in the basement of a Catholic
Church in Manchester
and the stories that we heard at that
meeting were from immigrants both with
documents and without who told story
after Story of being stopped by the
police for walking down the street for
carrying a television for driving and
being asked in these completely
irrelevant situations whether or not
they were a documented immigrant as a
result of that the Manchester police
made a policy that they would not ask a
person's documentation status if the
interaction was not an interaction that
would lead to criminal charges that has
made all the difference in the world in
our community and it is a policy whether
or not it's a sanctuary policy might be
something that we could debate but my
fear about Senate Bill 132 is that
someone would decide this policy was a
sanctuary policy and the city would end
up in court and our immigrant neighbors
would suffer
sb-132 is a discriminatory and harmful
bill that would force New Hampshire
police departments to act as immigration
police it would destroy all the work
that many many many non-profit and
ethnic organizations around the state
have done to build positive
relationships between the police in our
communities
sb132 will not make our communities
safer but instead will make us all less
safe as people who may have friends or
family members or fellow congregants who
may not have legal documents at this
moment they may actually be eligible for
legal documents tomorrow but they may
not have them at this moment all of
those people will be afraid to call the
police to report crimes domestic
violence or other concerns this is not
just a bad idea this is a false solution
to a non-existent problem and I urge you
to vote sb-132 in expedient to legislate
thank you for your testimony
representative L Word
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm reviewing
um a recap of testimony in the Senate
and a Kevin Williams testified that
uh there are special visas for
undocumented aliens who cooperate with
the police
and that they're good for two years
during which time they can apply to
become a permanent resident do you know
that to be true or not I am not an
immigration lawyer and the immigration
law in this country is so complex that I
could answer yes I've heard of such a
thing or no I haven't but it would not
be a relevant answer to your question
thank you thank you
thank you for your testimony uh
uh next we have Grace and I don't know
if it's a silent k or hard K and I can't
I can't read the last name so
all right there we go or silent right
silent soft hard
all right so thank you thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for taking my testimony today my name is
Grace kinde hard K soft A's soft ease
um I am the program coordinator for the
American friends service committee which
is a 100 year old Quaker organization
focused on social justice and I am here
in opposition to sb132 and I urge the
committee to Market in expedient to
legislate
as our lawmakers I understand that it is
no easy task to balance both the intent
and the impact of the many bills that
come before you and I urge you to see
this bill as an attempt to solve a
problem that doesn't exist by pushing
the idea that New Hampshire has
Sanctuary cities it does not but it does
have welcoming policies in order to
ensure that the cities and towns that
make up our great state are places that
people want to come to to stay in and
invest in
so I think it's important to note as
well as what other people have said is
that this bill would void the hard work
that many municipalities including my
own municipality my own town hometown of
Manchester has taken to implement
policies ordinances
um and regulations that ensure that
every person in the community regardless
of their status regardless of where
they're from feel safe and has trust in
the law enforcement departments that
work to ensure that our communities are
safe and secure for everyone I myself am
an immigrant coming from the Democratic
Republic of Congo who grew up in
Manchester and has made the granite
state my home for over 30 years the
majority of the time has been as an
undocumented person and now as a U.S
citizen still a person
decisions from municipalities do take
the form of policies procedures and
rules and they are informed by input
from those communities I have the
immense privilege of being able to work
in multiple spaces across the state
spaces that include lawmakers such as
yourself Community leaders law
enforcement and everyday community
members I have sat on the Manchester
Police Department's comp stack Community
Advisory Group to support their work to
decrease gun crimes and incidences
involving young people in Manchester
our conversations were dominated by the
importance of building trust and Rapport
within the community in order to ensure
that this growing problem does not
continue and this bill would undermine
that work
today I was humbled to be in a space
with over 30 young people of color most
of them all of them actually high school
students from Manchester as well as
other local schools and they told me
their hopes their dreams as well as
heart-wrenching stories gut-wrenching
stories of issues and difficulties that
they experience at home and in their
personal lives issues of assault of rape
of domestic violence and ongoing abuse
things that they have to deal with every
single day
and these difficulties reflect the broad
range of problems and issues that too
many grandestators are experiencing
every day this bill would seek to
undermine those people's abilities might
our students our community members
ability to be able to go to law
enforcement and seek help and protection
we do not have Sanctuary cities in New
Hampshire we have policies that have
been created over many many years to
ensure that our communities are actually
places where people feel safe and secure
I have been part of those ongoing
efforts and I implore you all to also be
part of those efforts and vote itl on
this Bill thank you I'm happy to take
questions
thank you representative Edward
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
thank you for being here today I'll ask
you the same question about Mr Williams
testimony do you know it to be true
whether or not a special visas that are
good for two years
um are issued to
undocumented persons who cooperate with
the police and that they can then apply
to become a permanent resident so as
someone who has gone through the
immigration system and has been with
others we've also gone through the
immigration system whether a category
like that exists again I'm not I'm
myself I'm not an immigration lawyer but
those categories of whether a relief and
um categories where people can apply to
are very complex and the criteria to
whether or not you are would be eligible
for those specific categories really
depends on a many many factors which are
you have to look at on a case-by-case
basis though do those visas exist
possibly but do they apply to people all
the people who go and come and cooperate
with police no they don't because not
every single category that we have
within our immigration system as limited
as they are apply to everyone who would
possibly benefit them thank you very
much you're welcome representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question I'm seeking to get some
clarification about your statement that
we don't have any Sanctuary cities in
New Hampshire or or towns or whatever
and no Sanctuary policies as defined in
this in this um
but then you also made the statement
that it would that this legislation
would nullify some of the work that had
been done and so since this legislation
only nullifies Sanctuary policies I
don't understand how
um based on your interpretation how it
would nullify the the work that has been
done since there have been no Sanctuary
policies so I said there are no
Sanctuary cities
um so there's not a city in New
Hampshire that has said that we will
completely flout immigration policy in
any undocumented person all over the
country can come and live here there's
not a city that has done that I mean
municipality has done that however what
we do have is that we have policy we
have policies we have rules we have
regulations statutes some other folks
have shown come up here and given those
examples and under the the text of this
bill it up says that policies include a
broad range of procedures statutes all
sorts of things that towns have put into
place in order to ensure that their
cities and their municipalities are
welcoming
to all people
representative Cahill you look like you
had a question no I did thank you for
taking my question so has there been any
cities that tried to become Sanctuary
cities in New Hampshire so I don't live
in every city in New Hampshire so I have
no idea
any other questions
not seeing any thank you for your
testimony thank you so much next uh
Devin chafee
thank you
good morning chairman turcotte and other
honorable members of this committee for
the record my name is Devin chafee and I
am the executive director of the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire and I appreciate the
opportunity to be before you today to
testify in opposition to SB 132 and I
want to be clear that for in my point of
view that this bill clearly implicates
two core issues one is should New
Hampshire taxpayers be forced to pay to
do the job of the federal government and
civil immigration enforcement and two
will the legislature endanger New
Hampshire constitutional protections
against unwarranted detention and I just
want to dive straight into what has been
I think dominated a lot of the
conversation at this hearing about what
this bill does and doesn't prohibit
because I think you've heard a number of
Representatives certainly in the
beginning representing that this bill
is voluntary that it doesn't actually
require police departments to cooperate
and I want to say that in my reading of
the bill this is simply not the case and
I understand why it's difficult to to to
figure it out and I really appreciate
representative yokella trying to knit
together the different definitions in
this bill but to unders because to
understand how expansive it is you
really need to look at not only the
prohibition you need to look at the
definition of a sanctuary policy and you
need to look at a definition of policy
and how they all relate under this bill
I mean in some ways it's intuitive if
you are going to prohibit cities and
police departments from not cooperating
with Federal immigration enforcement
then you are requiring them to cooperate
that's that's not a very complicated
notion but this is affirmed by what is
an extremely expansive definition here
if you knit the language together again
this bill says that law enforcement
cannot knowingly enact issue adopt
promulgate and Forest permit endorse
maintain or have in in effect any rule
directed policy procedure regulation
motion order ordinance resolution
Amendment practice or custom written or
Unwritten and so this is a very
expansive definition of what is
prohibited and what is considered a
quote-unquote sanctuary policy so
essentially effectively under this bill
a lieutenant or a chief can't even have
a side conversation with their Police
Department about the fact that they
might not want to be prioritizing
cooperation with immigration because of
other resources under the language in
this bill
because if they did they would
potentially be engaging in creating a
quote-unquote prohibited policy that
would be in place under this legislation
and they would be at risk for violating
the law I do also want to point out that
there's nowhere in the definition of
sanctuary policy
in the bill it does not state that the
prohibition has to be total or in all
circumstances there's nothing in there
that says you have to prohibit
cooperation in all circumstances all
police departments in the state of New
Hampshire cooperate with immigration
enforcement in some circumstances but
this bill simply says any even Unwritten
practice or statement oral or written
that says that we will not be
cooperating with immigration enforcement
is is prohibited so it's a very very
broad prohibition and this is why law
enforcement such as the chief from
Manchester are so strongly against this
policy for those of you familiar with
the ACLU of New Hampshire you will know
that it is not that common that the ACLU
of New Hampshire and law enforcement
come together in in full agreement on
any given Bill and today I'm here to
hand out a letter from the police Chiefs
of Hudson Manchester Nashua Merrick
Hollis and Dover in addition to the
sheriffs from Stratford County and
Cheshire County
asking you to itl SB 132 because all of
them believe that this bill is going to
have a negative impact on the safety of
their communities and they believe that
it effectively robs the ability of local
communities to decide how to best use
their resources
I'm going to pass up okay and you are
Feeney that's four four and a half
minutes so I'm gonna stop you there I
will say thank you very much for
actually speaking to the subject matter
of the bill that was very good uh
representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman I just gotta I'm
over here man oh thank you that's okay
I'm just going to join a question for
you as executive director
um how many cases a year does your
office deal where you represent
undocumented uh individuals in the state
of New Hampshire they may be charged or
whatever
I would say that we I mean how many so
you're asking how many cases regarding
how many immigration related cases do we
take for undocumented individuals I I
would have to go back and check with my
office it's probably under 10. something
around that okay thank you
representative Edward
um can you confirm that
neither the police
the Chief of Police Association and the
sheriff's Association spoke uh in
opposition or support I haven't asked
the chiefs of Police Association what
their whether or not they're taking a
position on this bill I do know that
several independent police Chiefs are
concerned about the impact that this
bill will have on the safety of their
communities thank you
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um it seems like your your
interpretation of the law is a little
bit different than mine but
um the the uh would you
um talk a little bit about what your
interpretation is of cooperating because
um it is not really defined in here and
so the level of cooperation that is
required by this law seems to be
nebulous you could Define that
um you know if you cooperated in a case
every five years that may be cooperating
with law enforcement agencies or maybe
you have to cooperate on every case let
me can you speak to your interpretation
of that requirement for cooperation
thank you representative that's a very
good question and I think part of the
concern here is that I think what we're
seeing is that law enforcement entities
are are are not clear on what it means
to cooperate and I think there is
significant concern that any
um
any policy that might limit cooperation
with Federal immigration enforcement in
any way including like denying any
voluntary requests made by immigration
enforcement would be prohibited under
this statute I think that's the concern
here and I think that concern is very
reasonable
thank you
representative L word do you have a
question again
uh yes okay go ahead Mr chairman I do
um I'm looking at
um
Roman
seven Sanctuary policy definition and
I'm confused about
oh the last part of the last sentence
where it says
there can't be any policy prohibiting
cooperating within enforcement of
federal immigration laws with the
enforcement of the federal immigration
laws
including U.S 8 USC 1373
with respect to a person who has been
detained by or is already in lawful
custody of
the state County local law enforcement
agency for a suspected violation of a
state law to include enforcement of
arrest warrants issued by the courts
can you can you
help me understand how this mandates
mandates cooperating
with ice
I think that's what I'm trying to say
thank you thank you representative I do
think I I I will I think I understand
what you're trying to ask and I'm happy
to answer the question I think one
really important part of the the section
that you just read that is important to
remember is that it says including but
not limited to individuals that are
already in the custody of the police
right I see that and so what that means
is that anyone including people who have
committed no crime
or are not suspected of committing any
crime that they have to cooperate in
those circumstances as well it's very
clear that this law is not limited to
people who are already in the Detention
of law enforcement so it applies to the
innocent car passenger during a traffic
stop it applies to the person who
offered to interpret for the police in a
difficult situation and these are in the
most part we're talking about
enforcement of civil detainers civil
detainers are not a warrant right a
warrant for an arrest is approved by a
judge you have to have probable cause
when you're talking about a civil
immigration detainer that's one federal
agent that has signed that civil
detainer that we are talking about and
potentially putting New Hampshire law
enforcement in a place where they are
taking people into custody on the basis
of something one federal agent a
document one federal agent has signed
puts as a result really puts is is a
dangerous place to put New Hampshire law
enforcement in a place where they may be
be erroneously detaining even U.S
citizens because there have been a civil
immigration detainers issued against U.S
citizens in the past wrongfully into
custody
representative
Davis go ahead
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
are you aware of any successful
prosecution of an Unwritten policy
am I aware of people I I think one way
thank you representative for your
question I think one way that I would
think about that question is am I aware
that there have been prosecutions based
on what people have said or based on
practice under the law or violations of
the law that have been found and the
answer to that is is certainly yes
thank you
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um on the second page
um on line 27 the prohibition of
sanctuary policies
no state government entity no local
government entity or law enforcement
agent she shall knowingly enact issue
adopt promulgate enforce permit endorse
maintain or have any effect on the
sanctuary policy
besides law enforcement does this also
include other
Services uh that we provide locally and
in the state like education and health
care
and other social services would those
also be
rejected and denied these people and if
they asked for them
I think that's a very that thank you
representative for your question I think
that's a very valid point I think you
know we have certainly seen here
um that uh that the concern is is
largely by law enforcement agencies in
the state because they are our folks
that are dealing and trying to build
public build relationships within their
communities on a daily basis around
Public Safety but I think it is very
clear from the definition of a state
government entity that it would
potentially apply to the other entities
that you just listed representative
power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so I'm trying to
understand like the process and the
timeline
so a section on page two section seven
you know we've we've focused on this
quite a bit and it talks about
um
cooperation with law within the enforce
enforcement of federal immigration law
and it it also points to you know this
USC but it and it also goes on to just
to state that this with respect to a
person who is already in custody they're
they're presently being detained
or they're already in the lawful custody
of
so
with regard to the timeline and the
process so we have an individual that's
in the custom custody of local law
enforcement
already presently then with local law
then contact ice
representative thank you so much for
your question and I know that this you
know that the language is somewhat
confusing but again I I think it's
really important to be clear this is not
limited to people in law enforcement
custody it says including but not
limited to right in that section that
you just cited and what that means is
that this provision doesn't just apply
to people who have already been detained
by law enforcement that might be
scandals in the way thank you excuse me
I I understand that I understand this
two there's two scenarios here with my
question I thought was pretty clear is I
was setting up the scenario in which
there was an individual that was
presently in custody and I wanted to
understand how that would play out with
regards to cooperating
so with local law enforcement then
contact ice and say we have this
individual here there's there's a
retainer then what would happen and if
they didn't respond with the what would
happen then with regard to that Federal
um immigration law thank you thank you
representative and I am doing my best to
to answer your questions as you stated
them um I mean I think that the rep
representative the chief of the
Manchester Police Department did sort of
an adequate job of sort of explaining
what his Department would do if they had
somebody who they picked up and then
they found out that that individual had
a civil um a civil detainer
um uh or it that they were that they
were flagged in any way by immigration
by immigration enforcement I do also
though want to I think it's important at
the same time to recognize that this
would apply to for instance and this was
a client of ours an individual who had
been
actually just happened to be at a
convenience store when there was an
issue between a police you're going Way
Beyond the uh the question thank you
any uh
representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
if this bill would be enacted with the
governor's Council on diversity
inclusion be at risk of being in
violation of
this bill
um I I think if this work Bill were to
be passed there would be a number of
different government agencies that
uh well that's a good question that's a
very good question
um representative I'm thinking through
what the governor's Council the
different types of policies
um and um recommendations that the
governor Council uh has Pat the
governor's Council has passed and
certainly it would seem that they would
be recommending actions to be taken by
local governments that are contrary to
what is in this bill
seeing no more questions thank you very
much down to three more so next is
Margaret Burns
foreign
good afternoon I'm Margaret Burns I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here this afternoon in opposition to
Senate bill 132. Senate Bill 132 is an
override of local control local control
exists when local officials or voters in
communities make decisions about their
own policies and their own ordinances
Senate Bill 132 overrides that ability
to adopt policies in this particular
area by mandating what municipalities
are allowed to adopt or not adopt with
respect to local policies you've heard a
couple examples here this afternoon from
a couple different one from a town and
one from a city about why different
municipalities May adopt different
policies in this area and what the
benefit is of those policies to the
Greater Community including to the
overall safety of the community so I
will not go in depth on those arguments
this afternoon what I do want to take a
moment to point to is just some of the I
think technical issues with this bill
um assuming the committee were even
positioned to recommend the bill as
ought to pass which we are suggesting
you do not there are some outstanding
issues with the bill as written first of
all I know that the bill is amended from
the original version introduced in the
Senate but on page one starting at line
12 the term immigration detainer is
defined in the bill but it is not a term
used in the bill
um on page two local government entity
is very broadly defined as has been
previously discussed this afternoon it
is Broad to include
um any entity of the municipality not
just the police department or law
enforcement entity within a municipality
this is relevant because when you look
at lines 27 through 29 further down on
the page and consider the extent of the
Mandate on municipalities under
prohibition of sanctuary policies all of
the different entities within a
municipality are prohibited from
adopting Sanctuary policies this would
include under the terminology in our New
Hampshire statutes not just governing
bodies but also towns as in town
meetings the legislative bodies that
have the authority to act on behalf of
towns and which are used synonymously
with the term Town it is further deeply
concerning that the prohibition does not
only prohibit the adoption of policies
or the enactment of policies but it goes
so far as to prohibit the endorsement of
a policy and if we're looking at this as
a broad prohibition across an entire
municipality all departments all bodies
all boards we may even be talking about
an investigatable prohibition on a
member of a governing body endorsing the
idea of a policy and not even going so
far as to enact the policy equally
concerning the definition of policy
itself further up on the page lines 14
through 16 which would include even
emotion with respect to such a policy as
well as a practice or custom whether
written or Unwritten in conclusion one
thing that has not been brought up is
the complaint process it is is
concerning and of note that a complaint
against a municipality could be brought
by any person line 32 rather within the
municipality or even within the state as
I read it it further would allow the
filing of an anonymous complaint so this
is a complaint that could be
investigated and lead to a complaint and
and costs against a municipality that
would be anonymous and on the final page
page three lines 11 through 13 lines 11
through 12 would even allow for
attorneys fees and costs against a
municipality if the complaint is found
to be valid so for reasons based on
local control as well as technical
issues identified within the bill nhma
is opposed to Senate Bill 132 and asked
that the committee recommend the bill is
inexpedient to legislate
thank you very much for your testimony
uh representative Brown
yes thank you Mr chairman um as you know
I'm a freshman representative so maybe
you could help clarify a term for me
I've heard this a number of times since
I've been in the house but uh
the test testimony regarded uh local
control can you clarify that for me
because I thought that New Hampshire was
not a local control student
why don't we let okay thank you Margaret
thank you for the question she thinks
local controller thank you I would be
happy to New Hampshire is not a home
rule state which means that we do not
automatically inherent we do not
inherently vest all authority within
municipalities instead we are a local
control state where the state holds the
authority unless and until it delegates
the authority to municipalities and we
have a long tradition in New Hampshire
of the state delegating a wide variety
of authority to municipalities to act on
at the local level zoning is delegated
to municipalities law enforcement
welfare roads Bridges schools all of
these extremely large and significant
issues or or areas within New Hampshire
law have been delegated by the state to
municipalities and so that's the
difference between home rule versus
local control there are states where
municipalities inherently have authority
unless the state takes it away and that
is the opposite of what New Hampshire
has
and having listened to the definition
which was okay
um I will say that local control
um depending on the issue can be
somewhat subject uh subjective because
we've it's not it's not always uniformly
applied and I think even Margaret would
probably I could give some recent
examples of
where
it should have been many of the bills
that we've done in this committee on the
housing issues we've said local control
no mandates from the state but there
have been other issues where
that's not always applied the same way
you may
so I just want to make sure I understand
how this bill specifically undermines
local controller whether it really
should be local control or home rule or
okay thank you thank you municipalities
have the authority and ability and they
do make decisions at the local level
about how to prioritize resources as
well as how to direct their staff their
departments their agencies and they
adopt a variety of policies that reflect
those decisions about how they are going
to utilize resources and that is
something that they inherently have as
Authority and so this bill would take
away that ability and say well yes you
can make decisions about prioritizing
and deciding how to use your staff and
how to direct them but not in this area
we're going to override your local
decision making with respect to this
type of policy
representative color thank you thank you
for taking the question
um you just stated that this would um
prohibit essentially prioritizing
um one
um cooperating in XYZ circumstance or
not
um but my reading of this law does not
say that it prohibits
um prioritizing it only prohibits
prohibiting cooperating and so
um it seems to me that there still would
be local control to say we're going to
prioritize this
um and not per we're not going to
prioritize cooperating
um it's going to be you know the 50th
thing on the list that we prioritize and
therefore we are not prohibiting
cooperation we just may never get to it
that often is that the there's been
testimony here that says that believes
the interpretation is that this would
require cooperation every single time
and
um
and however but the law seems to State
you can only uh the the Restriction is
only for prohibiting any cooperation
would you would you um kind of expound
on your thoughts on whether or not
um
the prohibitation versus prioritization
sure as you as you know representative
we oppose all overrides on local control
I don't think I need to say that
um as for your question my concern is
with sort of your example of of
prioritizing and maybe we'll never get
to it you know maybe we'll never
cooperate maybe we'll never respond
um to to that the broad definition of
policy it it's so broad that even a
practice or a custom that it and that is
either written or Unwritten can lead to
an actionable complaint that the local
entity is in effect
exercising a policy that violates this
bill and that I think is part of what is
particularly dangerous about how broad
the language of this bill is
representative yokella thank you that's
exactly my point I think um if so you
could have these local agencies let's
say I don't know the school that has
essentially
zero times in the last 50 years of
cooperating with ice therefore maybe
statistically have a policy
Unwritten on
ever brought up by anyone saying that
they have a a sanctuary policy Sanctuary
policy because they've never actually
cooperated with ice
um so therefore by statistics they have
a policy
and could be taken action against in in
this interpretation possibly this is a
very broad this is very broad language
thank you
representative status
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um this bill it is not yet a law
um talks about
endorsements Unwritten policies
you know broad definitions of what
constitutes the divisions I mean
municipality in your view do you see any
abridgement of First Amendment rights
here when you're talking let's say I'm a
member of the Lebanon planning board and
I'm talking to a colleague and I say you
know I think Sanctuary cities aren't a
bad thing
could somebody Institute a complaint If
This Were
passed and became law could somebody
Institute a complaint against
me personally the city of Lebanon how
would that even work
governments do have the First Amendment
right to speak on their own behalf that
is that is part of the First Amendment
so I do think that there is a concern
there that you're raising the complaint
process I don't know if it would be
further established by the Attorney
General's office to be more than these
few paragraphs here in the bill but I do
think again that this broad language
that defines what it means to have a
sanctuary policy that refers even to
endorsing
um such a policy it's it's a concerning
um it's concerning with respect to open
and Free Speech in our local governments
so you know my questions thank you very
much
uh Suzanne Corby
thank you representative turcott and
committee uh my name is Suzanne Corby I
live in Manchester New Hampshire I am a
teacher of English two adult refugees
and immigrants I've been doing that for
about 20 years in Manchester
and I am also part of the mayor's
Multicultural advisory Council in
Manchester
and as a council we are opposed to
Senate bill 132. a bill that prohibits
any state or local government quote
unquote entity from establishing
Sanctuary policies which appear to be
very vaguely defined in this bill
it is our mission to promote full
integration of immigrant and
marginalized communities into the
greater Manchester committee Community
if this bill becomes law it will
negatively affect negatively impact our
mission in Manchester and the people of
Manchester
enforcing Federal immigration laws is
the responsibility of the Department of
Homeland Security of ice as a portion of
the Department of Homeland Security
Federal agency ice Ken and does detain
people living in Manchester
who they believe to be of undocumented
status the Manchester police department
does not stand in the way of this
further the Manchester Police Department
willingly cooperates with Federal
authorities ice Department of Homeland
Security all federal
departments on criminal cases regardless
of whether suspects or native born
residents documented or undocumented
immigrants
however
if this bill becomes law the Manchester
Police Department could be and perhaps
it will be forced to determine the
immigration status of people they
apprehend and they will be or could be
forced to detain people as requested by
Ice that's the murkiness that we're
hearing about in this hearing
um the broad scope that people are
talking about
living a lot up to interpretation
to not do this if such an interpretation
would be make them guilty of acting on a
sanctuary policy the Manchester Police
Department along with interested
citizens
has worked hard to establish a
Cooperative relationship
with the Manchester Community especially
with the Inner City Community where many
immigrants live
it is a difficult
task and an ongoing challenge as many
immigrants come from countries where the
police cannot be trusted and are
understandably feared
here in Manchester the police are
working to overcome this fear and
distrust and if this bill passes I think
it would be a negative impact on the
city
can I add one thing
um um if it takes you less than 10
seconds okay Pittsburgh New Hampshire
many more
uh ice cars uh Vehicles up there in
Pittsburgh in the last couple of years
Pittsburgh local control of Pittsburgh
wants to cooperate with ice in any way
and I think they already do that's fine
very good questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
last pink card I have uh don McKinney
good afternoon it's been a long
afternoon I know I don't want to hold
you up I wasn't planning to testify I
just wanted to make sure a couple of
additional pieces of testimony were
provided by people who couldn't be here
I'm Don McKinney I'm the policy director
at New Hampshire legal assistance we are
opposed to SB 132
and I have the testimony of Bob Dunn
from the Diocese of Manchester that he
asked me to hand out and then also
there's a a letter of Municipal
officials who who all signed on who
wanted us to share it with you as well
okay
if you could just turn off that mic for
me thank you very much
all right
um on the blue sheet I have nine in
favor and nine opposed those who signed
up
and I thank everybody for oh on that we
will close the hearing on Senate Bill
132 f n
foreign
committee members
um just a heads up look as of right now
uh tentative it's not been put into uh
hard writing yet but looking at a May
10th as our probable exact day that's a
Wednesday
so that's tentative but probably will
end up being the day
so other than that
Wednesday is the May 10th
uh would be at 10 o'clock that's correct
we would have a caucus prior but again
tentative
all right everybody good have a good
night